foreign
[Music]
thank you
what's going on
talk to me let me know how the level
since I know the screen is frozen I know
that's gonna have to be worked out next
week but
um let me know how the levels is going
see if I'm sounding all right
if I turn myself
[Music]
what's going on pop now what's up man
side is good all right try to get better
back better yeah yeah I know I gotta
turn up a little bit part of it is me
but we gonna turn up
what's going on oh man Robert Kelly
gonna be an interesting show interesting
show you know saying Zach Riley what's
going on I am Mike what's up Danny
passion official what's up Lydia Master
what's going on deliverax what's going
on ghost fix it y'all was in here early
Thomas September sorcerer
if I love Tim the sauce
oh man Gerald back oh gee I saw the
video bro it's loose salute Mason what's
going on enforcement what's going on yo
appreciate it turn up a bit make sure
volume is right you know what I'm saying
we hold the court today I had to lie was
thoroughly up Robert because my feeling
but no I'm not 100 still to address this
thing a little bit more seriously
I will talk about that
how come it's only gave us a state of oh
man oh man
yo messy messy
we're going to talk about it we're gonna
talk about we got some uh cool
announcements and things some guests we
got a patreon guest we have some special
guests as everybody gonna come through
soon again good to see y'all and uh yeah
I know there's gonna be some messiness I
know there's gonna be some messiness but
uh yeah I will be back and uh we're
gonna get this thing going
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all too Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
arson up in the apartment they call it
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rain you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you man
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
foreign
welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is the Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got you
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Snapple and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
yeah
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rain you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter social or
my city but I'm still in my Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
foreign
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all the
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
a Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start it regardless messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but a man time social or my CD
but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they wanna compare me to Freddie
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and snapping and making it flammable
this is that this is that Yoga Fire
Flame they think it's arson up in the
apartment they call a department and I
get the blame still I'll be running
collecting them rain you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start with regardless back when you
was messaging people on AIM check my
vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it uh
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating it
[Music]
detrimental to an elemental was an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be me
though I know it's my destiny work to
carnido who cares if he fly if you steal
a mosquito you swear you ain't nothing
but really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if he really was that dude King
David still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this and you're cubicle on the Lord day
[Music]
three radio
we're switching over bikes are hot let's
do some uh mic checks right quick uh see
how we are doing uh Lord Derek let's
just see how you sign them right now
check one check two yeah yeah yeah
that's what I'm talking about solve
what's going on hello what's going here
we go there's the smooth one attic the
young wolf how we doing this is a muted
not now no I had muted in the beginning
because I ain't gonna put Lord there in
business he was talking some stuff and I
was like I'm gonna wait until he
finished that
yeah
in the panel yeah something come up he
he couldn't make it uh but we we have
some some stuff that he made to give you
guys yes we do guys we have some some
special guests from
potential appearances special guest from
King and we have actual special guest
guys and we do have actual special
guests so special guest from his
multiple personalities
look man so don't give up on us just yet
I know it's the other dudes don't give
up just yet is iop's other dudes you
know B team or whatever they want to
call it you know what I'm saying but
we're coming through sorry so Mike
checks are good no doubt no doubt here
you hear ye and we are live welcome to
the island launch podcast LLC and also
live on lordsofgaming.net episode number
306. it's another glorious Sunday we're
back at the round table on the Lord's
date I'm extremely excited about our
patreon guest and we've got the
PlayStation showcase aftermath
Bungie's impact impact on Last of Us
factions and Alan Wake 2 digital to
discuss so we gonna get right into it
I want to introduce a lord whose passion
for OG gaming and Teslas eventually
drove his career into one of the most
impressive self-made I.T architects in
the game
introducing they're creating host of the
Tesla tidbits podcast and one of iop's
most loyal members of The Realm the Lord
of infosec and hot Sports takes who
properly wraps that red and gold 49ers
every football Sunday
live from Ohio and making his debut into
the realm of the Lords my man Lord
daring one how are we doing sir
I'm doing great although you gave me my
the Niners cred and I'm wearing my
drowns we're gonna talk about that other
team that you loyal to do through proxy
we ain't gonna talk about that but I'm
just joking I gotta wrap the home team
and then I got my other team because my
home team ain't never done anything yeah
so we gotta talk about that real quick
how does that work like like do do the
Browns fans except you for this this
Duality
everyone knows in my in my crew it's
it's Brown's first no doubt but I grew
up watching the Niners I watched you
know grew up watching Montana and rice
and Craig and lot and and those guys and
you know how could you not like just
gravitate to those guys so that's where
I got my 49ers uh influence and stuff
with it even through the dark times here
in the early 2000s there no doubt I
respect that I respect this will be
talking in the pre pregame pre-show you
know what you've been playing would you
got to see you got a shirt that man be
uh indicated well I got two things I'm
playing first yeah I am playing tears in
my childhood otherwise known as tears of
the Kingdom because
um
yeah it ain't it for me oh no no and I
didn't like uh so let me let me let's
let me back it up here's the kingdom and
breath of the wild are very good games
but for me and I think Sav is with me on
this oh objectively the worst Zelda
games
I'm diametrically opposed to you
I'm playing a lot of tears of kingdom
and like turn the corner it's coming
down oh the longer I play it because
it's like look it's a great game like
don't get me wrong but it's the same
thing I feel about tears of the Kingdom
where it feels like I'm literally doing
exactly what I did in breath of the wild
go here do a mission get someone go here
do a mission get someone sure chores of
the Kingdom one and then everyone
combines and fights the last boss like
they literally feels like the temples
there are no temples where are they at
oh man oh Forte my mess boot this guy yo
here's the deal okay we we got some Keen
Clips all right guys now I promise King
snitched the whole thing no no but but
no see here's the thing we doing the
we're doing this by likes okay oh okay
okay
negotiated he feels like you got to know
you guys holding a lot so he wants to
see them likes up to over to what's the
first one so 200 200 the first king
yeah well I did want to get one one
thing real quick if I wanted to play
Banjo-Kazooie nuts and bolts I would go
play bandage
wow my tears of the Kingdom take okay um
but yeah my other my other uh Mr Maddie
plays will be proud I'm in my Persona 3
uh bag
um I've been playing that for a while
um you know
you know wife and three kids I only get
to play an hour or two at a time I'm 64
hours deep in that so that's my two
games right now yo rousky coming at you
guys he said oh hell no attic holding
King clips for ransom
stop holding the likes for hostage
all right now see here's the thing okay
like
it's it's it's on it's on Brandy King is
the general he wants to know his
soldiers are ready Are y'all hold it
alive
shout out to the house so he supports
the idea yo Brickhouse actually we
should hold the line and not like
yo that was wild anyway moving on but I
hear that's good to hear what you
playing it's definitely gonna get into
the show you know what I'm saying we
already know we got the well we don't
have the full husband unfortunately we
have the three Horsemen but we got my
co-host to co-host
the difficult game conquer a lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
Lord addict of the attic show how we
doing sir
I'm doing pretty good you know uh to
clarify a little bit when it comes to
Zelda Zelda clears the game is still an
amazing game so a fun game I still enjoy
it a lot uh but it's exactly how I felt
by breath of the wild cheers of the king
is probably gonna be my game of the year
because the adventure that gave me the
the Bland canvas they give me they feel
like I could do anything I want but at
the same time
it's not the best Zelda game so you
agree with Darren he basically yeah you
you and Gary the same pocket from OG
stuff anything else sir she been playing
uh that's about all I've been playing a
lot of that I popped on Destiny for like
a whole 15 seconds to grab the oh the uh
the the auto rifle okay season thing and
then I pop right off okay okay all right
salute for you for attempting and of
course we have almost technical gaming
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single play a selfish experience and
also the sastradamus the Lord of clarity
and Lord patreon of the iron bank my man
PC Master races oh Lord Sovereign how we
doing sir
downloading is going well this week
downloading games but not playing that
loading and patching is going quite well
still no Zelda I heard there's a Zelda
game out yeah
the thing is solved is like
even though that I'm like I think it's
just the thing that stops me from
jumping straight into the Zelda pool is
like they'll be this massive scene all
this voice acting and then literally
right after that it's like I'm reading
1999. it's just like Nintendo you're
making a lot of money off these other
games now there's some voice actors
please it's the it's the Pokemon
tiny little carton they gotta fit all
that voice on yeah it could be
restrictions restrictions they are
limitations
[Laughter]
yeah so that that's pretty much I did
jump into a little bit of a Jedi
Survivor uh there's always some kind of
patch going on for it but it's running
beautifully now uh that when I got out
finally got out to the open world
sections and it's like yeah yeah City
games
so far I'm rocking with uh you know
classic single lightsaber dual wheeled
lightsaber too I'm not I'm not really
the Darth Maul sort of oh you don't like
that it's cool it's cool but I like to
rock with the two lightsabers separately
and then in the solo the classic I like
how they introduce all the the
lightsabers like they do a really good
job like look like you might want to use
this for this particular moment no doubt
is it sir yeah I didn't really get to
mess with anything else or actually so I
since I can't play uh I don't oh I
haven't got my TV yet Oh I thought you
had to do it that's good oh man they
keep every time I call them they're like
because the calibrator's name this is
he's a famous calibrator he is because
he's on YouTube whatever wait wait you
got Vincent how no now this is
damn I got you know the dude that goes
on with fomo sometimes the older the
older man yes like he owns the store
called value Electronics up in Scarsdale
okay so they have their calibrator is a
dude called D nice
you got D dice
you know they have a number of TVs to
calibrate to it you know mine was
whatever on the list right that's good
people are ridiculous in the chat
they're saying they are there
yo the channel
super chats are so lit today we're
getting crazy crazy yeah so I'm waiting
on my TV I'm supposed to I got a call
tomorrow to make sure that D nice is
working on my team so I can have it by
next week but yeah I thought I was gonna
be playing around with the TV this
weekend
I thought I was balling in my setup in
the basement until until I heard your
stuff
King is part of that new iron Lords
podcast battle pad yo they said we doing
battle passes
I like that
King's like Uncle make videos he made
like 10 videos
he wanted to be part of the podcast
so he actually the first ones we
couldn't use because of the the the what
should we call it the way that he
recorded them he did them again he did
them again but it is what it is yeah we
had to pick the best of kid because he
really really wanted to make this show
and trust me if you know King you you
definitely want to beat it all bad guy
oh this is crazy so obviously that's it
sir that's it let's move on let's move
on let's move on quickly the ghost of
Kings coming and of course we have the
gaming ninja himself this shinovi Lord
Cognito spreading really to the Roman
IOP not telling me what you want to hear
but what you need to hear shout out to
my man's Mr Maddie play used to finally
do go check that out we had our raw
reactions to the PlayStation showcase
you know we got that in talk about
what's going on there shout out to all
the last World ebontist I got Travis
talking about that Dusty that new season
of The Deep what's going on there a lot
of interesting stuff obviously uh
Bungie's new IP marathon and how they're
doing um as far as me shout out to
everybody who um you know sent me some
love this week obviously for about a
week so that's my brothers know I've
been battling something it's been it's
not been fun you know what I mean so I'm
just trying to power through but I
appreciate the love that everyone sent
me you know on Twitter and behind the
scenes LSM Community salute for real
y'all y'all help me down y'all made a
brother feel good you know what I'm
saying so hopefully I'm gonna get some
clarity on this situation soon and once
I get some definitive answers I'll let
y'all know but yeah I'm still kind of
battling and working through it but
there was no way we're going we're gonna
lose King and we're gonna lose me this
thing no no no no no okay we're gonna
we're gonna definitely power through for
the realm but salute to y'all y'all made
me feel good
um yeah as far as me the few times I got
to play by battling sickness oh planning
of Lana y'all get on it get on that man
game pass the thing is absolutely
beautiful stunning download I didn't see
it yeah yeah just put a search um it is
it is gorgeous the art style is amazing
you know you know Cog loves his little
um inside kind of games 2D scrolling I
mean this thing is hand-drawn beautiful
art style you know very dark and early
like it starts off playful and happy and
yeah the alien race but it gets dark
quick and these these aliens is out here
abducting people they don't care about
[__] they are harvesting humans and that
you better do something so all I'll say
is you know you get to a point where you
you meet another character which would
be your companion character called mui
this is the most adorable little thing
I've ever seen it is an amazing
adventure where you guys work together
with platforming stuff like that not too
long maybe four or five hours tops but
I'm telling you the music that set
pieces is absolutely amazing y'all on
gay but I want to hear y'all better
download this game then support this the
loving care that they put into this game
is amazing salute to them I believe it's
um Wishful games I think it's them
switchfully but yeah go check them out
man it is it is amazing you know what it
is man you gotta download that game and
hold the line yeah
talking all this ain't no games or
whatever yo this gangs go play that
planet Alana so I've been doing that
um salute to my man Luke Bernard I
believe Colin had him on before uh he
made his little game that dropped this
week called light in the darkness and
it's a good good little story about
little boy educational about the
Holocaust is real y'all it's real oh
yeah he he came out like I said it guys
it has some little issues here and there
I'm not gonna say it's perfect you know
saying but I will say like the way
they're telling it from the perspective
of a young boy and his fan family is
really hard women to let people know how
this time period was at you know at
what's going on before after the whole
bit go check that and also no excuse
PlayStation fan free on PlayStation
free currently right now free so go
check that support my man is called a
light in the darkness go support my man
on that and then a little bit of Destiny
when I have some chairs and uh yes um I
think we got some things you need to
take care of us I'm gonna read the Super
Chat all right
to the other stuff hey [__] that uh
light in the darkness that that taking
us on a field trip no it's not Museum
like where it's like hey deals trip oh
oh field I thought you said okay I
thought you said field okay no no no it
is yeah it definitely feels this is
definitely feels you could first of all
the art style is just it's hand-drawn
you know and you can even tell by the
way they did the eyes and so it's very
saddening of the characters you can tell
they're going through stuff so yeah I
it's definitely a field trip not perfect
but definitely highly recommended all
right
Robert Kelly Two Dollar Super Chat hyper
King to say how right he is
you will hear from him you're you're
definitely hearing it yeah Robert Kelly
once again five dollar Super Chat so
nice of Sony to show us quality Game
Pass Indies during this game
just starting early I see okay I'm
giving us bungee games too was a great
bonus video
then we got zip Davis five dollars for
chat I held the line for over four hours
and refused to call a doctor oh wait
yeah don't do that don't do that
don't do that don't be don't be caught
don't go to the damn doctor
then we got Gerald Mack member for two
years five dollars for chat all hail the
IOP salute the Lord shout out to Lord
Kingston Thomas 98 right is a real thing
hashtag hold the
um
this is probably the biggest thing I'll
have to actually give him this is
greatest he's he's becoming the face of
Xbox it's not even a good question oh
Lydia Master thank you it's Thunder full
games that made planet of Lana thank you
thank you
and we have Marvin ginyard two dollar
Super Chat let's preserve the Jim Ryan
dancing clown fish okay no no no I
already thought of this up the what I
was gonna suggest is our our uh uh
animal of the day is the Peruvian honey
badger we're gonna say the Peruvian
honey badger oh he a fan I like I like
that there it is a little idiot okay so
to Peruvian just just just uh just
listen we might be saving another animal
today oh okay okay okay there we go
continue then we have mass hole 1977 two
dollars
Celtics is seven yo y'all did that I
could never see y'all coming back from
3-0 bro Celtic Nation shout out to my
man Dom a lot of my Celtic fans that I
know who get who get wrapped them hard
yo y'all looking good
I don't know what happened I don't know
I went to sleep after you know thrill I
was like yeah it's gonna be over then I
was like what it's tied up
absolutely they were they would Eclipse
my calves come back 3-1 on on the dubs
yeah if they can pull this off I can
pull it off absolutely oh man it's like
a Yankees Red Sox yeah it's a type of
energy going on in Boston salute
and we got the man who got them horns
remember for 30 months Lord bronze
showing some love hashtag keep pushing
that powder hashtag Hold the Line powder
yo go right now um there's a sale for 35
off you know what I'm saying I believe
it's mem 35 but uh stay tuned we got
more iron more sales too if y'all won't
wait
you know
there we got Robert kellett once again
two dollars Super Chat damn can we kick
Lord daring out or daring one out now oh
yeah
slander was not gonna be popular but
you're welcome here anytime
if there's anything I'm an expert at is
fighting this chat
I got the first one yeah I got the first
one no doubt there we got Nintendo the
otaku two dollars Super Chat missing
content at launch delay the show
we gotta launching complete oh
Nintendo Taco once again two dollar
Super Chat and they're cutting content
to sell for like
I don't know what to talk about uh
then we got Tom from Toonami two dollars
chat IOP turning into s-i-e with
charging for Content
then we have the king of chickens with
two with the two pound super chat I cut
my internet cable while I moved my oh no
what he did I cut my internet cable
while mowing the lawn today oh oh no bro
shout out to you for coming I'm guessing
you're on the phone
I don't wish that on nobody ain't
nothing ain't nothing some duct tape
can't fix it I mean he's getting that
good internet after that duct tape
though continues then we have a little
kaibotsu iot member for one year five
dollar Super Chat and I thought I used
to be the king of back alley deals bro
I guess you talk about all this
shiestiness we're doing with the King
Kai was Notorious for uh you know when
we went to uh get our systems
yes we would we would go into just this
guy you owe me bro you had us going into
some wild projects you had me at Queens
one time with some wild projects you got
me you had me Yo God could have got us
killed a lot of times
Fearless when it comes to Tech and games
and modifications are getting over that
man gonna find a a plug and a connect
and have you follow him somewhere
I remember the drug deals going down bro
they're waiting for our
consoles living ready oh he said some
things ain't worth a modded PlayStation
he said nah he said I'm talking about
the D dice calibration that's what he
told me
okay okay but Kyle we know about you bro
you was in them streets a little too
crazy with that yeah
you know why I'm here bring on King
messiness you you will still get killed
you will still get some awesome promise
we have Robert kellett two dollar Super
Chat you need Game Pass ultimate to get
King contest you weighed that you wait
at the highest tier yet yeah yeah I just
made the first
then we got Tim per 21 remember for six
months he gifted 10 IOP memberships
thank you put the crust in the chat for
temper 21. oh it's going off I was like
what's going on then we got Tyson Lewis
as well one year remember for one year
gifted five IOP memberships put the
Crescent attack for Tyson Lewis
salute Roski I ain't snitching because
the statutes of limitations is over on
the modded console so stop so stop doing
that calling me no snitches over there
there we have let me see Astro parrot
King two dollars Super Chat King versus
God of War Ragnarok they are the same
DLC
damn then we have Robert Kelly two
dollars for chat Mew joins 808 as
Microsoft mascot please I
we got those we got those 15 new members
you know put some hold the lines in the
IOP logos in the chat with another
content we're gonna hold from them until
they get there
we just got two two clips from King man
we already met the first we met the
first you know you know what's funny uh
I'm gonna I'm just we'll we'll give you
both of them because at this point you
guys hit that 200 pretty fast I was
gonna say three but by the time we hit
that we're gonna hit three so you'll see
both of them to be honest with you I I I
was just trolling some likes it wasn't
you
here we go free on Kelly five dollars to
protect King couldn't be on this episode
because Sony watched Xbox with that
showcase we said Sony watched Xbox with
that I guess with their tears with with
the tears
a little bit
let me see
damn okay
or the legend two dollar Super Chat Xbox
showcase is being shown in movie
theaters yes that is correct that is
correct okay I got an email for tickets
that ain't happening
Tyson Lewis once again ten dollars Xbox
Please show something great at the show
because we are out here holding the line
like Spider-Man slowing down the train
slow down oh yeah speaking of that Cog
uh all right never mind we'll talk about
that after the show no doubt and we got
Nintendo on the otaku five dollar Super
Chat remember I was saying the
PlayStation show was gonna be mid from
the start I apologize for being so wrong
even I couldn't expect it would be pure
trash
wow wow wow wow I knew this chat was
going to be special coming into this
yeah you know this you know how the room
too yeah we have Max arthane two pounds
Super Chat showcases without a live
audience zaps the energy yeah you're
right you're right yeah it's a different
vibe when you're in there and we have
Spartan 661 two dollar Super Chat we are
holding the line yes you are no you guys
are definitely holding the line oh it
definitely holds two more of you need to
join the line
then we have Corey Tidwell ten dollar
Super Chat IOP Studios apologies to our
IOP listeners unexpected circumstances
prevented King from joining us today we
strive to provide quality content we
promise to do better stay tuned
it sounds like a certain uh statement
that was put out this week
the pony hey station has no games no
what happened the pairs are lining up
but they're prancing around lost in the
desert with no games
see you soon brother very messy very
messy very messy oh yeah that's right
he's going to be in LA with them
then we have Max arthay again two pound
Super Chat IOP selling a director's cut
with King content yeah
then we have Robert Kelly 2002 attack
will King be DLC for Tekken he already
had second he attacking what's up man
the Grand Master of drip King was it if
King was in a fighting game what kind of
fight techniques would he use would it
be a boxer or whatever definitely boxing
what's that what's that box what's that
fighting thing where you dance what's
that called
well I wish to be a favorite character
yeah
shout out to the Brian Fury video I only
saw it this morning [__] I didn't
realize what you sent me I was like yeah
I was like yo they tekking themselves
messed up the Instagram leaked the damn
trailer for Ryan Fury I had before they
was ready harada was Fury
you know the fan stat set up recorded it
threw it all up on it it's like too late
we got it too late we got it yeah yeah
looking crazy
yeah yeah we got let me see who we got
we got Jose Cuervo 45.
[Laughter]
that would have been awful
awful
stuff
here's how I probably would have said it
saudulia's oh time on attic or Spanish
let's go
okay then we got Robert Kelly Two
Dollars Super Chat Insomniac holding the
line for PlayStation truce
now for sure
and we got nerdy meat head five dollars
excuse me did anybody else hear Jim Ryan
say at the end of the Showcase I want to
surprise and Delight our fans
Jim Rachel yes he did
surprise surprise and Delight addict
speaks Spanish like Bloomberg you know
they stupid yeah they stupid leave my
man alone he's having fun continue then
we got void lock five dollar Super Chat
Sony got the Dollar Tree soap using the
bottle to clean one pot Tony got a
controller and have it put it on the
tablet
we would discuss yeah I like that joke
then we have Max arthay again two pounds
Super Chat Jim lion crying taking these
earphones Ryan wow
we will discuss that so what else we got
going on all right give me a moment here
okay so that's it for Super Chat
I'm gonna jump into the the other
business yeah what's going on everybody
be quiet while this is going on too
I just want to say something about
patreon before you read that like I know
I've been like lacking on the reactions
for patreon I've just been going through
a lot but I I did record like a giant
amount of Demon Slayer reactions and
that would be going up tomorrow I'll
probably give you guys like three
tomorrow to be honest with you to make
up for for the uh for the lack of
content so I'm going to grab the two
that just came through I could grab
those yeah all right
I got them okay give me a second we have
multiple X gone X Dawn the otaku five
dollar Super Chat in celebration of
PlayStation give me Xbox a w and Xbox's
upcoming showcase that will be amazing I
am now bought wow I'm confused if that's
like the actual Don the attacker or is
it like his oh yeah so one is clowning
him yeah we don't know
if your account has been compromised
compromised or being mocked be
impersonated please let us know maybe
have akw 10 pound Super Chat King got me
in the dog house with the wife we had an
argument about picking up the little one
from school and I told her to hold the
line and she told me to hold the line in
the dark let's
it's not gonna go well
then we got Stitch remember for 42
months Lord gold uh IPL just like IGN IG
IPL IOP just like IGN will not let
anyone talk bad about Sony after after
the for the street showcase the general
was going to tell the truth and shame
the devil but he is locked up right now
only kid keeps it real and like no one
else tells the truth
[Laughter]
absolutely
absolutely okay let's get into this
what's going on so what's happening
tonight
what is happening so
support for the iron Lords podcast is
brought to you by manscape who is the
best in men's below the waist grooming
their products of precision engineered
tools for your family jewels manscape's
performance package the ultimate men's
hygiene bundle joined over 8 million men
worldwide who trust manscape with this
exclusive offer for you 20 off and free
worldwide shipping with the code iron
Lords with an S at manscape.com my math
is correct that's about 16 million balls
so
the acorns the coin purse Deez Nuts
the Glizzy companions okay
the Family Jewels and the giggleberries
these are all colorful ways of saying
balls and for those of us who have balls
we know that maintaining that area down
below can be a little challenging
now for me and stop me if you've heard
this before on this podcast
I work a lot of damn hours and that
means that sometimes I come onto this
podcast looking like I jumped out of bed
and immediately got hit by a freight
train kind of like today
so
if you can assume that I didn't have
time to shave and quaff myself for
today's podcast or escape myself as it
were
it's probably safe to assume that uh
down below things aren't looking too
good either
and guess who that makes very very
unhappy
lady Saab
so yeah as I you know as I'm leaning my
head back in embarrassment and shame as
you know my significant other is telling
me
um yeah you're uh you have a little
overgrowth coming out of your boxers you
know uh you know how are we you know
it's it's not a fun thing for when your
significant other is telling you things
like that like oh I can't find it where
are they
it is one of those things that makes you
stop and think for a moment and say okay
I have to do something about this and
for me
uh I've tried going down below with a
regular set of Clippers and what you
quickly realize is that Clippers that
are made for your head
aren't necessarily made or down below
and uh I've had a few accidents
so again as I'm enduring my wife's uh
embarrassment I think to myself well
it's true
how else are we going to save the Puerto
Rican tropical trouser snake and it's
too little uh connects on the side
Harry cleared out the underbrush right
we have to clear out the underburst so
we can find the Puerto Rican trousers so
they in order to be able to save them
so like I said I was about to do
something that I was going to regret and
then then out of the blue out of the
blue out of nowhere
the performance package 4.0 arrived and
it is a game changer and it saved my
life let me tell you inside this package
you will find the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
the weed whacker ear and nose hair
trimmer for those of us that uh don't
understand the concept of your mustache
ends here and the rest of it should go
that would be me
The Croc preserver ball deodorant for
all those of us that have a swamp sack
which again I work a lot of hours uh
that's all I'll say about that and the
Croc reviver toner in addition to
Performance boxer briefs and a travel
bag to hold all of these goodies
now first off
the lone War 4.0 is the trimmer of the
future and dare I say it is the greatest
ball trimmer ever as someone who's used
a different product down there and then
went on to the to the to the lawnmower
4.0 I have to say that is quite true uh
yeah that it's A1 A1 their fourth
generation trimmer features a Cutting
Edge ceramic blade to reduce grooming
accidents thanks to their Advanced Skin
safe technology the lawnmower 4.0 is
waterproof and also has 4 000 LED
spotlights so that you need when you
need more Precision to shave eh don't
just the word of advice don't Trim in
the dark don't do that make sure you
have a lot of light on you it's it will
save you
because this trimmer is waterproof
you can say goodbye to the mess on the
bathroom floor you could do it in the
shower you thought that was good but you
want to take your grooming even further
to the next level the performance
package 4.0 also includes the weed
whacker nose hair and nose and ear hair
trimmer which I mentioned before the
weed whacker is also waterproof and
provides proprietary skin safe
technology which helps reduce Nicks
snags and tugs in those delicate nose
holes I definitely should know their
crop preserver ball deodorant and crop
reviver ball toner will change the way
you approach your hygiene routine trust
me when I say this fellas your balls
will thank you yes
they have thanked me multiple times
already trust me trust me so manscape
even threw in two free gifts to their
performance package 4.0 the manscape
boxers and the Shad travel bag bring
your comfort and boxes to another level
it's time to take care of yourself to go
to manscape.com and get 20 off plus free
shipping with code iron Lords that's 20
off and free shipping with the code iron
Lords at manscape.com that's 20 off with
free shipping at manscape.com and use
code iron Lords unlock your confidence
and always use the right tools for the
job with manscape
yes it feels so fresh and relaxed
I have it's so funny I mentioned it to
my wife yesterday she's like what are
you going to be talking about I'm like
oh nothing just you know General stuff
nothing she's like don't be mentioning
my name in these ads
she don't know about this one
luckily she doesn't
I'm like watching the chat for let's
play with each other this joysticks
they like where he's at
yeah one thing that I I do respect for
the chat is like I know a lot of
communities get upset with fed reads but
like our community they get it they like
we get it and plus we always gonna make
it we gonna make it make sense for us
we're gonna have fun we're the only
community that discusses the ad read
after the ad read it's hilarious but I
ain't gonna front though I did the um
also the nose hand trimming oh fire
listen did you get the performance
package that come with that yeah
those boxers
I've ever had yes yes listen you know us
like again obviously
we've been you know we've been trying to
get you know uh sponsors and stuff for
forever we're only going to mess with
things that we actually use and like
that's right you know that about us and
you know for us apart from apart from
Cog we're a bunch of hairy dudes
and this is no lie I have had to
relegate myself to using a regular set
of Clippers that you use for your head
down below in an emergency situation oh
that's crazy
salute to you for not doing the Lord's
work make sure y'all get your master
swords trimmed up
don't be looking like that decayed
Master at the beginning
exactly go support us go get get that 20
off codeine Lords Lincoln
spoiler alert man you might need that
energy to use that
we'll get today we're combining the
triforces of
is amazing my balls got a taper fade yo
overgrowth coming out of the boxes damn
hashtag footlong I meant thank you I
appreciate that but I actually met the
hair overgrowth
yeah they was killing you when it's like
you need to you couldn't find it or
something they was like oh man they was
killing you in the chat with that one
listen man oh Lord my turn 2010 lady SOB
I see the master sword too Ultra hand
top
yeah just I'm just grateful that my uh
my wife doesn't listen to the show yes
there we have Robert killing two dollars
Super Chat zombies joystick to escape
him no we don't we don't put that energy
out there
I think we're caught up I think that's
good all right no doubt I just got one
in from Raiden blade oh scroll down let
me just scroll down Raiden blade two
pounds Super Chat so IOP about that PS
showcase Lord Sav what happened we're
gonna
Delaware
gave report say five dollars in the chat
Bungie are The Pimps and first party all
the hoes whoa It's the assets right and
make my money and as always hey King
wait where's my boo-boo
yeah the tradition is broken I know I
know we're gonna make it we're gonna
make it up to y'all so look we I've got
all the bills thank you for being
patient uh we got a guest here Lord
daring man he's been really patient when
I was taking all all our business and
all that other good stuff so now we
finish with that we gotta switch our
Focus to him you know his video game
system history he's journey into it and
Teslas and of course what led him to
joining the realm of the Lords so Lord
Darren let's start from the very
beginning with some of the first video
game systems you had and what got you
into gaming
well what got me into gaming I gotta
shout out three people real quick before
this whole mess gets started let's go
let's go my mom my dad and my Aunt
Glenna are the three three people in my
life that I'm not gaming the way I'm
gaming today without them whether
whether they intended it or not oh wow
uh
good no no I did this was a Wilding of
the breaking of protocols that I have to
break for a quick second solve you need
to read the Super Chat oh no there we go
I am so sorry oh there it is
you you uh you will just dude
I'm not afraid to roam to the Jungle
yo he's on fire
I love it right we're never gonna find
out that that that's his wife yo his
timing is impeccable I I literally I
never break protocol to guess that was
wild crazy
apologies
back to you oh so yeah so you said Mom
Dad who's the third
how are they responsible for your game
in history sir
all right so we started off uh 2600 was
in the in in the house on the earliest
earliest days like my my dad and I
um we had two different football games
for that system
um I actually had to look this up
because I didn't I remember kind of what
the cartridges looked like but I just
know I was a kid it's like four at the
time it's like football but one was the
real Sports football and that was okay
but the other one was it kind of
reminded me of the EA carts on the
Genesis that had the yellow tabs because
it's all angular and kind of weird that
was uh super challenge football and that
was great because like you could
actually like you had your four guys
that you could give them the play and I
think that was the only one of those two
players if I remember right but my dad
and I we spent some time on those games
um one of the few things my dad and I uh
didn't have a super close relationship
growing up but that was one of the few
things we got the got to hang out and do
together absolutely salute that's what's
up so you started with 26 you don't say
the classic I think saw if you were more
of a 2600 guy right you had the 20s I
was a coleco guy yeah I played all of
those baseballs I think it was yeah real
sports baseball and just straight up
baseball right there's a couple of
different iterations of that it's funny
you said Real Sports because immediately
when he said Real Sports I I my mind
gravitated to Sports Talk baseball oh
yeah
yeah I had all of those cards because
Real Sports was one of the carts that
looked like a spaceship right it wasn't
a flat car it was a cart that it was no
that was the that was the super
challenge one the Cooper challenge yes
and super challenge as well we actually
got a guest that knows more of us this
stuff than Saul
oh my God
I have both baseballs though you're
right though oh no I'm still
fix your face
I
I can't uh can't leave out my mom though
too because I've watched her like just
own some cuber like oh you want to talk
about someone that was like a hardcore
gamer like she had a grid that said what
color everything turned to like what
level you were on like you had to change
in this color yeah the next level and it
was two colors and then they'd change
them back he had a grid of like 15 deep
that she was that good at it shout out
the ball so you talking like this is a
house a family of Gamers that this I've
never I'm not used to this you know what
I'm saying like that's that's dope
at least then okay my mom and my my dad
you know after the 2600 they were done
oh okay okay but I mean they still you
know engage and play that that's that's
dope gotta respect it but continue
but uh yeah so we can get to my my Aunt
Glenna because after the 2600
um you know my mom and I spent a lot of
time over my aunt's house and she had a
Commodore 64. all right and uh she had a
ton of games and
look she may have been sailing the high
scenes a little bit a few of those games
she had like 40 50 games she had this
huge like this system of disc A2
contains these games he had to flip
through it it was great okay
um but uh yeah she had uh a ton but like
there's like three different Olympic
Games this weird game called Congo Bongo
that I like
Bongo let's go look at that man I'm so
glad they stopped you'd be that UB
Congos Bongo in your life that's your
problem
the the Commodore 64 and I eventually
got one as a kid uh but the games I got
a shout out from there Jump Man Jump Man
yes Jump Man great game just stick it on
randomizer and do your best that's what
I always did impossible mission was
awesome I never could figure out because
I didn't have any instructions right
like what you were exactly supposed to
do I assume you're supposed to put that
map together but to this day I don't
know what you were supposed to do did
you ever play it on the possible mission
2 on the 7800 no no yeah
the 7800 they made it it was it was much
better like I remember looking at the
the commercials for that and being like
Oh man
did they have the voice on on the uh
Atari because like at the beginning of
the game we would say I bid you welcome
visitors stay a while stay forever I
don't remember if it did it had it it
was very crackly
you could barely understand it on the
c64 just to be clear that's true sorry
they had they they system refreshes
they're from there when you went from
commodore
so from there the weirdest thing
happened like out of nowhere one day my
dad had to go I think he had to meet
with his insurance agent and he had to
have me with him so I think he was
trying to like sell it to me like look I
don't want you acting up on this trip
well his the insurance Guy's daughter
had an NES and I at the time had never
even heard of it so but you better
believe by the time I left I was hooked
because we played Super Mario Brothers
and excitement for like two hours
and I was done and it was so bad like
look I'm I was as nerdy a kid as I am
now uh but knowing full well my parents
couldn't afford a nest I made a
cardboard box no it kind of look like an
ass and it had I made a little flip top
and I made little pieces of paper that I
stuck them in there and then me and my
friends would like pretend that we were
playing the games
absolute to to to to Innovation during
tough fighting
hi
good I remember uh I was playing
[__] old Pokemon Stadium game I think
it was like number one and uh I was in
Arizona and I remember like my N64
controller broke I remember watching
like the intro over and over again
those those cinematic battles that they
did to get you hyped into play in the
game that's like all I had so I like I
used to literally watch it over and over
and over again at the time I didn't know
like Mewtwo was in the game like that
he's like one of the legendary from gen
one I saw him in one of the trailers and
I'm like whoa whoa whoa whoa I never
played against him why is he on here
like damn it listen man it ties are hard
sometimes you just have to you have to
be you know get a little inventive so to
speak but continue continue Darren but
but I got made good uh because that
following Christmas uh my parents hooked
me up with the power set had the zapper
and the Power Pad
um that duck hunt you know what I'm
saying yeah and the world class track
meet
no doubt that was the Power Pad game you
had the Power Pad
yeah she gave me the whole thing oh yeah
now you're chilling you you now you
sounding very very I got a pocket watch
a little bit you sound very rich though
so I'm very rich because a lot of kids a
lot of kids they have that policy
usually you had we used to look at the
kids that was rich that had the gyro
bite one that had the robot yeah I never
had that and then most of our friends
had the basic one but that come with the
you know the Mario the duck hunt combo
but the power they blessed you sir
because that one that that could
continue
that Christmas was the Christmas of
Dreams because there there were two
things I asked for that Christmas and
only two I wanted a Nintendo and I
wanted a pair of Reebok Pumps
let's go shout out to Dominique Wilkins
and [__] that up continue I didn't think
I was gonna get either of those things
and I got both of them
um and then that was yeah that was the
Christmas of Dreams no doubt that's
um
do
you did anything it was just the idea
they probably hurt more ankles than
anything but she had to revive funds for
the greatest marketing scheme for
sneakers and everything so you got that
end on what you call
so like I said so we weren't we weren't
rich I have no idea how my parents put
that together uh but not that long after
that my talking about that my mom was
volunteered to take me taking you guys
back to Toys R Us to uh to get me a new
game to go along with it because Mario
duck hunting world class track meet last
me for a little while but then it was
kind of like all right what else do we
got here no doubt
um
so we're going into the store to buy
what was then a 40 game fiberman
remember right and that was nuts like to
just hey let's go buy a game but we get
there and there's the wall of tags oh
yes
you pick your your little slip they'll
go get you your game so I'm like sitting
there being super indecisive because
it's like the one game I'm gonna get for
like who knows how long and I'll never
forget this as long as I live but my mom
off the cuff goes well someone I work
with says this Zelda game is supposed to
be pretty good and
like the good little boy I was I
listened to my mama
uh gosh who was that that said that that
person was doing the Lord's world who
was that that said that to go don't
recommend that is someone in the store
who recommended that
for you to get the Zelda
for me or so no for you
it was my mom always Mom I'm sorry I
didn't hear that problem she said she
said uh someone I worked with said that
this is that's what I meant to say like
who was always okay got it okay yeah
yeah I had something similar but it was
the opposite I remember when Oblivion
came out and I remember trying to get my
Aunt Patty to buy it for me because it
was right at M so I couldn't buy it and
I remember her sitting there at the
counter and they're like okay let me
bite I I remember the dude just being so
extra for no reason oh you know what's
right to them right
I'm like shut your mouth up like this
has nothing at the time I couldn't buy
it but my mom was doing something she
would have bought it she wouldn't okay I
remember thinking this chick ain't go
buy this [__]
I'm like I want this game machine go buy
it and she just looked at that she's
like he ain't my kid
yo I don't care what I subject him to
now I understand the story but um like
wait the way he's paid in the Attic is
from like Toys R Us was like the mecca
for kids I've been to Toys R Us oh okay
so I didn't know if they had us actually
they uh I I they hosted like a lot of
Yu-Gi-Oh tournaments oh that's what's up
okay so you know about it so basically
the whole thing about like the games are
being in it but the tag and you take
that then you go to the little the caged
area with the guy I remember going to
Toys R Us or to play Twilight Princess
we went and bought it from Toys R Us to
play Twilight Princess yeah it was just
a whole game they used to guard those
games like it was Pharmaceuticals
it was literally that's a good example
it was literally a gaming Pharmacy see
like how it worked it's like you would
want you would win a Yu-Gi-Oh tournament
and they would give you credit in the
store you don't have to buy it on cars I
remember like winning a couple weeks and
just saving up credit because like
people hated when I did Yu-Gi-Oh yeah to
this day my friend John is like dude you
need to come back to you guys like dude
how many times I keep you out of the top
four like do you really want me back in
there and I remember like like
one time some dude like tried to you I
know this is off topic but he would try
to use a card that was fake it was an
Egyptian God card you're not supposed to
use them they're just purely for show at
the time they eventually remade them to
be realistic and he's like oh this does
this and this does that I'm like I I was
like I see your card just like that it
doesn't say none of that man just
because it's like that on the anime
doesn't mean you can use
because when you read the actual card it
just says it it's a it's a god this has
no effect fans you know what I said I
remember like winning like five or six
in a row just to buy like the the next
game that was coming out saluted Toys R
Us legendary shout out to um o x c o c o
c j he said fun facts you know that Toys
R Us is still big in Canada okay I
didn't know that but continue Lord David
we went off track for a little bit so
yeah get that Zelda you like oh man
see I was off and running then but uh so
that was the start of the the arrow but
the end of the era I never forget it
when I found out they're making the
Super Nintendo and being kind of like
with it as a kid I realized right away
oh no I ain't getting no more games for
this one so I like felt like absolutely
just
to betrayed that a new Nintendo was
coming out well you was mad
I was I was I was ticked
um I was like they ain't gonna make
anything more for what I'm not and I was
lucky to get what I got so there's like
how am I gonna get this next system
right was it that you got it towards the
end of the generation two or just in
general just the fact that it was coming
out
I think I kind of got it mid-gen because
we definitely didn't get it right away
okay
um because again I didn't even know it
existed one and two of my you know my
family I cannot imagine what work my
parents put in to make that Christmas
happen I feel better um
so I took matters into my own hands when
it came to that Super Nintendo then uh
so I did what any self-motivated kid in
the 80s would have done I got myself a
paper route let's go and hustled uh it
took me about three four months but I
walked into Woolworths this time well uh
it came out
came out with my Super Nintendo with
Super Mario World and
I was ah man like amazing game like that
game still holds up like just just go
play it it's it's it's phenomenal so
much Nintendo used it for hostage
classic man classical I love to hear it
yeah the grind in the story so you want
to be more Super Nintendo Joyce you was
rocking with
yeah in the Super Nintendo the first
game I got because they didn't have much
at the beginning uh I got me some Sim
City
um you know what a dork I am but I love
I love that game yeah I'm a big big
supporter of SimCity yeah
yeah and that got me to Link to the Past
came out and that
that I got so much mileage out of that
game I love that game so much we had a
house fire when I was like eight or nine
years old and we had a TV that went
through that house fire and
it didn't work right anymore like you
like the picture would start out right
and then it would slowly like Screech
down to like we had like three or four
like inches of space I played that game
on that TV when the other ones were used
because I love that game so much
expected
so yeah clearly on the Nintendo kid
right but like you guys said have always
said everyone's got the friend in their
life that's got the Sega that's right
kid you're the other way around that's
right for me that was my buddy Devin
let's go that was my buddy Devin
and whenever we'd stay each other's
houses or whoever's going over they're
bringing that system to come with them
so we can play whatever wanted and so
have you talked about Sports Talk
baseball yeah and we were all about the
Joe Montana football the halfback yes
the greatest pass ever again the half
back pass oh and I heard commentary in a
sports game commentary zoom in it would
zoom in on whoever had the ball oh my
God Sprites and the graphics so large
the weather
had the weather I forgot about that we
always wanted to play in the snow we
always wanted the snow games even though
it was terrible to play in mm-hmm those
are classic
let's go the other classic too of us
when I when I would be over at Devin's
house his dad would
he would just absolutely wipe us an
Arnold Palmer golf like that man didn't
really play any games but he loved that
game and he just put it on us like every
time we've been playing something
downstairs he wandered down in the
basement be like oh let's play some golf
kick our butts and then just disappear
back upstairs like a ninja
in case you're I don't think we ever did
beat him either for years but in case
you're wondering uh yeah as time went on
Devin did go on to make the full tower
of power too
he has the CD and the 32x but we didn't
know how bad most of those CD games were
I think the only good game you probably
ever have a song to get the Master
System power based converted to do that
that's that that means so he didn't have
that okay yeah but we love sewer shark
and Ground Zero Texas and Night Trap and
double switch even though they were hot
garbage when you look back on data Plato
I beat all of those except for Ground
Zero I never played none of this but you
just every time you guys talk about
these old games that was before I was
born you say these names it seems like
those infra commercials like when you're
scrolling through at like midnight trap
like what what are they tripping why are
they trapping them gays
addicted there's trash the full motion
Choice the full motion video games era
in in the game performers back in the
day this is when they looked they were
so excited that the CD technology and
you could have feelings yeah you know
what I mean they were looking for a
reason yeah so it was the first by Jake
Solomon picked Marquis but in a way it
worked because kids somewhat somehow was
gravitating towards this this fad of
wait wasn't really gameplay you're kind
of just watching a movie literally like
you're literally watching a movie with
some of these things it had like some
very minimal interaction and it was
making it seem like you were you know it
but continues she had just like trap
literally you watched a video and
pressed a button that's the same that's
it that's the game that's the game a
button yeah and these movies were not
good but continue so you got your friend
in the end then you'll be Super Nintendo
now whatever what else you went from
from that
so up to N64 I was in high school when
that came out and I will never ever
forget standing in Best Buy I play a
Mario 64 for the first time that was
just like I'm thinking then like how
does it ever get any better than that of
course
but N64 had some great times for a
different reason because at that point
sadly my parents had got divorced okay
so I didn't see Devin really at all
anymore or any of my friends from
childhood but I made my core group of
friends I hang with to this day then so
what did we all play the same thing
y'all played GoldenEye and wrestling
games nice that's what 64. let's go
what during like the N64 like unless it
was like Super Smash Bros with like my
cousin's stage in store like I mainly
played a lot of like solo games didn't
really well my mom were like two three
jobs so I didn't really
have cousins to be around like that so
it was just like me watching the Pokemon
intro over and over again
Star Fox oh yeah I remember playing
Quest 64. oh yeah like you knew that
game that game was gonna be awesome I've
had 64 in its name
it was all about WCW mwl World Tour and
WWF no mercy like that was that's money
a day and my buddy Jim's basement
playing those games just we didn't have
the belt like King that would have been
pretty cool uh but no but I gotta give
honorable mention to the game that
caused friendships to be tested heated
heated arguments and that game was the
original Mario Party
one of my boys girlfriend's house where
she got so angry at everybody he shut
the game off and just kicked us all out
and he's been married to her for like
like 20 years now
some funny stories on that one as well
yeah very and then it was I don't know
if it was the first but it was one of
the early consoles to to have the four
player tap yeah built in because the tap
used to be the multiple attack used to
be an accessory for a lot of consoles
but this one was built right into the
car and it was so user friendly you had
that unique Bob what is it almost like a
batarang style controller but they had
these yeah the weird controller but you
had the analog which was not the worst
controller of all time I remember
remember the red expansion that you had
to put in the middle for certain games
you needed that for Majora's Mask and
Donkey Kong I remember my dad bought me
majiro's mask and he didn't buy the
expansion because he sent my grandmother
by it because he was on he was on the
railroad at the time and then like I'm
trying to play this on like Christmas
morning it ain't working it's like and
then like my grandmother called my dad
he's like I sent you the money to get
the expansion he's like she's like no
you didn't Paul
Jesus
beef
throwing her under the bus
um
so shout out to sob here that's when I
built my first real PC gaming rig about
that time uh I remember being amazingly
proud of that thing Pentium 232 whole
megabytes of RAM and I remember what the
hard drive was let's go but I was eating
good uh the low low cost of like two
grand I thought why buy consoles anymore
this is the future this is it it's a
future Escape then I would later realize
that man I don't have to lay out two
grand every three years to keep a
console current and play all the games I
want to play so I quickly abandoned the
PC Master race
I get it I get it where it is Advanced
the gaming space just yet
absolute man I love to hear it so you
just continued all you went from that
error to 64-bit era
um along the way you kind of stay
Mainline so I'm assuming like no turbo
Graphics is no 3dos no Jaguars okay
state but you still because those were
like yeah
but I'll hit your heart right now what's
up so I was a Nintendo kid right but I
was burnt the PlayStation started
getting the games the N64 wasn't because
of this versus cartridge thing I never
did own an original PlayStation but I
did get to play it okay so when
Dreamcast was announced and knowing it
was Sega and I like saying as a kid but
never got the own one I was on it I was
in for four of the worst ergonomic
controllers of all time
Adventure Crazy Taxi and NFL 2K and that
NFL too they couldn't see your place you
had your vmu and no it was no cheap
going on over on Dreamcast with the VM
usage
well and so that was one of the first
times I was really playing online
because me and my buddy Kev got together
and we do the Two on Two on Two over
online five and when you go whoop some
people fives all that that was some good
fun for as long as it lasted because
like you guys I think said on a earlier
episode it was like grand opening great
clothes on the dream class Dreamcast and
knowing I had a
had a ton of what was about to be
worthless gear on my hands I didn't want
to be stuck with I sold that all on eBay
as soon as I could so I got everything I
could at home okay Alicia you smart you
you bailed early you know I'll be a bail
Rider you know right all the time like
you said it was a shame because such a
powerful console such an amazing it was
like that everything came together for
them and that was the one that was
supposed to last longer you know what I
mean like it's just a very tragic story
and I had read somewhere that basically
the incoming president of Sega was
always against them being in the console
market and he got to come in and he's
like done we're out of here and that's
why I mean that whole thing was like two
years I think is all it left it was it
was a it was wasn't it was on the Japan
side they really what a lot of us failed
to realize that Sega fans is that Sega
did not have the capital to be able to
compete with a PlayStation coming like
they were always going to be able they
were always going to fall out of the
console space because they can't compete
because Sony had you know the Sony brand
behind it the PlayStation the Sony brand
Sega was just about games really and you
know the con the uh the arcade Market
had died yeah so it was just them and
another thing that Sega of Japan did not
like at all was taking losses they never
wanted to sell the council at a loss
whereas the American arm of Sega was
like no we have to sell at a loss to get
it out there
and and then we'll worry about making
money on the software and just think of
Japan did not think that way whatsoever
so I think I think a year not months
months before the console actually came
out here
um and it was a worldwide resume so most
people the console actually came out I
think the then president of Sega Japan
says something to the effect of like
this is our last console something that
you do not want to say on the cusp of
you launching a console yeah um so it
was just a lot of like it was it was so
much but ultimately the economics would
have played out as such even if they had
the greatest launch which you did if
they had been able to maintain that even
if they had a DVD player in the machine
to sort of Stave off what the
PlayStation 2 was going to do the
economics did not play in their favor
they just did it they just did it no
doubt no it was definitely all true
words spoken so you got up out of that
dream guess
burning ship you know salute to the
homies but um so parlayed that into a
PS2 second hand
no doubt No Doubt
so I don't remember a whole lot about
that era because it was a big transition
era in my life I had my first real
girlfriend that I dated for like three
years and moved out of my parents house
in my first apartment kind of balance
all that with a full-time job working at
the local ISP I gained for sure but what
I played on that PS2 like really only a
couple games stood out one was Shadow
Colossus was an amazing amazing game for
me yes yes yes yes what it did for its
time was just just mind-blowing for me I
couldn't get enough of that game and
while I know a lot of people aren't
really fans of it I really dug Final
Fantasy 10.
um I got into seven on PC and I also
liked what I thought was an underrated
Final Fantasy 8 on PC as well so when 10
came to PS2 I was I was in for that we
won't talk about 10-2 though because
that was hot garbage yeah
mm-hmm I'll skip a bit uh head a little
bit here because we're going to be here
all day but I picked up that blue Game
Cube with The Spice controller nice
jumped into the PS3 era by managing to
work one of those sites you remember
those sites and be like get a free
PlayStation get a free you know whatever
uh and basically you gotta sign up for
Columbia house and get like eight other
people
from Columbia House record music CDs
damn do I get like get like 12 CDs for a
one penny or something yeah you gotta
tape the penny to the back of the thing
I forgot about that yo that's real right
there salute okay but yeah when PS3 was
coming out at 600 bucks I was not the
kid or the guy at that point that was
gonna go get a second job for it I
already had a full-time job so I had to
work that hustle
that 600 George Foreman
got that foaming Grill salute
so finally I I I hit the Xbox side then
um had a buddy that had the OG Xbox I
liked it when I went over there but not
enough to buy one because as I saw
Microsoft was new to the space and I
didn't want to get dreamcasted again
so I I had to sit there for a minute
um but yeah finally a good old Circuit
City going bankrupt is what got me into
the 360 era because it's Circuit City
and I caught the 360 for with the 60 gig
hard drive for half price
I saw someone on Tick Tock he was like
because I don't remember Circuit City
he's like an older dude he's like let me
tell you about the drift on Circuit City
he's like me and my friends had dead-end
jobs so you know what we did with Circa
City went out of business you you was a
you was a uh a floor manager at Circuit
City who they go to talk to
Sega city was the spot man that was the
Best Buy before the Best Buy in a way
like so you said it was that spot yep
good job yep
in Gears to this day that my
aforementioned buddy Kev that uh we uh
we hung out and did NFL 2K with like
lead gears together uh we came came in
later on when Diablo 3 came out on on uh
uh Xbox and and whatnot like we we Co-op
that game together and cannot wait for
four to be coming out we'll Co-op that
together too but yeah we I was down for
the the couch co-op games like me and
Kev really have have some gaming nights
those are the best man
and then later I up they updated that
360 to an S uh and then I gave that
original one to my brother-in-law so he
and his family could enjoy it I know
y'all are gonna ask it never red ringed
uh who's one of the rookie ones wow yeah
okay yeah okay yeah by the time the S
Cam run they fixed it right it was one
with who yeah yeah but that was like a
year or two after I got the original one
that I got the f
but yeah that original one like to this
day is my brother-in-law I don't think
he ever told me at Red Ring nice
no doubt no doubts they stayed up in
there that's what's up man love love
that then from there every subsequent
you know you went Xbox One PlayStation
pretty much yeah yeah it was like so
from that generation I have I've had
every console and in the kind of that we
we uh that's when my kids started
happening and uh that was kind of
interesting because my oldest is now 13
and he doesn't understand why I'm not a
fan of new Switch zeldas even though I
introduced him to the old school ones
I'm pretty sure he actually beat the
original one on Virtual Console
um and he may even beaten Zelda 2 as
well which is saying something
um but yeah he's 13 now and he just
doesn't get it but he's made me many an
impossible Mario Maker level but great
memories there that's fine brother loved
it here man a lot of hitty story you
gave me history certified though you got
a lot of gems in there man I love this
very specific games too from each era
which is very cool I want to ask you got
a new question we asked those in the
room where did you first hear about ILP
and what was the moment that made you
join the realm you on LSM oh that's
that's how I got introduced and I heard
you and your energy and you're just like
just the goodness of you basically uh
and I'm like I got to follow this guy
over you know I told you all the
pre-show like all the podcasts I
listened to and I'm like I don't care I
gotta make room for this and all I
needed was one episode of hearing you
guys on here making room for our shows a
lot there's a lot of points you
sure you was ready for this when you
found out but I know people that watch
us ever week but they're like five
episodes yeah
baby like yes
I was telling karma too I'm like I gotta
catch up on you guys because I'm two
episodes back
before I get on the show but yeah that
that's that's a that's I had to make
time because once I got over here and
like like I was talking about my crew
earlier when we were getting together
with the the wrestling games and stuff
like that and I hear you guys telling
the stories I'm like you your crew and
my crew would have got along so so good
um
I felt felt kinship there so yeah I
could not be listening to the show every
weekend but super humbling man much
appreciated and um it's interesting is
here we have guests and you hear the
stories and you see so many groups of
people in all different parts of the
world kind of doing the same things
unbeknownst to each other that's that's
the part that's dope you know what I
mean and thank you for the con work that
was super dope because you always assume
it's just your group yeah like stuff
like like playing in TVs over yeah like
we're the pioneers and no one else was
doing this except us kind of energy but
it's dope to hit man and then what what
so did what made you join the round was
there any particular moment you know as
far is joining the realm itself so the
joint in the realm came
um so I always kind of hang around the
show for a little while like I I'm a
patreon member for lfm as well I've been
patreon member uh your boy Ryan
McCaffrey on the Tesla side you know I
was pretty I remember him as well like
anything that there's another show that
I was a patreon member of called cord
killers there a show just kind of about
watching watching TV and movies and
stuff and they had a great saying they
said we're a value for Value model if we
give you guys some value each week we
ask you guys to kind of you know if you
can find it give give us some value back
from from your side whatever value you
think we're bringing you and I kind of
that's kind of stuck with me like the
shows that I am like like constantly
Listen to I got a support so that's
that's what made me join because I was
with you guys long enough I was like I
know I know I got to give these guys
love brother appreciate you man that's
dope that's dope super humbling you you
know listen to this me attic and solved
listed in obviously King you know we
forget sometimes how much sometimes we
affect people sometimes and and it's
cool to see you know saying this is the
the beautiful thing about the hard work
and and you know trying to keep it the
way we keep it with the positivity most
of the time but
um that's why we try to keep like the
drama stuff because like I've been
attacked by other communities and it's
not fun so you know we try to keep that
like no drama stuff because I don't
wanna I don't want to send the policy
over there I will yeah but that but you
know this addict is easy to do beef it's
easy you don't say to create problems
and we get it but it's like Knuckles is
coming like I to me the stuff that Lord
daring is saying just now resonate and
it provides more value than that it made
it worth it you know what I'm saying
because like if we have more stories
like this like that to me you can
there's no monetary thing that you can
quantify that with you know what I'm
saying like that's that's love so salute
to you there that's that's fine what
I'll say about the positivity too like
for me like sometimes I'll there's in
the past there's been some shows that
I've listened to that like end up having
beef with each other and they'll bring
it on on the show and I'm like guys I
ain't here to hear my best friends fight
like yeah I don't need to hear y'all's
Dirty Laundry like take care of that in
the background and then it's about his
video games do you how you grown men
really serious beef over video games
like I is bro like come on like what we
doing you know there's real stuff going
on life that I do gotta uh quickly move
on because I don't get Beyond time but I
do have to ask the question that we ask
all the get rare guests here around I
need that top five you know what time it
is I need that top five video game with
franchises of all time lord daring
so I put some thought into this list
like it you heard that length of history
there and I had to put some thought into
this but coming in number five is
Battlefield Bad Company two
for me that is the goat
um talk about the Dork that I am I
literally at one point so me and my my
crew would get together every Friday
night once you know when we're in kind
of our early 30s at that point and we'd
get on there and it got so good like I
can't keep track of all of our stats and
figure out who's doing the best of all
of us and everything that was the dork
in me that
that game was amazing like I'll never
forget like strapping some C4 to a Jeep
and just fire in that Jeep somewhere and
then remote detonating that C4 to cause
the building to collapse or whatever
great times there hello salute No Doubt
number four is Sin City 2000.
that was the Goat Sim City for me
um those are colleges were where it was
at no time
number here here you go uh for the
fighting game Community out there number
three is Street Fighter two Champion
Edition
my man was either the Gods uh that was a
tiger boy tiger
and I'm trying to think who is my
cigarette was my main and then I kind of
flipped oh I gotta give a shout out to
zenji oh God oh my God hold up yo
YouTube you know what's funny right
because I was always a Ken main right
yeah and then once you got Championship
Edition you can play as the bosses I
went to see Scott as well because I'm
like oh he's got the same kind of
moveset you know what I'm saying as
Canon Ryu
um and he has this upper and lower thing
where yeah nobody could get past you and
then I I this was me this is my hubris
right here I was like I'm so good with
these two characters I'm gonna mess with
the character that everybody thinks is
whack yup and I started messing with
Zangief right and that's where my love
of the grapple characters came oh yeah
they just transitioned you to kick the
tank okay it's in the original in like
in the original
pulling off the the spinning pile
drivers I think it's so hard to Full
Circle move I mastered that and I
started and I I would call him the gift
he's just the geese
like the gooch in the arcade I could
never get that thing to go easier it
should be easier
yes but I could never get that thing to
go in the arcade when I kind of gone to
the Super Nas I could get it because you
can kind of cheese it and go
back yeah um and that's how I would get
it at home but yeah
um but yeah the original Street Fighter
before the Champions Edition Zangief was
my God uh I didn't know any better
because I was like Hey the big hulking
dude I love him yeah I know that's we
got this street fast three what else we
got
number two is Super Mario World uh to
this day like it's just like I said
earlier and what can you say about that
game it's amazing I I put so much time
into that I I got all the secret exits
on all the levels like I finished that
game 100 fire and then number one I'd be
remiss if I did not Legend of Zelda
which one to the Past A Link to the Past
is is the goat
I I play that game at least if not every
year every other year I jump back into
that and play it and finish it again
um
love it to death
um what what can you say you know they
kind of fool you at the beginning uh
three temples and it's done no no no no
you got nine more coming after that
clapping emojis
absolutely daddy I love it bro
tremendous list Final question favorite
console of all time and why
I think it was that super Ness and I
gotta say it was because I bought it
with my own money my first time uh and
bringing that thing home and having that
satisfaction and putting in that work uh
to get that console self-made self-paid
let's go you know what's up so I ain't
gonna put your business out but we me
you know I see I see the vision I know
what you're doing I know what you do yo
that's fine Lord David wood an absolute
legend in the game brother yo you was
right you called you said Carl when you
hear my story why
and I was like all right we're gonna see
I'll salute to you brother super
humbling you know I'm saying we love to
try to do more of this and again the
support that you you give us is
extremely humbling and I love to hear
stories like this brother Lord there are
you still hanging out though right
because we got to show you yeah yeah
okay look when you guys have guests that
come on and they're like I'm bouncing
after that like I I'm like you guys are
missing out on the best part after that
I know it's like today yeah it's like
it's like you got to get them you know
sometimes you got to get them they
little sneak in their little vegetables
and the stuff they need but then you
give them you know what I'm saying you
know the main cause of the fast food or
whatever it is day one kind of thing but
no no doubt because I gotta I gotta say
like you know so I'm I I'm not here for
the console arguments like that type of
thing
um so I got you know I own them all and
I kind of lean Xbox a little bit
um but today is gonna be real
interesting because I love my my Sony
stuff but man I know we'll get to it but
it was that that showcase was not it for
me and I think a lot of people agreed
save some of them thoughts we got we got
time we got things I see people joining
as to all we got the the Long Island
Viper the highly requested Long Island
Viper in the building how we doing sir
oh hey I was muted hey good to see you
guys good to see you good to see you
just hang out we got two questions hello
bills and stuff apologies for our tardy
this because we're supposed to have you
a little earlier you know I was talking
I was just playing drums for a while so
oh no doubt it's a little salute no
doubt no doubt solve um you want to do
the super chats and then yeah and then I
I got to take care of some business fuss
absolutely all right we got slo-mo
backslap remember for two years five
dollar Super Chat Bungie ruining more
than just the destiny Community now
pretty soon pretty soon the entire Sony
Community will get to enjoy the pleasure
of never being satisfied oh you need uh
Bungie the the highest uh what is it a
live service
acquisition from certainly that that way
then we have Ninja buckles five dollars
for chat come on bowdlers gate three
bring that Inspector Gadget energy Hold
the Line okay we holding it we're
holding it
what else is good Raiden blade remember
for two years five pound Super Chat
PlayStation soft brains POS why are you
not asking for Jim to get fired wow
okay okay here's some home truths for
you all them games you've been enjoying
from are from Sean Laden's work oh wow
we taking credit early okay I see what
you're doing I see what you're doing
then we have JD gamer remember for two
years ten dollars we chat pre-dream cast
there was no no loss no losing money on
the console model that was forced on
Sega after the Sony declaration that
they'd always win because they made
their own Hardware Sony was the big
money bully yeah that's right they did
jump in and sort of change the entire
Paradigm and Sega could not hang amongst
other reasons why it was crazy
then we got Hollywood rules member for
16 months Lord silver came to see
Michael and got Jermaine Tito and Randy
oh don't do this don't do us like the
other Jackson Five's bikers can you call
him Michael Jackson Don't do us like
that man I kid I kid best part in gaming
period watching happy Sunday have a
great show hashtag hold the lights
we just got the Jacksons you know when
they were just the jack
then we have Raiden blade once again
remember for two years five pound Super
Chat Sean Laden versus Jim Lyon Ryan Jim
is a thief living off next person
hard-working Sean had a plan Jim doesn't
only and only how to lie and steal your
own steal your hard-earned oh my God I
love you punctuation please please
fluctuation please let's go that okay
hold on a second that was the last one I
copy pasted then we have Astro parrot
King
2016. oh my they did it y'all some real
ones yes yes oh man you know we got to
get the PlayStation Community you know
we gotta get some real representation
that's that they were caught up all
right no doubt real quick
no please
um after parking again two lawsuit for
chat just like Peter Lonzo IOP stays
winning you already know let's go match
salute you already know I know he's a
Florida Gator I know Astro Perry good to
see you guys this is the one bright spot
now real quick before I pray the bill
just want to do a quick mic check right
quick we have the legendary big cloud
gaming Lords of gaming.net's own and of
course rgt podcast let's do a quick mic
check sir yes sir what's up how we doing
the building salute appreciate you
brother appreciate you all and of course
my man happy to see him the bad bit Mr
Bad bit PlayStation trophy cases oh how
we doing man how are you how are you I
don't have any like I don't have a nice
little mug but I got this little cheapy
link
all right all right I love cheap I love
it man we got some good PlayStation
representation in the building got to
pay the bills really quick so just need
everybody hit me up there Mike for a
second cause we got time for some sweet
talk it's sweet talk time so today's
episode is sponsored by PayPal honey the
easy way to save with shopping on your
iPhone and computer have you been
feeling the impact of inflation what's
the craziest price to hike that you've
noticed with high prices how do you feel
whenever you do find a deal is it
exciting is it a relief thanks to Honey
manually searching for coupon codes it's
a thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the as one
defined to your cart here's how it works
imagine you're shopping at one of your
favorite sites when you check out the
honey button appears and all you have to
do is Click apply coupons wait a few
seconds Honey shops for searching for
coupons and confines for that site if
honey finds a working coupon you will
watch the prices drop inside and outside
your realm your boy Laura Cognito uses
honey all the time when searching for my
tag my clothes and even hotel bookings
recently I was priced comparing
different hotels for my upcoming La trip
I was definitely surprised to see the
honey app browser extension pop up give
me a notification in the window click
that link saved about 30 bucks on a
hotel room for my trip it was that easy
did you know honey doesn't just work on
desktop it works on iPhone too just
activated on Safari on your phone and
save on the go if you don't already have
honey you could be straight up missing
out and by getting it you'll be doing
yourself a solid and supporting this
show get PayPal honey for free at
joinhoney.com
slash Iron Lords that's join honey.com
slash Islands I'm b-roll I do like it
and I use it all the time there's no cap
like it is really good like I I what I
like is that you don't think it's nice
to have something when you're in check
out they're like yo they'd be like yeah
they'll be like yo yo don't don't you
you good you know what I'm saying you
can get this for cheap or somewhere else
or but you could be good good Oh They'll
hit you with that yo they use this
discount code to get the saving on the
checkout so that's that's the choice we
paid the bills in the Realms you know
the ties and everything but we got to
get into this thing man
um actually one last thing we do have a
poll results I forgot last week's poem
results are in and the people have
spoken with the European Commission Now
approving the Microsoft Activision
Blizzard deal how confident are you that
Xbox can still move forward with this
acquisition the winner of the three-way
IOP poll at 46 of the vote was Xbox
beats FTC in court org figures out a way
to carve out the UK group coming in at
second place had 36 of the vote whereas
I don't care we wrap kick David we held
a lot
and in last place at 17 of the vote was
not confident FTC and CMA are still
blocking the deal group Lord solve your
thoughts they feel that this is gonna go
through Meg
yeah I mean like I said before uh it's
unrealistic to think that Xbox is gonna
pull their business out of the UK so
um seeing as it would be holy uh illegal
to move forward in that space
um it's gonna be difficult for it to
move forward as is uh especially if the
FDC continues to try to you know sort of
strong arm and not and kind of Hold the
Line even with even with uh kind of
arguments that I don't think are even
remotely as strong as what the CMA did
talked about so I I don't know like I
said there there were remedies put on
the table that could allow this to move
through with you know with Activision
breaking up parts of uh of its business
Call of Duty stuff like that stuff that
they said would not happen but if they
really want this to happen it kind of
looks like that that would be a path
forward maybe
um but as is it's still going to be a
tough going if the FTC folds and maybe
we see something unprecedented with the
CMA but I don't know so you heard it
hear from himself let's get
we got Robert kellett two dollar Super
Chat yo you got College around LSM x i o
p no yeah oh yeah shout out to Honey by
the way I used it like 10 minutes before
I signed on to buy a t-shirt mommy see
look
all invite for himself look there we go
Alice in the building oh real quick
Darren um being at your patreon guys I
wanted you to say the shout out because
you are not only a patreon of the island
you are a patron of the LSM family
absolutely uh seen here in column was
coming on here uh that yeah I I'm I'm
I'm I'm dead you're alive friend wake up
man is it all right you still here with
us you're rocking with the best
I have a bong sitting next to me
one thing I forgot from my my number one
I was supposed to bust this out oh
the the Real Steel Master Sword nice
love it nice oh he was a bad bit
reminded me when he when he filled the
TV link
no no let's get the rest of these
JD gamer two dollars Super Chat there
needs to be Sony smoke it's coming
stop coming for you guys it will be
appeased then we have the black Harry
Potter
absolutely Mr badmin in the building
we're missing Kyle but that's okay one
half of the PS trophy room is good
enough to have a great show fellas we
don't call him Kyle we call him who that
ninja that's right that's right thank
you man that's his real name real ones
know that was there for the beginning
video on Game Pass is this PlayStation
showcase what we should expect going
forward from the gym era you want to
answer now I know it's probably gonna
save your bars
how deep do you want to get I mean Jesus
then we got Robert Kelly for clowning on
you great work Lord daring don't dare
now whatever you know it's all fun
them over
mm-hmm we are good all right no doubt so
sorry I'm sorry chats Captain chats five
pound Super Chat great to see Mr Bad bit
on today's podcast great PS podcast my
favorite happy Sunday all thank you
thank you so much for the praise
everybody first off real real real fast
the ILP Community the past 24 hours
y'all are too kind
thank you for all the content yeah
what's funny is when I uh because we
were like who are we gonna have for a
Playstation representative I was like
I'm just gonna let the community pick I
don't care the community picked all who
are here
how do you how do you want to handle the
king thing
all right so uh real quick JD gamer two
dollar Super Chat I'm on the line
where's the General
in route as soon as you ask and you
shall receive so look we're right on
topic I know we're here for the
PlayStation showcase aftermath obviously
uh Lord King couldn't be present but uh
some special guests are so no I didn't
know that by the way I'm just I'm a
little disappointed about it I know I
know I don't expect him to go oh but
trust me you're gonna get a lot of him
disappointed y'all all gonna get a lot
of if y'all watch turn on to the street
go to the stream right now Colin if you
go to ILO podcast YouTube and channel
and go to the stream click watch it
right now so the king uh has thoughts
okay Cadets I want y'all to get ready
iron Lords podcast
fatigue gear is in session now
sit down
and let's assess what just happened
the opposition has just full barred
themselves that's right you heard me
right fubard themselves we have seen a
terrible show we were preparing for the
worse and what we got we got absolutely
nothing it was a white drizzle
so I want everyone to hold the line and
prepare
for June oh June can't come too soon
pause
so remember people hold the line and do
not football yourselves like the
opposition did that was absolutely
disgusting he thought Spider-Man could
save the day I say no way
did you see what happened when the
opposition tried to do games of the
service
smells like poo absolute poo so all you
spineless jellyfish that left the ranks
stay where you are enjoy that you are
fubar
yeah well
how'd you like that show
it's definitely fantastic now
I know a lot of guys is out there
complaining but come on man I gave you
Spiderman Don't You Buck up on me do not
buck up on me
I gave you some games of a service I
showed you some trailers you got Bubble
Bobble too the remix
fantastic stuff
and um from what everybody says IGN told
us it was a near perfect show
IBM is on program
everybody needs to be on program if
you're not on program I need you to go
to our brainwashing camps so you can see
exactly what I want you to see now I
want you to see a perfect tank
and I want you to know and love
Spider-Man
and uh I showed you a handheld
no I don't want nobody complaining about
the battery life you're home
when it dies plug it back in and get
back in the game an hour later
three four hours you shouldn't be gaming
that hard anyway we know that y'all need
your Twitter time
so I made sure there was three to four
hours in intensive games so you can get
back to Twitter playing Twitter like you
like the most
and I'm gonna tell you we're making big
bucks here you guys pre-ordered
Spider-Man had an alarming rate you guys
I appreciate every last one of you stay
brainwashed
and I heard the opposition telling
people to hold the line well I'ma tell
you to hold the LIE hold the LIE alive
Don't You Buck up on me Don't You Buck
up on me
so uh yeah
uh yeah King made his presence uh no
obviously he has his thoughts in his
opinions and we gotta get into the rest
of this battle but yeah definitely hold
hold up the PlayStation
you're supposed to hold the line
supposed to hold the line salute the
king for always
what does he call the second one
that's the butt character that's the
reason yeah the rich Tycoon PlayStation
owner who doesn't care about Gamers
feeling so to speak anyway
moving on we got some esteemed guests
let's get right into it Alex topic but
I'll set it up for him so yeah obviously
the PlayStation showcase aftermath we've
had time to assess and I want to
actually start off with bad bit because
I haven't talked to him in a while yeah
it's a bad [__]
some Trophy Room assessment right quick
you know not it has time to settle you
know what are your thoughts on the
PlayStation showcase man it's been a
crazy few days of just me kind of coming
to grips with what I saw because on one
hand you know I said this on the trophy
room this week if it was if the show was
a Jeff Keeley joint this was a great
show there's like a lot of games that
I'm interested to play like you know
alawick 2 looks fantastic right like
Assassin's Creed looks phenomenal can't
wait to play both of those but when it
comes down to how do I feel as a
PlayStation show
I can't help but feel like this
this felt like an obligation to Partners
rather than them wanting to put out a a
good show like there was a lot of third
party representation again a lot of
games I'm really really into but when it
comes to the question I feel like we all
had walking into this event which is
what's after Spider-Man we still walk
out of this going what's after
Spider-Man right like fair games the
logo aside seems interesting I hate that
I have to read it through a blog post I
would love to hear like Jade or someone
on that team like talk about what this
game is because when you hear it or read
it it sounds interesting I have no idea
what Concord is Hell divers okay looks
like a fun time but other than that like
what is PlayStation's 2024 looking like
and is it them having to rely on
third-party Partners or second party
Partners to to push it through I I don't
know so as a as a fan I can't help being
let down by a 600 plus weight of what's
the next PlayStation thing to get
excited for so to me I just felt like as
a PlayStation show this was like the
second best state of play I've ever seen
right like I feel like the state of play
in September was fantastic like rise of
ronin where was that game Stellar blade
where is that game amazing game right
and so to me I'm just left as a
PlayStation fan disappointed as a gamer
who's going to be probably playing all
these games that they showed I thought
it was a great showcase but again not a
not a PlayStation one so at the end of
the day I can't help but be kind of let
down okay so just really quickly if
we're doing one to ten yeah scale like
what would you give it currently
as a showcase itself of games that I'm
interested in a seven if I'm thinking
about this as a PlayStation showcase uh
thing that's supposed to represent the
the future one plus two years of of
PlayStation
I mean I saw that that Spider-Man stuff
and I loved it and if you all know me
I'm very biased when it goes to
Spiderman I give it about like uh I know
right I give it about like a five or six
on the PlayStation front uh nowaday's
divorced from it so again good showcase
is not a good PlayStation one okay no
fan about here where you coming from all
right let's get the Viper let's get
Cobra Commander himself got stuck in a
little secret but I don't know if his uh
thoughts have changed since then so now
that he had a couple more days to settle
like what's your thoughts on the
PlayStation showcase right now yeah well
it was fine well I guess it's not even
fun it just is what it is like the
advantage of doing a show like ours
where we don't do live streams I'm no
longer in media so I don't have to write
anything is that we kind of just get to
react and then we get to back off right
right and it's actually one of the
reasons I don't really I'm not really on
Twitter anymore I just promote things so
I know people don't really tweet at me
very much anymore but I notice a lot of
people were tweeting at me so I clicked
on it that's when people were asking me
to be on the show so we we talk to each
other via text and and I was happy to do
that but I actually got to kind of just
assess it in a vacuum I sat on my
recliner my fiance was next to me we
watched it on TV I was taking notes we
were going to go right in the sacred
symbols afterwards and I was a little
surprised by how negative people were
about it and the more I think about it
the more it really encapsulates it's
like what happened to redfall kind of
okay like is redfall the worst game of
all time I highly doubt that no you know
um and I just feel like everything's
either the best or the worst right like
you either want it to be all for you or
you can't really see any perspective of
what the company was trying to do
um so as I actually agree in that for me
I'm I kind of play Strange games right
like I like my Shooters I like my first
party games and all that but I play a
lot of turn-based games a lot of
role-playing games a lot of Japanese
games there really wasn't anything there
for me whatsoever
um but in like kind of a vacuum when I
was watching and I'm like oh I bet you
the audience is going to be pretty
stoked that we see what Haven's working
on I bet you the audience is gonna be
pretty stoked that we see what fireworks
working on uh Etc and so on and so when
I go on to artist Discord or I go into
patreon and then we're recording so I'm
going on and then as we're going I'm
going on Playstation blog right and I'm
looking up things I'm like all right so
what is this PVP going to the comments
everyone hates everything right yeah go
to the Discord everyone hates everything
go to the Twitter feed everyone hates
everything and I'm like I don't think it
was that bad like it wasn't great I
think you can argue it wasn't even good
depending on your perspective but I do
think that there's like a space between
you know I I feel like I wanted to say
this because I feel like this was part
of the strategy and I don't know but
maybe you guys can tell me if you think
I'm onto something let's go they
released a 38-page document for their
fiscal year 2022. so Sony split into six
sections as I'm sure a lot of people
know PlayStation is one of those silos
yep it's called games and Network
Services they release the 38-page
document on this and here's what they
said and I mean they said a lot of
things but there's just certain things
where in fiscal year 19 12 of their game
of their revenue or I'm sorry 12 of
their investment was in games as a
service fiscal year 23 so the one we're
in now 55 of their investment will be in
games as a service fiscal year 25 so
that's two years from now 60 of their
investment will be in games as a service
Investments by new IP versus old IP in
fiscal year 19 only one in five dollars
that Sony spent on development was spent
on new IP that's Now 50 50 and moving
upwards and so what I say by that is I
look at it I'm like I kind of see what
they I think they were trying to do or
what they thought that they were trying
to do certainly as I said earlier there
are a lot of third-party things in here
and Deals foam Stars looks amazing
rip-off I can't even believe it
is Splatoon
Nintendo's lawyers will be at the ready
that particular game made me want to
talk about Square Enix much more than I
even want to talk about Sony because you
would wonder how much of a glutton for
punishment this company can possibly be
making games and service whether it's
babylon's you know publishing babylon's
fall Avengers outriders which I love
outriders was arguably my game of the
year when it came out I [__] love
that game
um great but it's I it's so that was
weird but I think overall it was fine
you know and I I wrote down some stats
that I thought were interesting 34 games
in 70 minutes certainly big complaints
were lots of lots of CG yeah not a lot
of gameplay I think the biggest problem
was the spite of a lack of a Spider-Man
date although my my kind of 20 years I
kind of broke the news on it Colin he
said it starts in August the marking for
that yeah yeah yeah and I believe and I
and I my personal theory on this is that
they're gonna bundle it with the new
PlayStation and you know the news model
and they don't know when that's going to
be ready I also think that uh they don't
want to kind of there's so much velocity
in the old sales right now I think
they're kind of afraid so I think they
were in between a rock and a hard place
it would have been cool he got a date
for hell divers too but I personally see
I went to fair games and I'm going on
and on I'm sorry
tube
um and people hated it right like
everyone hates that game I'm like I
don't it definitely has that Ubisoft
stench yeah which is makes sense because
it's a Ubisoft game essentially that
team is basically a Ubisoft team
um Concord we don't really know what
that is 75
anything about it they literally just
showed like the thing in the burger I
was like what is this about yeah so so
for me okay so for me it's like but then
I went to Spider-Man I know Spider-Man
was brought up earlier Spider-Man 2 and
actually pushed Square just wrote about
this and I went and looked
between so on Playstation they have 7.5
million views on that trailer already
with 374 000 thumbs up and 9 000 thumbs
down 9.2 million on Marbles YouTube
channel 388 000 thumbs up 7.6 000 thumbs
down Phantom Blade was a huge thing too
1.7 million views 84 000 thumbs up 1.6
000. so like when people say it's like
that was the [__] oh I'm sorry that
was the worst thing ever sorry about
that that was the worst thing ever I'm
like I don't know about that I've been
in the industry for a long time I can
there were worse E3 conferences than
that they were worth it I don't know so
I just feel like it's somewhere probably
in the middle okay I've heard from
people that I know and I think it's
fairly obvious that there will be
another showcase later in the year I
assume it will be
um more focused on some of these games
that are rattling around but like a
future game showcase like they branded
it the first time around yeah something
like something like this and maybe just
even Market it as first and they don't
like using the term second party they
just like to pretend everything is first
party but really like mature and get
those games out of there but there are a
lot of things that I was reading into it
where I just I'm like where is the room
for the middle when I was watching this
I'm like I just don't see it this way my
audience really sees it this way it
seems like the hardcore PlayStation
audience really sees its way but as I
kick it back to you guys I ask you
what's this going to change nothing Well
PlayStation 5 is still gonna sell
enormous amounts of units Spider-Man 2
is still gonna sell 10 million copies in
a few days like all these so it's like
to me it's just it's very a small
blemish
what I will push back on Colin and I
want to ask you this is that what about
the fact that the weight right we've had
the the two years so to speak and the
fact that there hasn't been you know
it's been pretty we have state of
plagues things like that but the fact
that there really hasn't been any
significant and then obviously see the
moniker of showcase and historically
PlayStation let's be clear like they
have put on Amazing showcase like to the
like the Showcase of Dreams grown men
crying announcements of games that you
couldn't eat when they're in person it
was it was a very interesting thing yeah
so but I also remind people of that too
that last E3 it was pretty bad but it's
just like the standard has been set so
high right so do you internalize that as
us the gamer putting too much pressure
or based on what we're used to them or
just hey that it was okay but you know
it wasn't as bad as people say but I
think the the main a lot of the main
discourse I'm saying is that people
waited for so long and they felt
disappointed in conjunction with not
only that a lot of CGI no actual
gameplay no action release dates first
party game that actually had gameplay
right so I think it's a combination of
the those things but I'm curious to see
specifically about the two years my
question for you is really about the you
know being that they've been away for a
while and then come back if you see
maybe you can understand on that side
why the the base is so kind of like
virally upset with I definitely
understand that dude trust me there's
you know
I I kind of never fall under the
hardcore PlayStation Camp of what people
feel for instance I thought God of War
was great but I didn't think it was like
the best thing I've ever played I
thought Horizon was way better than
you've been kind of War personally right
I'm always in like kind of a weird space
right I've been in the PlayStation space
for a long time but I'm not quite Your
Mark where it's like you can be like
this is the guy right that plays
everything and does everything I'm like
I don't know about that I have kind of a
weird taste so I I do try to take that
into account which is why I try to look
at things more objectively I think I
look at things from Sony's perspective
and I don't they probably are a little
surprised in fact I think that they
definitely are surprised by the feedback
I've talked to some people at the very
Studios
um you know I congratulated some of my
friends at Insomniac for Spider-Man 2
which looks absolutely I mean insane
that the presence of that game alone I
think makes it can't possibly be bad and
especially when it's 70 minutes long and
so it's like that's literally one
seventh of what they showed
um so I don't know it I I think Sony I
think the Sony's perspective right now
and I think this is why the Activision
dealer like why they're so engaged in it
is that according to the documents I was
reading they only plan on releasing two
first party games a year that's what it
looks like they say that straight up
that's all they want to do they say at
least two first party games a year so
that's two first party games a year so
when you look at things it's like okay
they don't really want to have this
release schedule I think they're much
more frankly focused on getting like
honkai rail star or whatever the hell
that game is called that gun should
impact thing over to PlayStation where
they make hand over fist money on it
over and over and over again it's the
same reason why they're so concerned
about Activision leaving so I think they
just look at it and they say like people
are gonna freak out they have a right to
freak out you're absolutely right from a
hardcore PlayStation fan dude I want to
know what all these guys are working on
too I want them to talk I heard some
interesting rumors and things it was
cool to see helldivers and Arrowhead
re-emerge after eight years and all
those kinds of things but at the same
time I I just think we have to explore
the middle ground and it really does
remind me of what Xbox just recently
went through with redfall where it's
like dude it's I just looking at it it's
not the worst game of all time like
there's no way that the way you're
talking about this is actually realistic
for what the game actually is whether
people like it on so this Falls
somewhere in the middle I think yeah you
know and I I just think based on the
data I was telling you people have to
get used to PlayStation saying this kind
of stuff they are interested in being in
this space save that thought yeah next
time because I got some debt that's a
big question to ask you but I saw a jump
in and I want to open it up yeah I guess
though I I think I think that's where it
is like there has to be room for the
middle ground it's right like we cannot
we cannot go at Sony for for the stuff
that we've been seeing Microsoft do
forever right where it's like you know
game pass that you have a lot of those
smaller games on Game Pass they do make
their way into big showcases in ways
that I personally don't necessarily like
but I do think it is something that you
that you said in the past as well Colin
I think it kind of holds true on the
PlayStation side but for different
reasons where you say Game Pass is
taught Xbox players not to buy games
right and I think the expectation on the
PlayStation side has kind of taught some
of the PlayStation base right maybe
perhaps the loudest ones in the
PlayStation base that
anything that doesn't look like a
horizon that doesn't look like a god of
war anything that doesn't look like a
Last of Us is inferior and that you know
being that that has been kind of the
company company line all the way from
the PS4 it's kind of it's difficult for
them to sort of
except that this is a new reality I
absolutely think this is a new reality I
was just surprised that they didn't make
an attempt to hide it as much as I
thought they would with you know
interspersing more of these sort of
um you know PVP games and and service
games with their bigger titles
um so I for me it's just it's it's a
narrative thing and how true that is and
how true you know narratives are are
created and die every single day but at
the end of the day it just feels like
the narrative that a PlayStation
hardcore player that loves what
PlayStation became in the PS4 generation
this is completely opposite to that yeah
and and there's that fear that this is
what they are moving forward and I think
it's more than a fear like you said it's
the truth and we're gonna see more and
more of it they're telling us trickle
this way they're telling you I just sort
of think I just sort of think that
it's weird because in the past we've
accused Jim Ryan of saying things that
weren't true or whatever or not
understanding the business just caring
about the business side of it and not
you know the faith that you have to put
the fans and whatever but he it's funny
because he has sort of been on that line
where he knows the he knows the the pop
that the big bangers get and here it
sort of seems like they went into this
and didn't read the room and realized
that too much of this without the
bangers around it was gonna get this
reaction and uh I mean in a way I I
can't say I kind of commend them because
they sort of jumped in feet first and
kind of they're telling you what it is
and they're telling you're going to see
more of this and you may be disappointed
with few with future showcases because
there's going to be more of this um
again at the end of the day if all those
games are great then all those worries
go out the window but it does change the
perception of what what it means to be a
PlayStation first party game and what I
would say to that too of is uh it's like
you know Colin you were wondering like
yeah like I'm interested of what Haven's
working on I'm interested of what
firewalk's working on
at the same exact time I feel like a lot
of people would been a little bit at
ease if there was something else that
looked more familiar like it's kind of
like like you know it was kind of a
shock to the system if I'm a hardcore
PlayStation fan I know for the past what
like six seven years that this is what
PlayStation does and now suddenly
they're starting to turn somewhere else
and now something looks foreign and
weird to me so I'm it's kind of like a
culture shock moment so like if there
was a moment where it's like and here is
goes to sushima too I think even if it
was just CG trailer it would have been a
big enough exactly you know because it's
not like CG trailers are the worst thing
in the world I love the the you know the
Xbox showcase a few years back where we
got a look at like a vowed we gotta look
at what Like Fable looks like like
hellblade looks stunning like all those
games you didn't mind at like their CG
or in game or you know in engine games
um
because we trust those developers we
know who Ninja Theory is we know that
playground hits we know that you know
obsidian doesn't miss so like when we
see those games even though they're CG
we know and understand the pedigree the
problem with Haven the problem with
firewall because though we hear names
behind the studio we don't fully know
the studio yet so it's hard to to put
our our faith in it if I am the well
even if it's a known studio if it's not
a known IP like what what are we looking
at right like you have nothing to go on
so it's really hard to know should I be
excited for this because that's like
with fair games again I know a new
studio and new IP I'm like wow this
concept looks really cool but what the
heck is this game I mean I'm gonna make
an assumption based on like Watchdogs
what it showed that it's going to be a
third person kind of squad shooter but
we don't know that yeah they're gonna be
like powers or like what's the actual
game I think I think the biggest issue
that people add is not only the cloud I
got you after the lack of showing stuff
I think another big issue people had is
like the stuff you did show us and you
like obviously they opened up with
Haven's game I'm pretty sure that was
David's game but it's like when you look
at that you kind of get a concept with
that might be but we still have no
realistic idea of what that game is so
it's just like you know even if that is
my design by the way just to tell you
like I think that that
was interesting that's you know so I was
saying earlier that they he thought they
would hide more I'm like I think they
hit everything
kind of did you know
you know I've had everything because we
didn't get gameplay right but but what I
did get from it with did I personally
don't like I don't know how people who
play these type of games react to it but
I got this this overwhelming sort of
okay we're gonna take a little bit of
fortnite we're gonna take a little bit
of uh here's our take on here and I got
a whole bunch of like weird like and I
just kind of feel like looking at like
the stuff that Ubisoft been doing as
well and you talk about the Ubisoft sync
on it it looked I looked at it and I was
like are they making Watchdogs like yeah
I looked at it
the creative director was the art
director about Watchdogs right I do I
have a question for Colin real quick
yeah I'm sorry
when you look at it like obviously you
know I I didn't know the percentage was
been increasing for games as a service
in Sony
do you I think like I'm sensing some of
the concern on some PlayStation people
and I've always concerned with this in
the past like we love these newer IPS we
love you know the sequence of like God
of War
to me
if they start having a couple of these
head out the market and they're making a
lot more money do you see a round where
Sony pulls back on these other IPS
because they're making more money in the
games of service and start pushing that
field more
I don't know if they can ever get away
with doing that fully but I think that I
think they're going to try to have the
best of both worlds right because they
need that Revenue like the God of War
made all of its money back and basically
twice or 2.5 times its money back in a
day day and a half you know it's it's
they need that kind of cash and we'll
get into it I think it was what Cog was
saying later about why I think why I
think they're being deliberate why I
think they're shutting games down and
all this I think it's actually ties into
that which is that they realize they
need to release PlayStation quality
games they cannot afford to release bad
games because they don't have to get
money to do that and they can't afford
for their for their reputation which is
their only really their major advantage
is their reputation
um so I I think I mean you want to hear
you want to hear something uh depressing
here which is for people is that by
fiscal year
2025. so two years from now
be for every 10 games PlayStation
releases
five of them will be PS5 games four of
them will be PC games one of them will
be a mobile game so for every 10 so this
is this is a a new world we have to just
figure out what it looks like but with
Revenue going up with the velocity of
PlayStation 5 so high their net income
is so much higher now than it was during
the PS4 era I think they realized that
they could just have it all if they
tried but I think that they need to they
realize we were talking about redfall
before Microsoft can afford redfall and
they can afford a failure like or in
quotes a failure like redfall a middling
game like redfall would really hurt Sony
not only reputationally but because they
would they just don't have the the cash
so they have to be more deliberate but
anyway I'm going on I'm sorry no no
doubt let me get on big cloud he's been
really patient rgt podcast make sure you
get on that I think you had tested on
hopefully soon
um I mean Chris Reagan will answer the
call bro get on that maybe one day Long
Island and of course
you know I gotta get Colin on one of
these days a good podcast brother I love
what you're doing man enough
questions.net
um now that you've got a couple days to
settle you know where you at with the
Showcase I mean first of all a great
point in smeared by y'all are definitely
hitting uh hitting a lot of the points
here but for me
um so you know I would get like this man
you know we've had stayed a place you
know 30 minute shows that felt like they
had five times more energy and
excitement put into them than what this
show had all together the show is over
an hour and 30 minutes so when you have
that anticipation that built up from
great state of place not all of them but
you have these great state of plays
building up towards it
um and you know we hadn't had one in
over 600 days Now's the Time for a lot
of people to go you know what hey we
might see Wolverine you know we might
get that factions reveal we might see uh
look into what Blue Points working on
um bad Bill was hoping for bloodborne
again everybody support badly my
condolences but I thought you was gonna
get your blood Bowl bro some dreams
never happening
I think at this point we need to realize
that
that's probably yeah sometimes some
people like myself are just addicted to
the pain
I was gonna say when they have blue
points in there they just killed the
Demon Souls remake like why wouldn't you
throw them at bloodborne like they
probably got other projects that they're
working on well they think about it with
their new IP as well okay I was just
gonna say we actually just went into
this recently about bloodborne because
we were trying to like Occam's razor it
like they I always say this to people
they know they know they know they're
not you think that Jim Ryan and all
these guys are like walking around their
hands in their pockets not being like
bloodborne just throw that in the
garbage we're trying to think of like
why why hasn't anything happened and
actually my Occam's razor answer and I
don't know if it's true or not but we
were just trying to figure out like what
is the most logical explanation of this
and it's like could it be that there is
some sort of second party contractual
obligation problem that they are the
ones that have to work on it yeah like
it can't be done by anyone else that
might be one of that that that's the
only thing that makes sense
and they also own 14 of katakawa which
owns from stuff so they but they so they
do but they could it could be a unusual
second party relationship remember so
when you let this get away they could
have had this from the very beginning
when when they went to Bandai Namco the
game was up demon souls should have been
published by Sony instead of Atlas in
the west they had no idea what they had
so I think from software
that just seems to be the most logical
explanation because you would think it
would have gotten a PS4 Pro patch even
so that's what I put out here is that
maybe it's something unusual like that
you know be crazy if they holding that
on that for like the the next gen
release it's like a launch title
bloodborne remake like they did with
demons
but yeah I think I think what Colin is
is alluding to I think yeah it's
probably the cases I mean even with like
the Demon Souls thing it it they made it
sound like they kind of asked for for
from blessing to to do this and and and
so I kind of think that's the case but I
every time I put that out out there on
Twitter I am playing I I the the day
that happens I will be deceased but
at this point
I agree continue to go back to this
again over 600 days we had to wait for
this showcase and you know it's not
really the third party like the third
party like you guys said like there's a
lot of third-party games that I was I
saw that I would definitely pick up day
one I think I already told you uh Cog I
was kind of Gone with the Assassin's
Creed and I saw Mirage like you know
what yeah that hitting a little
different I don't know I might I might
have to get that class accessibility for
me oh yeah Phantom uh Phantom Blade was
a nice surprise series Platinum pretty
much every last one of them except for
the last one of the Demon Souls but um
Dark Souls sorry but going even further
into this like we had
um you know
there were some okay surprises here like
again like the the rumored Metal Gear
Solid that started to set the tone to go
even higher and that's usually how they
go they show you the Indies they show
you a few games here a few little like
updates on third parties you've seen and
then they'll show you the reveals and
usually it will go up up up up up
but instead it kind of just went up and
then it just declined and then it got to
the point where I was like okay I hope
the guide you know this being a showcase
I even said this on stream I was like I
hope the guy we don't get no Hardware
reveal
you gonna get that Hardware sir don't
give me no hardware
and and here it is you know Jim Ryan
gets on stage he's like hey um yeah
about that uh Q it's real and I'm like
shout out to Tom Henderson who's in the
chat right now who actually broke the
news you know what I'm saying with us
dead right on that one and I'm like okay
you know usually when Sony shows stuff
like this off it at least looks
attractive
this has got to be the ugliest handheld
okay I'm glad you said it because
outdoor I was just me
okay handles
badly onto a late night
hey rip the Dual sense in half and
attached it to a switch screen right
basically it's like a controller it's
like a controller fell off the table and
it split and they're like yo that's it
though it probably feels really great to
play though it probably feels a great
place so that's what we're that's what
we're losing that's what we're losing
here's the thing some regards to it
though like when it was going to have
the Dual sense functionality I remember
I said to myself I was like dude it'll
be a nightmare if they just took a
tablet and put like
and it literally it's exactly what I
guess that's literally what they did but
real talk like you know we've been
covering it for a minute on the trophy
room when you see the blueprints listen
we got an upgrade because originally it
was like two dual uh attached inside I
I'm the only one on the internet and
I'll stand on this Helen proudly die on
it I love that thing's design I love it
you're not the only one there's another
person
[Laughter]
I don't have any interest in in uh it
like playing that if I can play
something more natively I'm actually
because I play Turn base I play a lot of
turn based games and slower games I
wouldn't play it they're actually
showing it I think with God of War or
something I've never play anything like
that but I you know my turn-based games
my role-playing games my trails are cold
steel my you know yeah whatever uh slay
the Spire it's perfect you know and you
have you said there's a lot of um I
don't really see I don't really so I
think it benefits as much because it's
Remote Play yeah
and I'll say you guys mentioned that but
I played most of the original God of War
on that backbone right there and it was
great uh if you're local on your network
it's oh it's it's really good attic user
says I want to go around the panel real
quick actually what's funny is uh Lord
Tom and King have a bet going on with
that price what what do you guys think
the price is going to be we're gonna
start a bit cloud or the uh
yeah whatever that thing is they're just
playing on your bed with your feet up
thing
I can see that easily being two to three
hundred dollars okay easily we got two
to three anybody taking any bets who
else yeah I'm sorry I think 250 250.
you're gonna get that PlayStation tax
just like the Apple tax you remember
PlayStation's now all about premium
the single fan of this device what are
we doing yeah I think 199 would probably
be the lowest it would be okay I think
that would be a steal though for me
again I I think I'm excited about this
thing it kind of goes into like when I
was watching it in a vacuum
well you would love a disc conference
then I was just confused because we've
known about this thing for months no one
complained about it what the hell did
you think it was gonna be oh no question
no question no question like that's
that's the whole that's like my whole
confusion I think what it was it wasn't
the column it was just shown it was just
the fact that it was showing during this
time you know because before we got to
the other stuff we got like Jim Ryan was
like okay before I showed my first
announcement I want to show you guys a
game and then he cuts to the Gran
Turismo
and I was like
what did he just do yeah I think that's
the biggest I think that's the biggest
disconnect it's like I don't think
people cared about the hardware
announcement people cared about they've
been waiting two years to see what these
bigger Studios and I've always said like
look you guys keep forgetting these
games as a service they've been cooking
for a minute they're going to at the
show these games now too and like when
you go here going into the future when
it comes to these showcases
you're going to see both not just one
not just the other like they're just not
gonna not promote the games as a service
games like so I think people just like
really expected like them to end with
something big not a game that you know
has been seen already and we've been
known I think that's the biggest it's
like just the disconnect I do feel like
the expectations for this was kind of
lacking you know Microsoft has a lot of
issues in certain way when it comes to
like promoting stuff I remember they had
like a fiasco with gameplay once but I
have seen them when they see those
expectations go a little too high eh air
jump on Twitter no let's roll you back a
little bit
and it's just like I feel like
PlayStation was just oh Metal Gear Solid
Castlevania and then you know apparently
some of the the developers were hyping
it up too like the actual Studios that
micro PlayStation owns like I think
that's the biggest thing people people
just they're looking into the future of
PlayStation you know uh especially
coming up to this event we had some you
know Studios that they've been working
with had massive layoffs obviously the
The Last of Us thing that happened after
the show and I think people just looked
at this as like I want this show
to show me that they're gonna have
consistency like they did the PS4 but
then when it happened and they didn't
really get those big titles that they
were you know looking forward to I think
that is what hit the most because like
to me if that show would have had a
little bit more of a variety of stuff
that people like people would have been
all over the weird looking handheld
thing but the fact that it was there
people saw that he said we got one more
game but let's show you this and they're
like we ain't seen Spiderman so we know
that's the next game
became the known quantity at that point
it just Cloud on damage okay
yeah it didn't even stop with that
though you know we saw the new earbuds
yeah that they were hyping up um so you
got this which is probably going to be
two to three you know in that range that
you got these new earbuds that he's
hyping up as this new high tier thing
and that's probably gonna be like what
the max 150 180 I don't know something
around that that price range
if you guys remember there was reports
going around that once the queue was
shown or revealed there was going to be
a PS5 Pro the following year
that's what was going around that was a
rumor that was going around now I don't
know if it's gonna happen next year but
if it does happen and we get a PS5 Pro
next year after all this
uh
you know what I'm saying like I already
feel weird going into just gleaving this
show because I'm like Tom it's been on
the money he's in the chat I don't know
if he's still in there but uh Tom if you
want to comment on said reporting feel
free I think it was very disconnected if
they would have had like a because I
personally did not really I I thought
Spider-Man 2018 was good but I thought
people blew that game way out of
proportion but what I saw was like
I'm looking forward to this Spider-Man
because it looked like more of you know
variety of gameplay you know it looked
like the bosses have been fletched out a
little bit more but it's just like when
you hit that end date and they're like
we ain't gonna show you a release date
and I was surprised by that is marketing
stuff going into that but it's just like
you needed to tell me that we about to
hit June and you still ain't gonna tell
me this game coming out this year I
think yeah Tony Todd uh released all the
info on that and he had the back strike
but he said it starts in August I don't
know
um if there then they should have moved
this whole thing to August that's true
that's true at this point but I'm like I
don't know if they're doing like another
state of play I don't I don't know
probably another PR beat yeah I don't
know at that point but they said a big
PR thing is gonna go for Spider-Man
that's gonna be a big thing I'm pretty
sure black custom plates are going to be
sold by PlayStation to go with your PS5
Tom Henderson responded said the pro is
real Jets he's still standing on it I
think Still Standing so again if that
drives next year and you got this and
keep in mind next year uh well even
though it's not the they okay and Sean
Nick's kind of hoping for 2024 to be
wolverine's-esque right like you get
something in regards to it I don't know
I just feel weird about it and what's
even more crazy about it I think 2025 is
a more realistic date for her yeah I
think that's the real release date but
you know something you'll see about it
will be 2024 maybe even 2026 because
they still working on Spiderman like the
whole studio ain't even working on that
game right now anywhere anywhere about
Spider-Man that's what I saw no no I'm
just saying like they're they're
dividing their resources on two games
right now one's most likely about the
end development but they're still doing
both games yep and then uh there was one
particular thing that I thought was
would be here you know this is something
that I had a lot of people about that
you can attest to this because I made a
video in regards to this you were with
me on this I flat I said listen why is
it at The Last of Us remake doesn't have
factions included and you're charging me
seventy dollars for this and do so but
you're getting accessibility features
accessibility features should be there
to be to include others it shouldn't be
hidden behind a higher pay wall
especially when you're cutting out
features and core mechanics that was in
Prior and this took a case makes no
sense you you throw in a new workbench
mechanic in this but you can't give me a
Dodge and pro mechanic
interesting you see what I'm saying so
the factions is not included it was not
there and we and I had to say oh you're
going to get factions this year as if
they knew it was going to launch this
year no that's not what Neil druckman
said he you will hear something about
factions in 2020 uh three that's what
you heard about something all right yeah
so when we got to the show and it wasn't
here I'm sure they're going uh yeah um
good point okay there's no blue point
games there's no factions there's no
real there's nothing that can really
that tells me anything about Concord
there's nothing that really tells me
anything about fair games aside from you
see Josh reals looking around CGI
trailers are cool for the eye candy I
guess you can say but it doesn't do
anything in terms of telling you what
you're actually going to be doing inside
games how many CGI Trails have we seen
of Assassin's Creed where they're doing
this unbelievable parkour stuff and when
you get into the game it's not even
close to that you know what I'm saying
CGI trailers do nothing for me it's cool
to build the anticipation kind of like
how the Order 1886 did it man like it
was like that little the little little
little title screen it was moving with
the water right and you heard like eat
like like werewolf noise and you're like
okay this is gonna be dark gritty right
then you get the actual physical you
know you get the reveal the next year
type of thing that's how I went into it
I was not impressed by a lot of the
stuff here in terms of the first part
and it was underwhelming in my husband
like and when you had these you know
dudes on here telling you hey you guys
you got to change your diapers there's a
game that's gonna steal Spiderman's
Thunder don't be revealed I'm like
here we go so are people going to learn
that most of these people that say
things have no idea what they're talking
about exactly
some people played in my Discord kind of
you should see my Discord there's some
people posted them I just like Yo dude
big cloud this is going to happen like
when has this person ever been right CD
project red is about to get boys
I heard GTA
6.00
yeah I've been taking like my personal
YouTube channel more seriously and I
used to have like this hard I'm not
talking about rumors but now I'm like
who cares because to me even though that
most likely nine times out of ten Sony's
not gonna buy CD projekt Red but it's a
nice
I'm sorry baby and then I want to get
there even patient oh no I was just
gonna say yeah no that's Sony my uncle
that works there oops my inside source
[Laughter]
them out keep it in the family brother
Lord daring won PlayStation showcase
aftermath your thoughts sir
I mean so obviously I'm not don't have
the pedigree of the folks so the rest of
the folks on this panel but as a fan of
PlayStation
um I mean tell me like outside of Spidey
2 and Metal Gear uh Delta like what and
and of course Final Fantasy that we've
seen 752 times taking up another like 10
minutes of the Showcase when it's
releasing what next month right I think
um what in there really got you hyped
because I think Phantom Blade was about
it for me and
it I couldn't like I mean it looked like
gameplay but again you can't really tell
for sure so you know we are we gonna get
the batons glitch there same thing with
um oh she what was that second game that
they had with the well like magic and
the you saw the hands on there oh I
think it was the EA original
Immortals yeah yeah that's what it was
yeah that game look great but how much
of that is really the gameplay
because you really didn't see any I mean
I assume it is but that is the game
comes down in a couple months yeah okay
excellent but yeah I mean like that's I
mean there wasn't you know would you say
Colin I think 34 games on there and yeah
34 games like personally
maybe four of them I was really like
looking for and to your point Colin I
guess I could see about like what's in
there for oh sorry five because Cat
Quest I gotta put a shout out again
I I I love I got to see it in person the
original one in person that packs uh a
bunch of epoxies a bunch of years ago
and I I've always been had a soft spot I
love cats too but
um yeah other than those five I know
that's that's wrong but I have I'm kind
of missing like the the what everyone
I'm trying to be objective and see what
everyone else could have been excited
for but to your point and never I think
everyone's in agreement like no it
wasn't bad but it certainly wasn't great
either I like you asked for a rating
earlier Cog I think I give it a six of
ten okay also shout out to you and I
don't know why I almost forgot about the
marathon
Destiny and then marathon is going to be
there we're not doing that we're not
doing that sir we're not doing we're not
killing off Destiny sir
you can try to wish it if you existence
I will say this uh when we got to the
Spider-Man stuff you know again that
right there is everything I've been
wanting in terms of the upgrades to the
game yeah the traversal was fantastic
I'm glad you can now Glide oh yeah it
looks top tier I like what they that
game looks amazing it looks crazy you
know and it's crazy because I've seen
dude try to I've seen PlayStation dudes
try to talk down inside Nick saying you
know like it looks downgraders I'm like
and you know it's crazy because I said
insomniac's literally like their best
studio right now like it's looking
around naughty dog is insane with
quality but if we're talking about in
terms of like keeping PlayStation really
in the the light in terms of excitement
it's been Insomniac that's been their
go-to Studio you got Wolverine still to
come and you have Spider-Man 2 here so
it's like it can be made for sure I want
to get um quickly solving them and
myself before because we got to get
these other topics in and um so so I
don't know if you got all your bars off
because I know you're kind of jumping in
now but your thoughts on the on the
PlayStation showcase
um yeah I had to sort of you know
separate my the thoughts on the Showcase
right like immediately afterwards
um and then afterwards just sitting down
and just looking at the actual games and
thinking about how many of these games
are actually interesting to me and that
I would play and the fact of the matter
is it's a decent amount of games here
that I am interested in playing
I just when it comes to a showcase right
a Showcase in the vein of what you
expect coming you know out of out of
PlayStation in the sort of e3 time frame
same thing you know for Nintendo with a
direct that E3 or an Xbox at E3 you
expect big reveals to be the main the
main thing that you're going to see
during the Showcase um I am admittedly a
showcase
showcase that got what and that's the
thing I I admittedly I am a showcase
bigot straight up
I don't know nope nope nope I don't know
if unless you are an indie of the status
of an inside a journey a seafood or even
a stray
um I don't want to see you here
oh you you slander in the little there
are there no little guy all right listen
this is my water fountain this is your
wall hold on
it was a good showcase for gaming bad
showcase only for PlayStation I mean
yeah only one game had gameplay
yes
so again like the the only stuff that uh
so that's that right so of those Indies
the ones that really sort of stood out
to me
um
it wasn't like never right that stood
out
um the Plucky Squire just because of how
pretty that game looks
um and that's pretty much it the one
that kind of looks like a breath of the
wild Towers
I don't really know you know and what
we're getting in terms of of sort of uh
exclusivity there and that's another big
thing that when you come to showcases
there's been in in historically there's
been a lot of exclusive exclusive this
exclusive that or whatever the case may
be we didn't get a lot of that right
very true so
um it makes you wonder it's so so messy
you should have just called it a summer
day
but again it was funny you know you see
Xbox's cheekiness afterwards to come out
with the list of games that are are
coming to Xbox right
um I'm assuming day and date right they
didn't say anything uh to the contrary
did you see the rumors solve where it
said that um PlayStation was
intentionally holding stuff back
I mean that that could be I mean I mean
I'm sure that is too that is true that
is true right there's certain things
they decided they're not going to show
obviously Sucker Punch is working on
something else like obviously uh Ben is
probably working on something else like
it those games are in the pipeline they
just why they chose not to talk about
them
at this time when historically they
haven't cared about I and I give them
this they don't care about talking about
a game five years down the road but I
guarantee you that game comes out and
it's good right and Xbox hasn't really
had the same sort of they haven't had
the that courage to necessarily do that
and I don't blame them necessarily but
PlayStation when they talk about a game
I don't care when they talk about it
years down the line that game comes out
and it's usually pretty damn good so
that was that was interesting kind of
surprising not to see that
um so then we get into the stuff the the
the you know the uh the service game
stuff and the service game stuff for me
is stuff that just does not appeal to me
right and the fact that they are you
know it just as an observer it is
interesting that the reality is we've
been talking about and hearing about is
finally coming to fruition now it's
happening
um and this shift
right gotta give all the flowers on this
he told 100 100 because this [__]
happened yeah this is going to happen I
just for me I was a little shocked at
how overt it was here uh granted they
didn't show much of anything but they
showed you that this is the type of game
that's coming to Playstation and there's
more to come right so I was just kind of
shocked by that um
and I mean I kind of wasn't because the
the fan base has kind of been acting
like nintendrons lately yeah
the fan base sucks right now yeah like
not because not because
people not because people don't have a
right to be upset but it's like it's not
within the context of the reality like
you would think that it was like we were
starving and PlayStation 5 was just
doing horrible PlayStation 5 is selling
more now than it was yeah two years ago
which is going to embolden this them new
directions
I will agree with calling on the fact
that is there reasons that people can be
upset yeah I think it was more of an
expectation thing but if you're an
actual PlayStation gamer and you like
the games that they delivered they have
delivered them yeah you know just
because these particular games
right does it mean that you know it's
the end of the world but at the same
time it's like you know got to be better
on that yeah on that come on when we
talk about like narrative and
expectation right the expectation was
more of what they've gotten in the past
they don't really care about it oh
you're fine but they don't care about
that they just care more about Twitter
they just use these games for bragging
rights yeah
I was just going to say like I made my
bones as a PlayStation reporter at IGN
during the early to mid PS3 era and we
often I often remark on sacred symbols
that that was truly a dark era and in
fact probably my favorite era of
covering PlayStation because it was so
funny how bad it was and so it was so
dark like people were so defeatist I
remember people printed shirts that said
PS3 2006 to 2006 on them and yeah and
all that sort of thing that was the
PlayStation 3 where I guess I just have
context from as a reporter and I think a
lot of us do as players where I'm like
guys it was pretty it was bad it was bad
and and uh like the consoles were
expensive the games weren't there they
were shutting Studios down remember
Factor five got shut down not Sony did
but Lair shut that there's Haze all
these horrible games right and
like as a player of PlayStation games a
prolific player of them I play a lot of
them as you guys do as well I'm like I'm
pretty satisfied I I don't always need
first and second party games I don't
even play half the first and second
party games that come out anyway I
didn't play Demon Souls I didn't play
you know destruction All-Stars I didn't
play all these I don't care about these
games and I think that's one of the
things that I walked away from
disappointed in the in the Showcase was
who cares if a game's exclusive or not I
don't know why people are so obsessed
with this
yeah
I'm with you on that but people were
like oh who cares about Marathon if it's
gonna be on Xbox who cares about it
Assassin's Creed Mirage who cares about
Alan Wake too who cares about Dragons
Dogma too I don't I'm like I don't
really care who makes I don't understand
what this obsession is where the game
only matters if it comes from first or
second party and while I understand
people being disappointed and I'm sorry
well I understand people being
disappointed in that Sony and maybe it's
just because I'm in the weeds and we do
and I do this professionally and so I
just I have this stuff going through my
head all the time they are telling you
what they're gonna do and then they'll
do it and then you're like you have
people on the internet telling it up
it's like it's not gonna happen I will
push back though I gotta push back
though because you gotta understand the
it's the you're right so what you're
saying as far as no one should care
about that but the fan base has been
cultivated to believe we are special
here we are vrp this is this is
Playstation only on Playstation this is
part of the market right prior so that's
kind of been faded though but but but it
has become the fan base it has been
cultured Behavior to say
that a money had if money had it
exclusive is something to expect it is
you know how funny it's become that's
what I know you'll watch a trailer and
everybody waits to the end and they look
at the verbiage and they look for 12
months only exclusive one thing and to
your point Colin and big cloud you're on
fire with this it's it's to say that of
the fans you got to come here to play
this and the people they the place they
should knows that their base cares about
this this country club thing is real so
the fact that so the fact that they're
not seeing it now and you're seeing you
know these new IPS and let's give credit
to Xbox a little bit for being a little
petty for them to quickly respond back
and say oh by the way all the stuff that
you just saw we got that too on us
because they are used to being omitted
from by Sony but he had those
third-party exclusives a lot of the ones
that I feel are like they have their
finger because give credit disorder they
have their finger on the pulse of
popcorn culture what they feel might be
the next big thing if it's not made by
them and somehow find a way to associate
with them and I think this was a a
reality check to your point Colin of
this new direction that Sony's going
that the base ain't a hundred percent
ready to hear just yet what do you say
that
yeah I I think that there's
I think we just have to accept reality
right like God of War was awesome I I
liked it a lot again I think it was
probably overrated Horizon forbidden
West
um I'm wearing my my Astra Corporation
today yeah for um for Eternal and all
the rest like we get these games and
they're the the interstitials and it's
good stuff for me you know I I enjoy
the exclusive games as much as anyone
that is the identity of PlayStation but
it can't be all of PlayStation some of
the stuff like people as an example
Crash Bandicoot wasn't a first party
game a lot of people think it was but it
wasn't yeah sometimes things just become
associated with consoles sometimes and I
think that so you have to look here let
me give you an example right Cog I'm
really bad at Alden ring I'm bad I'm
just not a very good player video games
generally speaking and so I get really
mad and I'm like this game sucks I hate
this game I tried to give it a chance
I'm like how can anyone like this game I
don't get it and then it sells 20
million copies right and with a 15
Platinum Rafe thanks so not only am I
wrong in terms of the minority of like
the the inclination towards the market
but I'm in the minority of people that
can't even play the game and sometimes
things aren't made for me in fact I
think sometimes people forget about that
particular question and so I see value
in third party games I own a third party
Indie developer we publish on all
platforms right like I I want so when I
see Dre like people are pooping dragon's
dog where people pooping Alan Wake or
something I'm like I don't know why
these games I understand why this isn't
a naughty dog game I understand why this
isn't a sucker punch game and we want to
see those and we're excited about those
but they're telling you they're only
going to release they're telling you
they're only going to release two a year
yeah let's call it 2.5 a year they just
showed you four
right and so people just don't people
are not seeing it for what it is and I
just you were right earlier when you
said like people are just not ready to
hear it but I think sacred symbols
audience well knows okay yeah I've been
on it even even shouting that from the
roof yeah you've been on it for a minute
with that but I don't think people have
to understand and this is what I was
saying about revenue and why it matters
before because net income and revenue
are going up substantially orders of
magnitude in some ways like we were
talking about accessories before they're
making a killing on accessories right
now and what it means is that if they
play their cards right they could have
the best of both worlds where they could
have the single player games we expect a
clip of one two maybe three a year and
then they can have games as a service
but what I think people are forgetting
is that they really want as I said
earlier hit that quality bar and I think
people are making assumptions that these
games are going to be free to play and I
think that that's a mistake
um because we know from their own their
own um documentation that they consider
one of their 12 games as a service and
development MLB the Show yeah I saw that
on the actual year right so um and they
consider Destiny one of those games
right so there's two different different
types of games and there's going to be
all sorts of different things so I think
their lone singular Advantage is quality
and as long as they can communicate that
to the audience through whatever they
put out I think the audience will get it
but it
I guess what I was saying about about
Elden ring is you have to defer to the
market ultimately yeah and that's kind
of where I'm at now with this if this
was truly as calamitous as a lot of very
loud people are saying then it's
certainly going to be reflected in the
console of sales yep that's true for
that I mean I got to get solved after
Batman yeah yeah and we forget like the
the you know the PlayStation E3 or 20 uh
what is it 2006 happened and like for me
I became a mainstream like this is my
main console PlayStation 3 during the
PlayStation blackout like the worst time
to be you're gonna fall in love with
PlayStation was that
so yeah sometimes you know Twitter's
loud it's not necessarily real I
definitely agree with you there
um and when it comes to those AAA games
that are showing third party games that
are shown as a PlayStation fan you kind
of get some type of comfort going well
okay all the cool little gimmicks that I
like out of my dual sense and all the
like Tempest sound all that crap that's
going to be utilized there so there is
like some Silver Linings to be had
either though this showcase was not
Stellar after you saw finish your
thoughts and I definitely got to get
into yeah I think at the end of the day
like I said narratives you know are born
and die every single day and this
narrative is is just gonna like the
loudest people are gonna Express their
displeasure with it and but the reality
is that is what the reality is moving
forward and you're gonna stay and you're
gonna play because you're going to get
you're still going to get the games that
you expect and want from them it's just
that you know now now their their
library is sort of evolving it's going
to be more of another thing as well and
that's just what it is I think you you
know at the end of the day you're always
going to have people yelling and
screaming at the top of the lungs about
how this is the worst
so I don't want you saying remember how
the narrative women how it was like oh
they're eight-year-old games I don't
care I don't care
it's two-year-old games exactly I don't
care right exactly and it's like it's
like yeah exactly you know that people
got over the PC stuff people got over we
believe in Generations they got over all
of that they will get it's still here on
Twitter defending all that stuff it's
like yeah they don't know what how to
when to put their foot down because they
have no ground they have no voice they
just want to just hide behind the box
yeah so and they will they will get over
this so they at the end of the day the
PlayStation was still cons it would
still sell like gambusters it's just it
none of that is changing uh but I I do
want to see how again narratives
narratives to me are just funny because
they can carry you know
they don't even have to carry a whole
lot of Truth for them to be to to affect
things in a negative way right and for
me you get enough of this
what does that do to Xbox right what
does that allow Xbox to come back and do
if XBox has been put into this you know
space of negativity by you know the last
few things whatever redfall and stuff
like that it has disemboldened them to
to be able to sort of take back quote
unquote The Narrative and run with that
in a positive way that actually
translates into you know hey more more
console sales or whatever the case may
be more Game Pass subscriptions whatever
the case they'd be so I just want to see
how the reaction to this trickles down
into the rest of the industry and
affects it if at all if at all
um but for me just quickly about the
games have remained um I was saddened by
the marathon thing especially because
I'm like okay I'm like Bungie's coming
back they're bringing it back it has a
narrative element and they're like nah
we don't want to do that oh yeah your
PVE sensibility yeah we're gonna mix
this completely so Bungie is just turned
into a company that don't doesn't make
games for me and that's fine yeah
what do we all think is is Marathon
matter or is matter or something else
it's matter it's matter from what I'm
hearing it it is
that that trailer did absolutely nothing
I mean you don't you don't know what it
is
18 million views exactly did you see
with the number one um
[Music]
I'm so glad that the wrestling Community
does not agree
Colin I'm with you I said I'm real
talking I'm a fanboy of them like I
couldn't believe it it had that I think
I wonder if they spoofed those numbers
in some sense I'd actually be interested
no seriously
I was with you then you did the spoofing
on me there
I'm always skeptical of every business
and what they what they do and I was
looking at it and I was like this
doesn't have nearly enough likes or
comments to have 18 million views that
show yeah um
all right I think my last point and this
is where again uh this is where I found
it to be kind of egregious and it was
psvr
psvr what I saw from PSI my expectations
for psvr was were stronger okay and the
things that we saw here I mean obviously
resident before remake we saw the
upgrades you can now see more than just
the hand you see the arm right and you
know again the rest of this stuff it
just doesn't
it doesn't pop in a way to me and I
synapse look pretty good but I still
think and I don't know how far-fetched
this is they really have to be in half
five yeah yeah
they got the number one game but I wish
you saw that Half-Life they should have
figured out a way and something and to
me some more stuff with their own IP
um I'm not saying just shoehorn it in
there but really dedicate the resources
and the time to making another game you
know Horizon uh called the mountain was
cool but it's very surface level it's
dirty it's pretty and that's pretty
disappointing yeah right ultimately
you're wild initially right because it's
pretty and then you play more and you're
like yeah this is this is timing
simulator 2023 right and it is and if
you want to play that just play the
climb and the climb as much as crime is
actually it's a terrifying game until
your points off with my dispatch I don't
know I don't know if you're going here
but my also disappointment is the reason
why obviously I have advice towards VR
but the reason why I was excited for
Sony's entry into the space was because
I thought they were going to leverage
those classic IPS that they're known for
and really put in uh Jin Sakai or and
really your alloy or really you know
what I'm saying Nathan Drake and
leverage it that way and I didn't see as
much Dad I'm like oh they're still not
there it just creates because again when
you start looking at you know the uh um
the competitors out there and it's not a
lot right you're just looking at the uh
The Quest 2
um
it really you want them to be able to
differentiate themselves in a way
instead of just like oh we got the the
higher resolution version of X game
coming here and yeah that's great that's
cool
um but it's probably gonna cost more
than it would cost me on this on on said
other sort of uh uh ecosystem and the
differences aren't so vast that
it requires me to buy a 550 piece of
equipment so I really would like them to
see the dedication from them with their
sort of first party IP uh in the VR
space and we haven't seen it yet so uh
disappointing because I haven't played a
whole lot of VR me neither my mine's
been sitting collecting dust yeah I
don't use it at all although I I heard
and I haven't played it yet on the quest
so red matter two I heard it's beautiful
get on that and and I heard it's
beautiful and on the on the on the psvr
2 is absolutely amazing and another one
that's coming I don't know if it's out
yet it's called hubris that they said is
is super great so there are some that
one they had called synapse look good
though synapse looks pretty good yeah
okay
um but yeah overall disappointment in
that because again you ask people to
spend 550 on this piece of equipment and
I just I'm not seeing enough
um of stuff that I really want to see so
that so that's it for Me overall a bad
PlayStation show for what I expect from
a showcase out of PlayStation but as
they've made clear the realities of what
that is
has to start evolving in our minds and
whether we like it or not it is well if
it works for the third parties how many
games will they have had to show not
only yeah
Thirty third-party games I think so wow
all right yeah so I'm in a short
showcase yeah yeah I think I think um
at the end of the day games matter more
than anything it doesn't matter like
games are everything but I just think
that I love the last of us more you know
more than probably anyone in the world
yeah I love the I love a lot of these
games but other games do matter too you
know like I just wish that
like having the games I don't care who's
making the game the game can come from
some mystery alien source for all I care
if it's on my console and I can play it
I'm going to I'm going to be down with
that I think that in some way not so
much Nintendo but maybe Xbox fans
already inherently know this because of
the recent lack of first and second
party of production you you understand
inherently this the very thing that
PlayStation fans I think need to
understand more as time moves forward
especially with higher production costs
yeah again there's two or three games a
year different types of games I just
don't know
um I I don't I don't know I I see
something here and I'm like this is fine
again I get you yeah I get you I want to
jump in because I get a chance to do it
but if that was a very last thing random
blade zero oh God yes most excited about
that I just want to make sure that's a
real game
everybody's a little skeptic that's
interesting
they just started production yeah yeah
look I get what everybody's saying
um you know to your point uh solve I I
get that I didn't have that trepidation
with that one for somebody for some
reason I think that one is it but we'll
see we'll see look you know at the end
of the day Some solid content but this
showcase was just not for me it just
wasn't and and I I'm the guy that likes
the diverse stuff and the VR and the
Indies and and I'm not saying that that
a lot and you know I'm team live service
so I'm not shout out to the cops they're
excited you know what I'm saying yeah
you know but at the end of the day look
the thing about it from what you said
about from a PlayStation Showcase from
what I expect from them it was jarring
for me it was jarring for me and I am
part of that maybe I'm part of the
problem because
I always come to expect a certain thing
and obviously a format so to speak and
this wasn't there so I'll start with the
good obviously Phantom Blade for me was
was amazing Bungie's uh presence to me
really elevated the show elevated the
show because again I knew about matter I
predicted that they would have a
presence I said the timing was right and
then you saw all of Destiny's quote
unquote a team on that project
Christopher Barrett the whole Squad that
game is going to be phenomenal like
they're gonna figure out a way to make
an extraction shooter something special
so really keep your eyes on that and it
actually does look like it has decent
law but I don't know if they're gonna
have any PVE component obviously I'm a
big Destiny stand cnk reveal on that
stage they know what they're doing that
was that was a that's going to do Master
for them the final shape so when I was
trying to tell people that aren't
Destiny fans how big that is huge and
you know I I get it I get it Miles
Morales come on do we really you know
say like if this thing is spectacular
this thing is going to sell like
wildfire I love the simulator like dog
pee they're like the Symbian I like what
was going on there the new abilities
they show gameplay to me yeah of course
they're gonna have to set pieces of
stuff but any New York fan no he saw the
Queensville bridge and so they was at I
was like okay let's go Queen's in the
building I'm happy they're bad let's get
it right out way too much CGI
no actual gameplay very few release
dates you know again I don't care about
the diversity is I'm not knocking the
diversity but it's just other showcases
are not going to be able to get away
with that you know I'm saying like where
some of them don't even give you context
like the Concord one is great as the
studio and I want to know what fireworks
walking on I love the talent assembled
there I didn't get any sense again based
on the Showcase now if you want to talk
about like after the fact and you're
doing research that's different but if
I'm going in there I can't tell you
what's going on besides the burger was
shaking and then you know what I'm
saying they flew out these these could
have been quick posts on Twitter right
CGI trust I gotta be honest Spider-Man
having
are just full release was surprising to
me it was surprising to me it wasn't
well it was intriguing because it was
just like okay is it maybe now that you
know because I assume September based on
the rumors that we heard the voice actor
leaked whatever you know what I mean so
you know my assumption was okay they're
gonna be it's going to be a big
competitive spot in September does that
change things now that star field and
Mortal Kombat are in the month of
September and is Sony being a little Coy
playing little games because again I'm
going to assume that game looked really
you know finished one of my major issues
with the show pacing pacing pacing
pacing did not like the pacing my thing
is I love Indies I love VR but we got to
be real the hardcore PlayStation gamer
the in the VR yeah like you gotta see
it's like it's like a kid you gotta
sneak the vegetables in some way so it's
like when you put all that towards the
end based on the history of Sony that
I'm used to that one more thing that
that thing that you didn't expect when
you put VR and Jim comes out it's like
now we're gonna you know the VR section
so to speak I love VR but to me that has
to be placed towards the front of the
show
build up
exactly that's how they did it before
and that's why it just was weird that's
why I didn't hit for me because it was
uncharacteristic so to me Sony is the
best at presenting whether it's their
music Movie experience that presentation
that Showmanship that flare like that
was missing that was my main issue with
it the Indies I love Indies but again
there was a section where it was like
four or five of them in a row and then
here come you know foam sud whatever
soapy soap whatever the story but you
know say like it wasn't for me you know
saying but I understand I'm not saying
these games are going to be bad I'm just
saying the pacing and then what what
really exemplifies it is when Jim says
that we got one more game not that
Spider-Man was termed we know Spider-Man
was amazing but because people are used
to one more thing and now Spider-Man man
is the known quantity stole the Thunder
out everybody's like oh the whole last
thing's gonna be Spiderman you see what
I'm saying yeah so it stole a thunder
again not saying the games are bad just
your presentation obviously surprisingly
not enough this wasn't it wasn't enough
for a while Factor Spider-Man was a good
yeah moment but it's not like it was
like yeah
you can expect some form or drop the mic
yeah
surprisingly not enough
um you know Sony first party you know
presents as far as you know obviously
Blue Point factions which we're gonna
get into the next topic we know why now
it's not there but I was really hurt by
that I was like man it's factions I
thought I put money like that was
definitely gonna be there we get that
um you know house Mark um Santa Monica
we didn't really know what was going on
with with them you know um I I got the
sense of it and I think Colin alluded to
this earlier which is that I'm just
gonna be honest with you these games are
taking long to make on both sides I
think they're very expensive and they've
taken one I'm not going to covet didn't
even want to know that I had a part of
it but I just think this is the way this
generation of development is seemed to
be trending that even then when they do
hit the four year mark that sweet spot
where we're used to now games are coming
out they got to be patched they Gotta Be
You you get the statement we're working
on it kind of thing I think the
development cycle has gotten longer but
that's just me the third the other thing
is the third party side again with Saul
alluded to I'm just so used to Sony kind
of money hiding that whatever like
even if it's the market marketing with
Hogwarts was a thing but they had the
exclusive mission right you know that's
it like make sure that you knew they did
like Sony always has this ingenious way
of like putting their finger and post on
it and it's like you could only get this
here and I think that's why I was
surprised that that's the Xbox tweet
with showing you know whatever whatever
I gotta be out the thing known I knew
they was in trouble goes off
was Final Fantasy 16 surprisingly
because to me as great as that game is
it showed enough of it but you're over
exposing like bro I know it's great stop
sure how are you gonna show this at a
showcase when it's already had its own
dedicated status yeah I don't get that
yet that's what I'd be honest with you
it kind of felt like that was like
shoehorned at the last minute in there
like that's when I knew that whether it
be from the first party side the
cupboard was Bare to show at this
showcase because the third party they
had everything in Spades no doubt also
uh Street Fighter that's right yes yeah
it was like we know about this and
there's no demo for it like you didn't
give us any additional information that
we really didn't know and I'm already
convinced that that game is amazing you
don't need to show me any more and in a
way you could make a Smite argument for
Spider-Man but I'm gonna I'll save
because Spider-Man saved the show but it
was one of those kind of like they
really showing us a lot of this kind of
thing and I gotta be honest
I get it
the movie looks like it's gonna be great
it's an adaptation it's that TV they
figured out a way to make grand Tours
but it's I'm gonna see it make no
mistakes
that looks absolutely garbage
okay I'm in on it because I thought I
would never be interested to watch The
Gran Turismo movie but fam do not show
me no movie trailer at a game conference
ever again do not do that don't get it
mixed up with the game because he said
after you've shown I'm gonna show you
guys her like I don't want to be
watching Sony conferences and now I get
Last of Us season two in the mid like
bro like this is that you're playing a
little bit you don't say like that's the
part where I don't say complacency but I
do think that when you are successful
right that you can kind of everything
you're doing is working you know what
I'm saying like you you kind of could
get into that mindset and I was a little
concerned from that because I I don't
think that is the place for put that on
there that's where you get TV TV TV yeah
I don't want to see that and energy on a
game showcase and yeah you know last
thing is is obviously on the cue light
we I mean we kind of you know spoke on
our feelings on it you know my main
thing even though I wasn't impressed
with the design was
um no information provided is it
remotely is it Wi-Fi is it price can I
can I go out the house
I don't know how far it's going to go
yeah after you like really voicing some
of these like it really felt like this
was thrown together at the last minute
it's like they had no info no Street
dates no release information well they
don't know when Spider-Man's coming out
like if that's the case then don't don't
do this like I'm just that's just my
personal feel you just don't because my
thing is this do you think they did this
event just because they wanted to be
present with all this news about to come
out with like uh you know the E3 season
obviously it's 93 anymore but you know
Xbox doing stuff Nintendo most likely
doing stuff next week that they felt
like they had to be part part of that
because this seems out of place this
seems like like it's just like
ironically before they do it and they
and and it's one of the worst showcases
they've ever done on one hand I'm always
gonna be appreciative if a company does
something for the base so I want to be
respectful there yeah I don't want to be
totally disrespectively fair so you know
we we love showcases we love what Sony
does showcases specifically as well you
know what I mean but again it's it's
what we talked about earlier the the
major key for me is we waited almost two
years for this this felt like glorified
state-of-play energy extended that's
just me you know I mean is it terrible
will these games be great they go they
could all be you know what I'm saying
they could all end up being great I'm
just I gotta rate you on how you
presented it though that's my issue and
that's it yeah they needed a better
editor is what it boils down to some is
not wrong like half those games didn't
probably belong in there if we could
have got more time on other pains that
needed to be seen then maybe this comes
off as better I'll push back what's all
in that forward Indy because I love any
I just feel that you're clicked you Mr
bigot Indie over here but you know I
feel like they're gonna be there it's
just like again hardcore games you gotta
find a way to put it in you got to put
it next to Metal Gear one two of them
here you got to put this you know you
gotta find a way to mix it in so this
way it it does and it keeps the flow but
look that's where it is in the previous
showcases Indies were first yeah you had
third party and then they closed it out
with all their first Friday offerings
and the reason why my rating is low at a
five is just that
the known quantities what I'm saying is
what kind of took a little the Lusty as
great as they were you know I mean it
just took a little bit of luster because
I kind of knew what it was again not
saying the games are not going to be
great but that's just where I'm at I do
want to move on I'm sorry come on please
please please please please please
please I was just gonna say two things
to consider about why they might have
done the Showcase when they did it
number one is
um they might have owed some of this
stuff in marketing to people yeah
I don't think that they intended to go
this long without doing a showcase and I
think that they were probably up against
it like and for personally people were
writing in the sacred and we talked
about it they're like they better not
show Final Fantasy 16 I'm like you
better settle in dude they're definitely
and and I wanted to read this from our
audience at sacred symbols someone wrote
in and said it was enlightening talking
on the phone with my brother today he
isn't on top of gaming news and leaks
and he called me freaking out saying did
you see they are remaking metal gear and
have you seen the new Final Fantasy when
you put it in the context there were a
lot of games at the Showcase and I will
be excited to play so I just wanted to
bring that perspective in about this
isn't necessarily only for us and the
second thing is that yeah I can't help
but think that there is some first of
all I think there's a an issue in Sony's
first party with quality and games that
are coming out games that are getting
canceled they're clearly going through a
review yeah kind of like a new GM
cleaning up an old GM's problems in
sports and so we obviously talk about
that but I also can't help but wonder if
the Activision thing has anything to do
with them just being quiet I think it is
I think they they probably need to say
something while and I don't want to say
they're trying to make themselves look
weak but I think if you kind of take all
of the different we owe this in
marketing we need to say something the
audience expects something it's E3 time
and we have all these things lined up
what can we do without making ourselves
look dumb by really by outlining three
more right you know third-party
exclusives that are going to make us
look like Hypocrites right
yeah and deal with this FTC thing so I
don't think you can underplay that
either I always try to look at the
perspective of they know yeah I mean
yeah like they so like there's always
reasons I guess
In fairness I think it applies to both
sides I think that you know both sides
currently right now are under intense
scrutiny by Regulators they're being
looked at and they're all both feigning
strength you know what I'm saying on
some level they have to not make
themselves look big and it the cure my
curiousness is that
how each is handling that and you know
as when that whole song is eventually
over we get the truth on what was going
on during these periods if these factors
you know kind of made into these
decisions so we'll see but I want to get
anyone else real quick and then because
I do want to move on I have a question
for Colin what do you think for 2024
that like they could possibly show to
probably clean the Slate here for what
we just got here well I think they'll
show more later this year but I would
assume goes to sushima's sequel will be
released next year we're in some sort of
Time Warp and I was in with cobit 2
where it's actually been longer than we
think since
like send is ready to go right even
though they took a year and there was a
Civil War at that studio and yeah John
Garvin was removed and all that they're
probably going to be ready to go fairly
soon and you look at other Studios I
didn't bear bad news for you there was a
bin Studio person and a space is like a
couple days ago yeah you just pretty
much like like he was acting like they
just started a project right I've heard
that they
um but you know gorilla my bigger my
bigger concern frankly about the future
is an over-reliance on IP wait we make
fun of Sony on sacred symbols all the
time for making what seems like I'm
pretty sure there are five Horizon games
in development right now but yeah yeah
um and like they're making an MMO an
online game Horizon three the Remake
plus the TV show it's like I don't think
so guys that's yeah ridiculous VR yeah
yeah
um so you kind of hope that like random
things come out of nowhere but I would
imagine that the next Studios that would
be ready to go are gorillas second team
probably isn't going to be ready to go
they just released that DLC so you
assume that's something like in a
combination of Sucker Punch and maybe
one of the new teams like Twisted Metal
at a fire Sprite or something of that
nature but uh yeah for the next few
years I think yeah compared to the Past
it's going to be a culture shot for
people real quick Paris Lily and Chad
salute my score for the Showcase was six
out of ten they were good games
presented but not enough from first
party good to see you brother
um let's get we gotta move on so if you
want to do foreign
are we going to combine this next
PlayStation yeah we probably should
combine yeah you're right all right so
let's just combine then I'll do all
super chats and yeah you're right we'll
do the last one yeah let's do that let's
do that so look let me see yeah and I
want to clarify uh someone just sent me
a DM on Twitter he he said that they
they weren't ready to show something
right now so uh they have corrected what
uh oh okay what was said okay no fair
enough fair enough so look we're going
to transition good good course off
um yeah uh Last of Us man uh factions
let's get right to it so
um initially let's uh I want to shout
out uh Bloomberg Jason schreier
um he had put out a tweet on this was I
believe Friday in reference to naughty
dog has significantly scaled down the
team on its like Last of Us multiplayer
project so as to say as it reassesses
the game following Bloomberg's quest for
comment the company put out a Twitter
statement today saying the game was
delays so that statement is officially
from the north dog Twitter account uh
The Last of Us fans we know many of you
have been looking forward to hearing
more about our The Last of Us
multiplayer game we're incredibly proud
of the job our studio has done this far
but as development has continued we
realize what is best for the game is to
give it more time our team will continue
to work on the project as well as other
games in development including a brand
new single player experience we look
forward to sharing more soon we're
grateful to our fantastic Community for
our support thank you for your passion
fans for our games it continues to drive
us and I did wanted to go into the
actual Bloomberg Auto that gave a little
bit more context on what is going on
from Jason Jason's reporting so it says
Last of Us multiplayer video game faces
setback at Tony weaknesses were found in
the game even as the HBO series became a
hit Sony Corp has slowed down
development on the upcoming multiplayer
game and its long-running Last of Us
video game series as the creators
reassess its quality and long-term
viability according to four people
familiar with the project the team
working on the game was scaled backed
after a recent evaluation said them a
small group remains on the project while
the company reevaluates the direction
while the game has not been canceled
many of its developers have been moved
to other projects naughty dog has been
developing the multiplayer title for at
least four years it's stated as a
complimentary mode till it started as a
complimentary mode to Last of Us Part
Two the single player game released in
2020 but the creators grew ambitious and
decided to make it into its own game
Sony has invested heavily in game system
service as part of that push Sony has
asked video game Studio Bungie to
evaluate the games across its portfolio
Bungie raised questions about the Last
of Us multiplayer's Project's ability to
keep players engaged for a long play of
time long period of time which led to
the reassessment so they go on to say
the single and multiplayer games
generally uh require different skill
sets although naughty dog has found
success with multiplayer games and some
of its titles the company is probably
known for developing its great single
player hits still fans were excited for
the project and raised questions after
it was not present at the recent
showcase so this is where we all
gentlemen you know this is big news that
Leah broke Friday right around the news
on cycle I want to start with Colin on
this because this broke outside the uh
your normal sacred window and I'm very
curious you know to get your thoughts on
this you know the obviously the delay of
the announcement your thoughts and then
obviously Bungie's involvement with um
the direction
yeah it's uh it's concerning and also
maybe what you would expect so I'll
explain that from Naughty dog's
perspective it's concerning because you
don't want naughty dog to turn into some
sort of BioWare shell yep or something
where you take your best team and then
you make them make something that is
unnatural to them I don't want to say
they don't want to make that because
that's not true they obviously do want
to make the game but that you kind of
try to pigeonhole and they don't really
come up and then you waste all this time
and then they lose their magic and their
Mojo I mean this is exactly the it's
like why when people talk about BioWare
I roll my eyes I'm like who cares like
no offense but I need to see another
game before I care about what you have
to release and you don't want Naughty
Dog which is widely looked at as Sony's
Crown Jewel to waste too much time
churning they have over 300 people
working there they're more you know what
I was surprised that people didn't read
into that is that they basically said
they have three games in development yes
so
um you have to assume one of them is The
Last of Us Part three I think that's
absolutely necessary and something that
they would be foolish not to do and then
you probably have a new IP you have
obviously Uncharted um being developed
outside and it seems like those guys
might have actually been hit by
something recently too who knows if that
has to do with uh you know the Stu the
visual art studio in San Diego
apparently had some layoffs but that
might have to do with the last one not
with Uncharted so we don't really know
but um so from that perspective you
really want to Shepherd your town your
studio to let them do the best things
they can possibly do and it might not
simply be possible for them to make a I
mean think about it's a lot of pressure
to make a naughty dog online game that
reaches expectations right right like
you have to have a quality expectation
it's just but Bungie came in see I don't
think it makes sense for Sony to buy any
studios I've long said that in
Publishers I don't want them to buy any
I don't care if they buy any it's just
not there's not really any sensical
targets anymore maybe like something
like ballistic Moon would be a Target so
when they went and bought bungee I was
like this is very strange
you want to obviously have their
expertise and all of that but what's
clear is that they they put them outside
of PlayStation Studios and they were
inherently going to be multi-platform
from the beginning which is why I was so
surprised when people were so upset
about Marathon I was like what are you
not listening to what they're saying
they've been consistent but but clearly
they brought them in and are empowering
them and I think that that's probably
important Sony doesn't know what they're
doing yeah you know they get a committee
to oversee it yeah right exactly like
they don't know think about the last
online games that they made right like
really you talk about drawn to Death
kill strain guns up if you want to go
back a little further you're talking
about Socom and mag you know it's been
Killzone shadowfall 3-2 resistance three
and two it's been a long time and they
have no idea what they're doing and so I
think it's probably wise for them and
this is what I was saying early is for
them to dispatch Bungie and say help you
know save us from ourselves because we
don't have the money in the capital to
afford many of these bad releases we'd
rather eat I can't imagine the write
down on this game would be anything less
than 100 million dollars if you canceled
it at this point you know and probably
significantly more than that you would
assume you know so they've been working
on it for years this was supposed to be
originally this Suite was built out of
what was supposed to be attached to the
Last of Us Part Two that game came out
in 2020. you know so when you think
about all the people that been working
on this all the time then Bungie working
on it if they write it down and cancel
it which is possible that they might
outright cancel and it sounds like that
might happen
um
if that happens I gotta ask you a
question now now we we we we're going to
be fair I shouldn't say that's wrong but
if it happens the The Talk
social media between both Xbox
PlayStation is mismanagement yeah
definitely so would you consider that
mismanagement if this game is canceled
yeah it's but it's but this is where we
get into the muddiness because
definitely okay okay I respect you to
say it out well it's I mean isn't it
obvious the the problem would be like if
you were dude it doesn't stop here
deviations game got canceled
like 90 uh employees right exactly and I
I we it's it's weird because someone
told me that two weeks before it
happened and I didn't report it because
I was like I don't I couldn't vet it and
all I still it's still very strange but
at the time the person told me that the
game's done and you could see that they
in they ingested firewalk they ingested
Haven the third Studio that they were
dealing with at that time was deviation
and they clearly during that review kick
deviation out this is when dreams was
canceled and all the rest which should
have been happening a long time ago
media molecule just hired a new creative
director they're probably not going to
get a game out for years you know so
clearly that I mean dreams itself is the
if you want to talk about Sony's
mismanagement first party dreams and
letting media molecules self emulate
yeah for years I was making this thing
that no one cares about wasting their
time you know um yeah the mismanagement
is is really serious and really severe
but the problem is this is and I I don't
know how many sports fans we have in
here but I know this will make sense to
you is and it's what I said earlier
about GM a new GM comes in right Joe
Douglas came into the Jets and he
actually came in after the draft that
year so Mike mccagnet had already made
all the picks you kind of have to deal
with it kind of purge things away yep
it's hard to say if it's like is this
Sean Laden greenlit a lot of these games
good point so is it is it him or is it
Herman Holst we kind of look at gorilla
as being an incubator of some good
talent because even Angie Smith's has
been promoted out of Guerrilla now and
into the PlayStation Studio she was
relating gorilla in Hermann Hall's wake
so there might be something there where
you assume that they're trying to turn
things around and take back mistakes
that were made under the previous
general manager as it was you just not
really able to say that you kind of have
to take the heat it's kind of your fault
right and it's not your child you
inherited but you got it and by the way
does it not say it because because I'm
sure a lot of your audience knows that
you know games go through review they go
through all these processes there's
there's CH you know they check in and
they have to really you know reach this
this and this it could be that it could
be that Hermann Holst came in when this
was already starting to fail behind the
scenes because these things move in slow
motion you know so it and and they're
very silent about that Yoshida also left
that position in a silent and weird way
you know and she was the person that
green lit the last of us he was the
person at Greenland goes to sushima and
so on and so forth so I just look at it
and it's like yeah there is a
mismanagement problem and that
mismanagement problem will come to a
head if Naughty Dog does indeed cancel a
game because that's a big write down
they probably haven't canceled the game
that big since the Santa Monica game
yeah which I think was an 80 million
dollar write down and that was during
the PS4 era so games are just much more
expensive to make these days so I I
think it's if you're gonna spend all
that money on Bungie and by the way
spend so much money on retention yes
because half the money for Benji was for
retention which is incredible so they
made they made probably hundreds of
those guys millionaires oh yeah right
and so which is an incredibly wealthy
Studio loyal to the cause and you say
like we're giving you the keys we need
your help then you have to kind of
accept that they're going to maybe come
in and say like you're not hitting right
and what you're doing is wrong and that
would make some sense considering I
would argue that Sony has never truly
shown a capability of making something
unique and interesting in multiplayer
probably since the PS2 era right you
know when you talk about Socom and
Twisted Metal black and games like that
specifically
it like really think about it no you're
right Socom died a slow death no one
cared about mag Killzone had a hardcore
but small audience no one cared about
drawing to death unfortunately which I
thought was a pretty cool idea kill
strain was a stupid idea but to try to
make a MOBA and all these kinds of
things they have no idea what they're
doing and so maybe we shouldn't be
surprised but this is I think why people
say focus on the on the single player
stuff that you're good at and they're
saying we cannot survive doing that you
know like we can't survive because they
see this is what I'm saying with gentian
impact and hankai star Rail and those
kind of games they're dead serious about
these games you know they they know that
they can't compete in these spaces but
um but yeah yeah this is why I don't
think Sony should expand at all because
they're already clearly not able to
manage the studios they have with some
of the cancellations that next rocket
League man that next week I do have to
interrupt everyone because I did forget
on some key thing that attic is probably
gonna kill before
um so yeah uh I know people don't see
King but uh we we have his thoughts on
sad topic
um well iron Lords is brought to you
today by our new sponsor Sony's
mismanagement
have you ever had a project mismanaged
so bad that they've been promising it
for years
well hey we're here to call a spade of
spade and naughty dog has mismanaged
fractions it was supposed to be here
that's why that show was pissed poor
brought to you by your friend Jim dance
moves Ryan now
I know everyone thinks that Sony does an
incredible job
but Bungie didn't think so
Bungie walked in and said show me your
build
and guess what naughty dog did they
showed it and Sony said uh
[Music]
that's not it
so now fractions is not there and what
would have been a great show
maybe gave it a four if they would have
showed it
was definitely a three
so hey guys
enjoy your mismanagement and remember
today's sponsor is brought to you by
Sony's mismanagement team hopefully
we'll do better
so he got his thoughts on fractions Last
of Us fractions the King has spoken see
we gave y'all some thoughts for the king
you know he wouldn't want to be here he
had to do something very important but
uh we got his thoughts on fractions
let's get on a bad bit who's been
actually let's get let's see big clouds
let's get big cloud this time let's go
let's change it up order uh your
thoughts on this whole um Last of Us
factions situation who would I begin uh
so again it all started with a video I
was like you know
it's really like a rant over the fact
that we had to pay 70 again for the
remake of Last of Us there was no
batches included period no new mechanics
and you know a lot of people come at me
saying you know it's not needed because
we're gonna get it this year I thought
I'll say you know it it's best we have
it so that way there's no pressure you
know I mean on naughty dog to have to
rush this thing it's best we have it to
fall back on and you know build even
more anticipation because a lot of
people who are getting into this you
know they can play this at a better
frame rate better you know new mechanics
you know you can change it up a bit but
then we got the the tweet and ironically
they put the Tweet out after the
Showcase the day after the Showcase it
said the reason why it wasn't there hey
you know
a part of me was just like you know I
won the laugh somewhat just because of
how all the the ignorant replies I got
leading up to that particular tweet but
we're all talking how I feel about it I
mean it's just like
I don't even know how to spell because
they said if the Pearson is delayed I
mean we never got a release date to
begin with
basically the window is I just say that
it has a has a bigger window of you
waiting it's like you're ain't hearing
this for a minute yeah they never gave
us a release date what Neo said y'all
remember he said you'll be hearing more
about it
in this year he didn't say it's going to
flat out release this year so he could
have had a game play you know they could
have something revealed at us but you
know with Bungie now overseeing it you
know in a weird way I'm happy they got
that because that guarantees that
whatever they do come up with it will
you know I mean it will work in a sense
but
at the same time it's like this isn't
something that naughty dog has really
done proper at all if you look at all
the Uncharted games or multiplayer they
never really had this paint like you
know they never really had anything like
this
that where the industry is heading they
tried it with someplace they even tried
to a loot boxes I don't know if everyone
tried a four but the multiplayer for
that they tried it with that they didn't
really hit those shreds so the fact that
it's delayed it's just like well
okay uh what's next you know and that's
where you go back to the Showcase and
it's like yeah not much not much showing
after Spider-Man yeah not fair enough Mr
Bad bit I need yeah I thought sir how
are you feeling after this yeah
and for everyone who's staying extended
time if you got to leave please let me
know because I really appreciate y'all
for rocking here and first foremost
thank you for having me oh now trophy
rule uh you know my thoughts on this is
my only thing that I'm upset by this
news first off I was excited for
factions right or fractions
I'm a big fan I'm a big like freshers
of a chance oh my God oh my God
I feel like listen I naughty dog makes
some good multiplayer experiences that
I've really enjoyed right like fractions
uh the Uncharted multiplayer is pretty
darn good I loved Uncharted 2's
multiplayer is it a lot of fun but
they're not like the great multiplayer
experiences and the thing that I have
regrets on is that they spent four years
making this game
where they could have been out here
making something else right so when
people go oh look at how can Bungie have
that much sway or that much power I
think that's the wrong question to ask
there's a reason why they asked this
game right they saw something that was a
fundamental issue we just don't know
what the issue was this game was four
plus years in development well this game
was supposed to be an add-on to Last of
Us Part Two it's easy to say that this
thing had at least been restarted once
or twice right
um so this thing had some problems and
you have someone like Bungie step in and
go okay whoa there we have issues in
these areas of said game and now you're
seeing you know the repercussions of
that I don't know if it's going to be
outright canceled I would think that for
how much time they've put into it
there's maybe something you could put
together in a like a a Last of Us Part
three but at the same exact time
it it's just it's disappointing as a
naughty dog fan to know that first off
it's exciting that they got other
projects right that's awesome that's
great to hear but it's also damage
control because those projects aren't
coming anytime soon quick yeah because
you're going to leave um yeah do you
think that one the new IP project do you
consider that new IP or do you consider
Last of Us three also like a new IP
Facebook a game with the torch when they
saw that live action and game reveal
where the girl was in the cave with the
little torch like they showed it briefly
I mean if it was a new IP they'd
probably say a new IP when they like new
experience I'm like that's that's
probably the Last of Us Part oh so you
feel new IP yeah I'm going to get your
thoughts on that yeah so at the end of
the day for me I this news really sucks
and when I when I heard it first I was
like all right this I I I I was thinking
all right we won't see it for for a good
year or two but then after the Jason for
it again it's a bummer but I'd rather
have no game than a bad game so as long
as they get it out of the way now they
make something special with The Last of
Us Part three I I don't much mind no
doubt well look before we give you the
proper exit you know what I'm saying oh
man Mr Babbitt always coming through
some of the best takes and one of the
most loyal members of the PlayStation
Nation very informative telephoned
people where they can find that trophy
room and more of your uh commentary
of course of course you can find me on
the trophy room a PlayStation podcast
made by the players for the players
where me and my best friend Kyle talk
about the latest the greatest in all
things PlayStation each and every
Thursday and we record live on Wednesday
nights at 8pm uh find us on Spotify
Apple podcast wherever you get your
podcast services and the video version
on YouTube at PS trophium guys thank you
all so much the legend Mr Batman put
your links in the description brother
great context always fun when I am
invited say what's up to the Ninja for
me the fellow ninja performing
absolutely yeah everybody give uh give
Kyle some love man he's had a like a
real terrible week so make sure at
Mister okay on on Twitter you know show
them some love Yeah show them some love
good to do it man and what I love about
you guys you guys are actually on the
floor talking to the devs yeah yeah I
actually have interviews and actually
real talk you almost I almost forgot
this week we are interviewing Ben Starr
the voice actor of Clive from Final
fantasy 16. nice 49 yeah 49 minute
interview it's one of our our favorites
uh the man's the man's one of us the
man's a gamer the man is on his way of
planning Resident Evil 4 remake
uh such a such a fun interview so yeah
make sure to tune in this week on the
trophy and before you go three bit says
you're the other best bit just
yeah now three bit is the better bit
than me man fellow developer out there
absolutely yo bad boy have a good one
brother and then thank you for coming
through on the Cameo last minute
appreciate y'all man appreciate y'all
appreciate you in Trophy Room salute
the daring one sir your thoughts on the
uh Last of Us fractions last fractions
gonna be able to get over fractions yeah
um so I mean maybe Colin can help tag
team me on this one because he's going
to have a little more industry
experience
that was hilarious
when they say that they that they're
pulling resources from this project I
mean isn't that kind of a death know
that this is pretty done at this point
yeah I would assume so I mean I think
the only
he
it's interesting because like they could
they have multiple options they could I
don't think Bungie came in and said it
was bad right so Bungie is saying that
this can't work as a long time as a long
term correct and so now I think Sony has
to think about well do we want to like
put a bow on this thing and get it out
do we want to throw it away do we want
to attach it to a future Last of Us
product or whatever I think that they
just have to figure that out at this
point but you don't move people onto
other projects if they're in you know
active development it might be in some
sort of review now and maybe they'll
bring everyone back to it when they
figure that out but this is what I was
saying earlier about
I don't think Sony needs to get any
bigger than they are right now in terms
of their first parties because they if
if you're they've always given naughty
dog a ton of rope and in fact Naughty
Dog didn't even have producers until
The Last of Us I want to say or maybe
even the last maybe even Uncharted 4
which is crazy if you know anything
about game development that is nuts to
make games without producers nuts and
they somehow just did it and so I think
they've just been given a lot of leeway
and this might really Rain have Sony
Reign them in internally which is
interesting to think about it but yeah
that basically does mean that I would
think no no no no and so your point
about like the options like I I can't
imagine they're gonna put a bow on it
and ship it because I think you end up
redfalling yourself if you do that
because I I kind of feel that that's a
little bit of what happened with redfall
is that Microsoft I don't think wanted
to take another L for having another one
of those games they promised in 12
months flipping again and they're like
out let's go it's it's out the door uh I
I think Sony would far rather cancel it
and eat that thing uh rather than ship
something that's not up to Naughty Dog
quality because I mean when have we seen
Naughty Dog myth when we seen Insomniac
myths we don't see the big you know
Flagship Studios from Sony missed and
but they would rather it's a lot of
money to just oh it's good but you gotta
keep that PlayStation
and I'm sure Carla can speak that
sometimes in this industry unfortunately
where that bottom dollar is more
important than something else yep well
the important thing yeah I'm sorry go
ahead I didn't mean to interrupted
I just want to say you can't have the
say that you're the the premium
experience and have you have your one of
your Flagship Studios put a turd out
there uh and I think Sony is much rather
much more willing to eat that than I
think Microsoft was I think they wanted
to get uh Arcane Austin on to the next
project because they didn't I don't
think they felt like they could save
that and I think Cog by you and Maddie
and Tom's Impressions uh on the last
show between what you saw and what we
got of red fall yeah I don't think there
was any saving that and so they're like
we're done let's go
and then they're going to get what they
get out of it which is Game Pass content
calling your your bottle you're about to
you're about to say something yeah I
just think if an important component to
the equation is that they probably
didn't intend for any of this to become
public so that if they were going to
release the game as it was it wasn't
going to become it wasn't going to be in
this thing of like well we're just
kicking it out the door and they
probably if that was going to be one of
the options that were on the table they
probably have to rethink that now
because it's going to have some sort of
taint but we have to remember too that
Naughty Dogs
um Naughty Dogs kind of I don't want to
say decline that's really that's what
party was one of the greatest games ever
made it's like not even close in my
opinion
um but they did release and put their
name on a port a PC Port although iron
Galaxy probably did a lot of the work on
it that they
for for the last of us um part one on PC
that is not good
and totally in it almost sold a half a
million copies in that state which is
crazy when you think about it but um
yeah but so I just think that they
they're neat there clearly is a review
going on it might just line up with the
end of the fiscal year which is possible
but it's clear that they're pulling
plugs and moving things around now and
um yeah that could that could really
speak to a level of mismanagement and
it's it's just it's interesting that
it's happening to their their most
prolific Studio I I don't know that it
could be argued now that maybe Insomniac
is kind of the crown jewel not because
of the quality of games which is high
but because they're releasing games
because well you've been pumping this
Insomniac still good I just want to know
if you do you agree with Colin on that
big cloud do you you could
Insomniac is number one
moving on moving on Darren are you good
because I want to get to get all the
rest of the pathways yeah go ahead all
right no no doubts I was just gonna say
like in terms of uh that little argument
I I do want to in Sonic is a very well
durable Studio but until they make
something like on the caliber of The
Last of Us I can't give that to them I
feel like they're they're the most
consistent company that that's for sure
but as far as like you gotta have that
game that hits like Last of Us Part Two
or Last of Us did before I can really
like just give you the best studio they
have slow mo says someone must be saying
that some neck because they've been
their best for three years
Spider-Man's the best-selling single
PlayStation published game ever so I
think that that's also an important
component of why they yeah
Spider-Man 2 is more like gonna break
that record more likely for what we just
saw I'm just saying so if you make the
most money addict you you don't get I
mean I I feel that and you know we've
been saying that phase four was was a
downgrade compared to the previous phase
that still made a lot of money billion
dollars this movie billion dollars that
movie look Marvel is hot
the ratchet and Clay Club what's up bro
it is awesome so salute to you for not
taking me but continue your thoughts sir
on this whole thing but that was that
was it yeah that is pretty much it like
but I don't want to like like downgrade
the the
the amount of insomnia because literally
and Sonic is doing what com uh what
Coalition did for Xbox one like but it
is put the PlayStation 5 on its back and
said it's okay buddy just sit back there
we got this production quality yeah
absolutely there's no question Lord
solve your thoughts Last of Us factions
fractions is uh is being delayed and you
know I forgot to mention I just let me
say real quick uh factions it's cool I
probably won't go play it uh you know I
hope that like
I want to beat you on this topic yeah I
hope BG and then get the game that they
want you know um I'm I'm very curious on
exactly
what critiques
Bungie had for them
because I'm curious if it's like a like
if a Halo infinite thing where it's like
look you got solid foundation for a game
we're just worried about engaging terms
right the live service long-term
continued engagement right yeah so it's
just and that's one of those case
scenarios where it's like
is a good foundation for a game or is
the money that you can make not going to
generate enough money that Bungie feels
it's worth investing into and did the
scope get too big because I know damn I
wish BG was here because he's such a
multiplayer yeah
I watch your videos it was funny
um one of his things and I was curious
at it because you close to BG it was
like well why credit you just give us
what you gave us with one multiplayer
right and just kind of reskin that so to
speak it's because that's like I'm
making the money that's selling right
yeah okay you won because he loves that
first one
that's a multiplayer like that that you
can you can argue that that type of
style of a multiplayer is like an old
Vanguard like it's like the old Call of
Duties like sure they still put money in
that Call of Duty but don't get it
twisted the future of Call of Duty is
war zone
no fair enough fair enough Lord saw have
you been patient what's your thoughts on
the fractions actions I just want to
thank your attic for folding all of my
points with your one more thing yeah I
appreciate you appreciate that shout out
but no um yeah that's exactly what I was
thinking I when I heard about this the
game
being sort of scaled back and reassessed
I said yes I said yes because
um
I like you know I didn't play a whole
lot of it but that original factions for
the first game
feels like it was special and it feels
like within the scope of what you
naughty dog can do considering their
expertise and I just think expounding
upon that in the sequel where you
already take the new mechanics of of uh
of The Last of Us Part Two that makes it
feel more like Splinter Cell than
anything else and then you add a level
of verticality to that
um new weapons and obviously
um new locales and you have a
multiplayer that I think is pretty damn
engaging and it still Falls within the
scope of what I think naughty dog is
capable of managing when you have a
naughty dog come in when you when first
of all when you decide to make it a
larger scope project this thing unto
itself
I immediately thought about what
happened with Halo infinite
and turning that game into a
free-to-play game a live service game
where the amount of dedication you have
to have from that studio to keep that
running and keep people engaged
is is far beyond the scope of what they
were willing or or knew that they had to
invest in it and so to now look at this
you know this Naughty Dog project and
Bungie looking and saying hey it's not
engaging enough
I'm I I worry that
the way that Bungie sees the world oh
careful isn't necessarily is it
necessarily what is right for a
multiplayer game coming out of naughty
dog and what I mean by that obviously
quality gameplay moment-to-moment
gameplay but this idea of long-term
engagement this this live thing that
needs to live for God knows how long I
don't necessarily see that as something
that is imperative for that game to be
successful not to say that I wanted to
drop a game that that people are going
to be done with in a month right but the
idea Bungie the Bungie's way of thinking
about live service and long term is
consid has a considerably longer tale
than what you would expect from a
multiplayer that is attached to a single
player game right and maybe that level
of multiplayer doesn't even exist
anymore right maybe that's just not a
reality they want to invest in but for
me
a reality where that where factions too
is just
more maps more uh more characters more
weapons applying all of the different
changes to gameplay they apply to the
base game to that multiplayer makes for
a pretty exciting and engaging game in
my view without having to have this
broadened scope of we need the game to
last 10 years what is the road map for
10 years
um
again that is great for a certain type
of game I don't feel that all
multiplayer games have to be that
um especially that one in particular
because again
who does that fall to to manage at that
point as good as naughty dog is their
expertise is a certain is in a certain
Lane you're asking them now if you do
make that game and you release that game
and that game is has the expectation of
living for God knows how long with all
these updates and sort of Engagement
that you have to continue to create with
your base is is Bungie bid it out to do
that right
to do right well no you well I'm sorry
not bungee is Naughty Dog sorry oh
outfitted to do that sorry not bungee
bungee is absolutely outfitted together
right this Naughty Dog outfit we'll do
that because there's no it doesn't say
there's an expectation that Bungie is
going to take the reins on making sure
that this game continues to be supported
and continues to be engaged it's one of
those things where it seems like they
walk in nah that's good that's not it
that's good see y'all later like almost
like think about it like a consultant
right like a right you have a bring a
consultant in and it has an expertise in
a specific area exactly and they're
going to go around and make an
assessments and you know to your point
you know up to what so far what naughty
dog has presented right well so and
that's a good point to solve because
like if they came in and they said like
this isn't gonna work as games as a
service and they are assuming that's
what they came in and said and they were
looking at releasing this as a 70 game
then like that was gonna that was gonna
flop I mean it was just wasn't going to
happen and conversely if you make it
free to play then are you gonna make
your money on it whereas and maybe kind
of what Colin said for option three
earlier can you end up with uh tacking
that on to Last of Us Part three and now
you have a great single player game with
a standard multiplayer game to your
point where now you've got a combination
of something that can work together
right yeah yeah so that that's my take
on it and not not everything has to be
this this humongous service this is so
obsessive I know this is my brother
fighting back
bro it was my thing is bro it was add-on
mode you ain't got to play it was at all
for certain people but I feel when
you're going with it it was more than
that
it was great I'm with BG I thought it
was great and I always put pushing Sony
as much as I give Xbox to smoke hashtag
just one I want the cinemat I give
PlayStation the same smoke where's just
two where's the the multi-player Focus
because I know you're capable at some
point now granted because I I don't like
when people say oh they tried now we
ain't talked yeah
it's just like it's just like Xbox has
dropped the uh the ball a couple times
to try to make that single player
experience do you get right back in that
workshop and you keep trying I want you
to sleep till it's done I'm not the guy
that's freaking out over you know the
live servants balance stuff but I will
say this I will say this again I gotta
get Madison bredrin you know what I'm
saying Long Island Viper here in the
building
um his flowers he he did predict the
shift right and the fact that this is
where it's going guys like this is where
it's going we could throw you know rocks
at the cloud all we want but there's
going to be about not saying that the
single player hashtag just won cinematic
experience is going away but they're
going to invest in it because the thing
is if you land with just one of them
right if you land if you may 10 you
hoping at least two to three going hit
and if you got two to three it could
generate a lot of revenue from them and
they're looking at this stuff now
granted there's a lot of risk so to me
when you bring in a bungee you are
trying to mitigate that and you're
trying to pull someone who I got see a
lot of little haters in the chat but um
for people who don't like Destiny um the
numbers say otherwise the numbers say
1.3 active million I'm 3.3 million um
active users as of right now on a Down
Season right then you're talking about
math and you talk about the creator of
Halo what are we talking about so again
it's one thing to not like Destiny but
let's not talk about it yeah let's let's
get our biases out of the way as far as
longevity and who does this live service
thing few can match Bungie so Sony in my
opinion made the correct decision by
saying hey you look at our portfolio
right you see and assess what we have
going on they looked at that that
surprising to me is this I shouldn't say
surprise but because naughty dog's
reputation to me is so immaculate like
Colin said they like they you can make
the argument that they literally are the
goat studio for PlayStation Last of Us
is arguably the greatest game of all
time right you can make these arguments
it is interesting to hear this report
that Bungie made the suggestion from a
long-term stability you know
sustainability and engagement standpoint
they don't think that what they
presented would have those legs I mean
that's hard to believe it's not that
it's hard to believe at that point but
the part that Sony
agreed with the cosine and allowed
Bungie to basically part of why they
brought him in right but it's generally
you're absolutely right it's just for me
genuine Nexus yeah and just for me it is
interesting to hear because if you could
pair you know Studio to Studio it's just
it's just an interesting thing to hear
that's all I was gonna say but as far as
um you know this whole situation you
know look
I think it's big you know that Sony has
made decisions I'm very curious on the
future set of um uh the factions portion
you know I do want it to exist I do want
them to have some take on it even if it
is some somewhat scaled back or like
Darren you set a good point like what if
they say okay we hold this back for
right now maybe we do represent this
with three and then give three that
whole package right because that's how
last divorce buff one was kind of
presented you had this the single plane
and you had this faction thing so look I
I think I want to give practice audio on
this I actually
I like when the pipeline is checked I
like when you people go in there and say
no that that's not it they see the leaks
and they're like let's fix that instead
of instead of waiting for it to explode
I I like that I like that level of
quality control and check it across
December line before you say finished
and push something out that is not going
to be received well and it could be it
could Sully your reputation so true look
at suicide yeah that that's where I'm at
you know what I'm saying so at the end
of the day you know I think this is it's
very interesting to learn this kind of
stuff I'm very intrigued by this kind of
stuff I do realize Bungie's influence in
the building and you know and to see
what's going on there and um yeah I'm
very curious hopefully this thing comes
out but I'll let anyone else any further
thoughts before we War anything else
anybody got on this or we good yeah
please please yeah real quick I was just
gonna say I think
there are certainly signs that we have
to pay attention to that
first second and third party
relationships are in different kind of
categories with PlayStation but that
first and second parties in a little bit
of a weird place right now you know yeah
the the uh there are so like the the
whole monoculture gorilla that I was
saying before like I'm really concerned
about that and I'm really interested in
what happens at Bend and how much power
they kind of gave those guys to steer in
their own Direction and do all these
other things I I do think Sony needs to
Claw at its only Advantage which is
quality like like when that's all it has
going for it so once if they ever if
they let that go
and especially from a studio like
naughty dog I think that that's a bad
sign for them so I think that I we have
to ask ourselves as PlayStation fans do
we ideally we would want all of these
games to come out and most of the time
you don't even hear anything about the
games that are canceled and sometimes
Sony just lets games go and they come
out anyway like remember me is a good
example of that right that was supposed
to be a second party PlayStation game so
sometimes they find their way out but I
think that games like the Last Guardian
too that game was in development health
for a long time a long time yeah they
still let it come out exactly and was um
it seemed like it was obvious that it
was gonna be canceled and all that and
they did let it come out but I I just I
look at these different relationships
and I just I hope that Sony contains
yeah I would my stance as a PlayStation
gamer is I want I would want quality
games so if that means fewer games and
that's what's necessary then I guess
that's what we would get ideally we
would have both cannons firing at the
same time which would be pretty sweet
but I just don't think they can let the
reputational damage to Naughty Dog
happen to it because I think that that's
just too serious I mean I think they saw
what happened to BioWare they saw what
happened to CD projekt Red they saw what
happened to some of these other teams
you just don't want to mess around with
that and I dude I really hope it
underlines a new stance that they're
going to take hopefully which is say
like why don't you let your teams that
make single player games continue to
focus on those and let your teams and
let and bring in new teams as you've
been doing we've used the reference on
on sacred symbols that they used to
really like getting in the bed and like
dating and like you know release a game
or at least two games and you can see
the courtship going and then sometimes
they abort them with Quantic dream and
sometimes it goes through
um with a lot of these other teams and
now I we call them one night now we call
them one night stands like they they
they get with Haven they're like all
right yeah everything's good we're in
Alpha whatever pre-alpha okay yeah fine
we'll we'll get with you like they they
seem to be under the gun and it's clear
they're going to spin off part of the
company Sony part of the company to
raise Capital to buy more Studios and to
buy more things and that sucks because I
don't think that this necessarily
portends of their ability we often
criticize Microsoft for their clear
inability to manage their Studios
um Sony is already running into that
problem I think you know look at media
molecule man I mean again do you think
it's like they've never been in this
realm hold on one second can I want to
attack the chat
um I want to be in my feelings and
attack the chat slow mo backs I gotta
come get you because I love you brother
but your bias is ridiculous now look he
says right Green's better than us or
Bungie no one is denying the greatness
of ryegades the issue brother is your
hate for Destiny supersedes your
intelligence or what is actual fact on
Console he's trolling me he got me today
he got me I'm out of
tweeting to dig it at me and I'm
breaking protocol yes you got me you
know in your heart bungee so stop it
all right I'm out of my feelings now
continue I'm sorry
like they never really been in this
position you really think about it
they've mostly just been known as that
single player Juggernaut you know I mean
do you and now the things do you guys
think that because I think Microsoft has
been expanding too rapidly too uh I do
you think that this might continue with
both students because to me
you can't I think it's a little bit
better on Microsoft because at least
they're picking up a whole arms that
I've always worked together uh but it's
like even though you're picking up
companies that so that manage themselves
they still have to be checked by the
company that bought them like so it's
just like I feel like the consolidation
is getting so rapid that they're like
we'll buy them first and this is for
Sony too and then we'll find that system
to monitor everyone afterwards like
yeah they're taking the risk up front
the Sony is taking the risk up front now
they never ever ever ever ever did that
until this generation the only Studio
that Sony ever bought that it didn't
work with first was psygnosis and that
was before PlayStation even existed and
so I've said that over and over and over
again literally every Studio they have
bought released at least one in multiple
sometimes two three four five six ten
and you know 15 with the in case of
Insomniac Games as a second party before
they get but I think Sony feels under
the gun and I actually think that comes
from Microsoft I don't think Sony wants
to play this game at all yeah I agree I
I don't think it's clear that Sony
doesn't want to play this game they do
not want to get into this mergers and
Acquisitions
crossovers it's two philosophies at odds
and Sony being I feel proactive to make
sure that they don't lose any ground in
that space that Microsoft is trying to
go to their mindset's like if we don't
spend this money and buy Insomniac
Microsoft might buy them next year
that thing where you just constantly
work with with these IPS and no one's on
untouching these Studios they're like at
any time tinting can pop in and buy
something Google can pop in and buy
something Netflix is getting in they can
buy some Microsoft just buy a whole
publisher like yeah no I get it I get it
yeah that's why I think it's I mean
though I I I don't think they're I truly
don't believe that there are very many
obvious targets for Sony to to acquire
whatever they acquire now is going to be
weird in some sense Bungie was weird and
I guess makes some sense but when you
see I was saying before that I I can
imagine two of four major Japanese
Publishers being bought by yeah
[Music]
uh Square Enix and Bandai Namco yeah um
they all like they clean it all like
Spurs kind of already like one foot in
you think about this is what the way
they've been part of it they haven't
come to terms on foam Stars yet
[Laughter]
all the folks out there that maybe don't
have a stinky switch like that's gonna
be their Splatoon
talking about my last thing on on this
is you know when they acquired Bungie it
was it was a weird situation as it was
like they bent over backward to make
that acquisition they're in their own
kind of spot over here oh yeah and the
rest of the studios are over here and
now you got the new acquisition
kind of home power over all the other
Studios that have been there for a
minute and I I hope that that doesn't
start because there were already kind of
some eyebrows raised when they got well
we're gonna make our games and they're
going to go everywhere and and it's
going to be like we weren't even
acquired we just happened to have Sony
on us now now they got some what seems
to be some power over the flagship
Studio I hope that doesn't create a boat
a little bit I hear what you go I think
that's a good point let's go I recall I
go some level because I think that King
has alluded to this in reference to
almost like the new the new member of
the family right and the new member of
family having this this level of power
there's one side of me that I do see
what you're saying there's another part
of me that says well it's power but in
this specific space right of live
service and multiplayer kind of thing
but it's a good point Colleen is going
to say anything before um it looked like
he was going to jump in you had
something to say I was just saying I
thought that was a really great point
that you you that that kind of stuff
matters I was
um when I worked at IGN we were in the
same family as like a bunch of other
sites and I know that a lot of the other
sites felt that way about IGN you know
that like why do these guys have control
and power why do they get the money why
do they get the budget and all those
kinds of things and it does seem unfair
and you've been there longer and this
and that the other thing and those
Dynamics do matter you just hope that
Sony understands that and Sony's
supposed to be a pretty good place to
work Microsoft's frankly supposed to be
a pretty good place to work too
um and so you hope that they're just
keeping their people financially you
know Tethered to the companies and able
to do what they do but hopefully they
can start to differentiate between these
two lanes and keep them apart and I but
I think they would make the argument
that they would be like well what about
Sucker Punch you know and it's like well
what about them and it's like well they
made this awesome multiplayer mode
real quick do you think that they should
you know maybe when a studio has a good
idea or something like uh what is called
Ray what was that called No Legends
Legends it was called ghost Legends when
they have good Concepts like that like I
do think factions is still a good
concept uh you know maybe Bungie don't
like it but I I feel like there's some
something you could do to fix that
because a lot of people did like the
other one
um you know where they had these
Concepts maybe to have another studio
and just like that main Studio that
makes a single player game they just
code code design it with them yeah
that's not old school I mean that's the
way it used to happen in the PS3 era you
know um where like a lot of you think
about Bioshock 2's multiplayer and these
other things where they're spun off I
just think they need to have an older
point of view about maybe folding some
of these things into their 70 games the
way it used to be like games aren't
released like that anymore and that
maybe I do they know the Telemetry
they're probably like you guys have no
idea what you're talking about no one
would buy that no one would play that
and they're probably looking at their
data too it was just last quarter that
more people were playing PS5 than PS4 so
I think they look at it where they're
like we have a little bit of time to
extract value out of this but I think
that they need to be deliberate in their
approach not only from a quality
standpoint like we were saying but just
from a Time standpoint they're competing
with all these different games too so
you don't want to put something out
there that gets two hours of of
someone's time or two weeks or two days
or whatever I just think it's it's it
makes sense to me but we'll see what
happens no no look I want to be
respectful of everybody's time because
we are going extremely long yeah we do
have one of the topics so all Colin I
just wanna already
thank you for your stomach get to leave
sorry you have to go yeah I have a roll
call at three o'clock it's over I mean
my LSM brother uh sacred symbols for the
best part play the best PlayStation
podcast let's be careful let's be
careful let's be careful we know we got
to tell we got to speak it into
existence and talk the truth you know
what I mean look you guys been killing
it for a long time it's always a
pleasure uh podcasting with you Rick and
the fine people find you what else you
have got going on Sir yeah thank you for
your kind words I'm pretty sure your
audience a lot of your audience hates me
but I like being here with you guys
thank you thank you for for having me
it's much appreciated
um yeah we're at Last Stand media on
patreon it's the biggest fan-funded
games uh media Network and history and
we're really super happy about that Cog
is the co-host of our Xbox podcast to
finding Duke so you can check that out
every week sacred symbols and sacred
symbols plus go up three times a week
now
um so yeah we're we're doing great and
we appreciate everyone's support and
yeah come check us out if you'd like we
appreciate that and thank you for
inviting me I I do always always got to
give balance perspective um your opinion
is always valued and the ILP Community
does not hate you we have a few people
who are in their feelings because they
wanted to throw tomatoes at a certain
platform today
I wouldn't get the vibe that I'm kind of
like the start like people get mad at me
for things I didn't say or do right so
like it's like well he said this but
what about this I'm like I didn't say
that
what are you talking about a lot of it
is just like it's like you know you can
throw your fruit at me if you like it's
fine I bet you can't be hearing rumors
about himself like dude this sounds like
this dude sounds like an a oh
one thing we always promote here and
what I like is that we could all you
know me and you agree disagree on a
disagree on a ton of stuff but the thing
is we have that respect to agree or
disagree and hear each other out and I
love that platform on LSM and on IOP and
it's always a pleasure to have you man
enjoy your day it's like a it's like I
said on Twitter it's like you know you
can disagree with our guests you can
hate our guests but we're still going to
give perspectives and New Perspectives
and we're not cool
IOP was built around not being an echo
chamber it's always going to be that
talk then talk at it well I appreciate
everybody's in the chat being messy wait
Jackie's idiot oh
yeah
thanks for having him on shout out to
Jeffy the legend I love Greg Greg Miller
I appreciate you guys thank you again
have a great day weekend shout out by
the way to all the families out there
who lost someone yes in engagements
overseas no we appreciate you all right
nice to talk to you too all right
brother have a good one Chaffee always
good to see you brother no doubt good to
see you up in there being messy
I always be like kind of gauging who I'm
gonna send the IOP Community to after
the podcast
we we went no he he did his whole show
it's like our show be so long sometimes
I'll be like look man I'm looking at the
end because I'm sitting I'm like okay
I'm gonna send them to Jeff now he's in
our soup now he's in our chat
before though no doubt yeah it was
actually a really really good episode
really engaging episode all right we do
have to take care of business right so
yes we do so I'm gonna pay the bills
actually before that and then we'll do
the super chat so Dustin Dustin Goins is
the last one that I got uh just in case
any other ones come in all right cool
cool give me a moment okay this is gonna
be a fun one all right let the man get
his balls off
all right
everyday
now
that little bit of poetry which
incidentally is about an elephant on a
bicycle like on a trapeze wire is
Unfortunately The Last Remnant of five
plus years of extensive French language
study which was also very very expensive
now for me learning a new language
especially French was a bit easier
because as a Spanish speaker the
similarities in the romance languages
just make it easier like Italian French
and even a little Portuguese
but more than 30 years removed from
those teachings the only things I
remember are of course the curse words
and the nursery rhymes that they usually
teach two-year-olds to so uh yeah that
is you know I get it how I'm probably
like a fringe case when it comes to
language learning right the truth is
that for most of most of us learning a
second language in high school or
college isn't exactly a high point in
our academic careers
now thanks to Babel though the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscriptions this there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you'll be traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
your family or just have some free time
Babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you'll actually use in the
real world
so I chose French right when I jumped
back into Babel simply because I already
had a history with it and the fact of
the matter is and stop me if you've
heard this before I work a lot of damn
hours and I don't do that for no reason
right so when I do have time to send
with my family and my friends I want to
be able to enjoy the fruits of that
labor and for me one of those things
that I'm definitely preparing to do is
travel more with my wife so I've been to
France once in my life and I would love
nothing better and to go to France and
uh you know show off in front of my wife
with my uh my French Acumen you know as
I uh as I accidentally like order wrong
meals and things like that so that's my
reason for coming back to to to French
in particular when it comes to Babel now
that was 15 minute lessons make it the
perfect way to learn a new language on
the go babble's expertly crafted lessons
are built around real life you learn how
to have practical conversations about
travel relationship business and more
other language learning apps use AI for
their lessons plan lesson plans but
Babel lessons were created by over 100
language experts their teaching methods
have been scientifically proven to be
effective with Babel you can choose from
14 different languages including Spanish
French Italian and German
plus Babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent which is of utmost importance you
can you can be speaking another language
but if it doesn't sound like the way
it's supposed to sound like it trust me
it's not good not a good thing
there are so many ways to learn with
Babel in addition to lessons you can
access podcasts Games videos stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee so start
your new language learning Journey today
with Babel right now you can get up to
55 off your subscription when you go to
babble.com ironlords that's babel.com
iron Lords for up to 55 off your
subscription battle language for life
all right okay so what the uh
let me roll with you I'm a bureau with
you okay you doing the the classic I'm
gonna do this because I want to go I I
want to learn different languages so I
could just talk smack people on fortnite
in different languages I want to start
in English and end in Spanish I want to
start French and end in English I wanna
I want people to think I'm different
people I'm going so hard on me yeah it's
all about here learning whole poems and
I'm like damn thank you look better
2015. oh we got okay the French
Community we agree the French Lords
agree okay
let me find out there one too okay keep
in mind like all the ads we were to you
guys you know they're all in the
description you know
you definitely go down there use our
code definitely helps out the podcast
yeah absolutely and we appreciate uh you
know all the support you guys through we
had over a thousand people in here today
it's because of the support you guys
that we are
yeah you know what I'm saying like
remember this is just the Jacksons
Michael is not here and we're still able
to do this so it's it's very important
you know that you guys support and
because of your support it's allowing us
this you know these opportunities
you know hopefully hopefully we'll we'll
get some content for you guys next oh
for sure we definitely gonna get that
anyway so let's get the super jacket
super chats was come in let's get these
super chats okay let me read the last
two that came in uh we got Joe Repco AKA
flame
it was me okay I shut down factions
sorry
all right all right there we go that was
probably for the best Lord betrayed I
forgot yeah it went two thousand yeah I
said man you fix some thank you thank
you oh yeah he killed that he killed
that bro okay now let me go backwards
okay so we got Dustin goings five dollar
Super Chat actually I'll just I'll go
all the way to the top now then yeah
starting Robert Kelly Two Dollars who
was chat who's hyped for porn stars the
next Square Banger
whoa whoa sir it's like Limelight the
game you remember when I talked about
Limelight and yes the bubble parties I
remember them listen all you need to do
is is make this game a limelight ask
party okay we're gonna make it add the
drugs oh fornication Studio 54 of the
game before the game you have me Carol
Goldberg
as characters and it'd be a banger
that's all you New York Life like that
life was wow back in the day y'all trust
trust then we got Raiden blade uh
remember for two years five pound super
chat so hey media where are your
articles about how about Sie showcase
calling your media what are your
thoughts about the lack of siee first
party games is Jim's is it is it Jim's
way or your way
[Laughter]
uh here for them let's go yeah you got
your you got those you got those
then we got tsws gaming member for one
month hamster building two dollar Super
Chat uh what past play State what past
PlayStation showcase was worse than this
one
uh yeah it's kind of hard like even
flute flute man was like they were
showing good stuff yeah so yeah and we
got Raiden blade again member for two
years five pound Super Chat firewalk
looks like they want to have the answer
to Starfield I mean look at the color of
the CGI shown Concord whatever see it in
see it in five years that is stick to it
what is going what's this is what
happened when we leave our young and
unattended for too long and these type
of things kind of happen I don't know
what's happening mask is that I don't
know what is going on
it's good to you sir I can't with this
man right now
actors in blackface
I'm
look look I can get canceled for that
don't worry
um
hold on a second there we have so yeah
firewall I don't know I mean it's if
you're just going by the colors I I
don't know about it trying to match
Starfield yeah so
we got Gerald back remember for two
years five dollar Super Chat it's
obvious the games of the service games
transition is going to be rough for the
Sony fan base but business is business
all hail the IOP
it's a little salute thank you
then we have our Geeks you need ten
dollars just pointing out games like
Knack exists PlayStation has had
stinkers it isn't the end of the world
not sure why there's an assumption that
Playstation only puts out good games
they've had bad first and second party
games
narrative narrative oh man they they
doing
they got caught they got calling stuff
everywhere on Twitter right now oh
really he said why we argued about with
the multiplayer everything should be on
everything with that conversation
ah they going to town with that you know
that the nation is upset right now we
understand there's a lot of the anger
the nation the nation
the nation
the nation's Obsession domination
then we got Robert Kelly Two Dollars
Super Chat link use the ultra hand to
make that cue thing
yeah wow
yeah we got JD game remember for two
years ten dollar Super Chat call in your
analytical when I think you know
PlayStation well so my question to you
is if you were Microsoft and wanted to
beat PlayStation what third party games
would you go for what Acquisitions what
marketing techniques uh yeah sorry we
weren't able to read all this during the
topics but it would just it would have
been crazy yeah he did mention the
acquisition towards the end yeah argue
Jenny once again remember for one year
two dollar Super Chat Logitech gcloud is
350 Q not likely cheaper ah the gcloud
is a kind of an everything machine
though so this is specifically for
PlayStation I do not think it's going to
be 350.
yeah three maybe yeah I mean at least
Max I better not be more than three I
mean
you got a dual sense in there yeah
that's so 70 off the rip yeah
how good is that screen plus the
networking yes I mean the eight inch
screen it's a big screen too yeah plus
if you figure if you feel sorry about to
come out and be 300. if you figure their
Elite controller is how much
wait was it 270 or something no the
controller it's 270 for the elite
controller the pl PlayStation yeah
Playstation One The Edge yeah let me see
it's like 200. I know it's like 200 yeah
okay so
maybe a little more than that yeah
wolf of Darkness 70 18 super check
greetings Colin Moriarty you're gaming
expertise is admired thoughts and
expectations for Xbox's upcoming
showcase Xbox's future interviews thank
you so you could get that one off right
now escaping I don't know who's on that
account but he said Colin said
exclusives don't matter I was just
spreading his message
behave yourself sir I know what you're
doing look at least you cut it up and
make it sound like something he did say
so that's all I asked yeah all context
mattered yeah exactly please
a part that makes the leather part look
crazy
that we have PS3 wide five dollar Super
Chat PSN coming back up drinking and
coming back up drinking episode of
Beyond was hilarious that was legendary
[Laughter]
okay Robert Kelly again five dollars
which at PS Studios must fuel away
seeing Bungie order the star player
around what do you all make a Bungie
throwing that Master Sword or people are
asking what Master says I literally have
no idea it was just laying there and I
grabbed it why was it laying there
uh
I remember that episode now you gotta
get to get now Cog has to wear the uh
the the Michael Myers
masks come on let's go let's go then we
have JD game remember for two years ten
dollars to be 10. how many black guys
can PlayStation take before it affect
sales we saw them take two this week
with the Showcase then factions and
slash Bungie and we know two and too
many could cause play a PS3 error
problem which leads us which what leads
us there I I it goes back to narrative I
think it's all narrative it kind of dies
down quick if the games are good it's
just
it'll blow over and that's it though he
said attic be having some wild parties
this weekend drop your keys at the noise
keys and cell phones at the door you
recorded this crazy good to you and we
have a sour blow 18.
wow continue I respect Colin but how's
the Sony showcase a B plus when Xbox
showcase has been criticized by having
little gameplay and lots of third-party
games we should keep the same energy I
love sacred symbols by the way all right
keep an energy and you hear what Colin
said it was a B plus unless it was
somewhere else he said it said it after
sacred when they yeah
uh X Don the otaku
five dollar super Jack Coleman finally
caught up the Sony after they released
all their safe sequels and remakes now
all the new stuff is behind expect 2024
to be dry as well all right let me go
see game development taking longer
though I know that X down the otaku
again two dollars Super Chat can't wait
for the conversations of mismanagement
I can't say I ain't saying it's getting
worse it's getting worse without people
now uh look apparently companies are
starting to write saying that Colin
Moriarty says he's heard that the second
PlayStation showcase is happening later
this year yeah y'all forgot about it
they go wrong with that you know they go
wrong with that yeah they go wrong with
that one am I allowed to make a video on
my own content I said yes
yeah let me see let me see Thai casar is
three dollar Super Chat this showcase
had Xbox One energy great show Lords I
think we specifically said that in our
private chat right after the show like
this has some real Xbox One energy uh
even through a little TV TV exactly
um I am Mike two dollar Super Chat did
Sony just do the Xbox next 12 month
showcase I don't know it was yeah there
was stuff a lot of 2024. shout out to
Paris he said PlayStation can take 43
more black eyes showcases don't matter
it's all about when games Do release
they aren't scoring 58 on Medicare facts
yeah you're right that's fine
narratives don't want to go so far and
Gamers Gamers will get over stuff
too is
even though that like redfall like
really under delivered to a lot of
people including myself like it
you're only as good as the old last game
yeah so what have you done for me Xbox
can literally drop a 50a for three years
in a row and then the moment they start
dropping those good and the people gonna
forget all about that year they're gonna
call it the dark time remember that time
yeah
us Gamers have short memories
should we expect a small show from Xbox
because of ABK I hope not
listening I want to be surprised and
delighted yes
surprise and Delight is the phrase
that's what I want listen just you know
just fine just fire the guy that you
hired to say exclusive just don't use
him
give me the bag though
I'll say exclude World exclusions
[Laughter]
we ain't gonna disrespect the king in
here we're gonna hold this line we made
it this far I hope
for the sake of Gamers of the Xbox for
real yeah for sure
because I mean so if you take the normal
like
Cadence of what used to be E3 you got
your your your big three given their
their showcases and if you got a flop
who wants another flop I mean
yeah nobody
super chess bro all right let me see
lydian Master member for six months Lord
silver the bigger question is can Colin
cap for this
yeah they was coming in with tomatoes
yo they was messy messy there you got
Spartan go 17 two pound Super Chat Sony
really finessed these dudes with
factions
fractions for the people that were
waiting on it for sure then we have Max
arthay two pound Super Chat Phantom
Blade zero equals abandon 2.0 damn I
don't do that don't do we even see what
abandon was that's what I'm saying bro
exactly oh yeah don't don't do that to
that that Phantom come on now then we
have JD gamer remember for two years ten
dollar Super Chat the worst thing that
PlayStation could do is release a bad
Naughty Dog game reputation is prices
and they'd ruin theirs they can't fight
a richer Microsoft and have a bad
reputation at the same time PlayStation
needs is rep
um
what's up
what what
I finished finished the Super Chat it's
a lot more yeah yeah just finish this
all right finished
remember for two years ten dollars
people ask what's the Nintendo magic how
they can excuse me how they can exist uh
against two larger richer Rivals it's
their reputation of fun and quality
without their without without them
they're nothing PlayStation has a
reputation for Quality to ruin it is
dumb
yes it is dumb to ruin it over some
multiplayer games for sure then we have
a hargit Chennai member for one year
five dollar Super Chat Spider-Man 2 May
sell a lot but keep in mind this is next
gen only and not coming to PC day and
date yeah it would take an incredible
attach rate to beat uh sm1
yeah but we're still we still got what
65 of a generation left yet I mean yeah
yeah it might not beat it now but over
time it will right and then yeah they're
not talking about you know monetaries as
it's just number of sales so unless they
pull a Houdini like oh that's on PS4
trouble
if they do that what's funny about that
they already did that with Miles yeah I
remember miles yeah
the king about that is I think the
reason they didn't say is because
they're going to say it's out for the
PlayStation oh I was like I was like
King that is the only one I will ever be
okay you realize how bad 20 will be but
if you come out there and say
Spiderman's who's on Playstation 4. yo I
don't think it's happening I think I
have that guarantee but
no I see it
or I get like a week of free
entertainment on Twitter yeah and then I
yeah
at that point I don't really give up
money I just give him his back so
for two years five pound Super Chat
Insomniac is a good Studio but is
supported by a massive IP that many love
same game three times in five years you
need to make and we'll sell but what's
the new
iPad
The Wolverine all right all right then
we have Shelley with the 10 pound Super
Chat naughty dog devs have come out
saying the game is fine not canceled
it's likely monetization that's the
problem it made a multiplayer game not a
live service game delay hopes to correct
that uh let me see I say make it seventy
dollars
all right
then we have jax 82 five dollar stupid
chat Bungie told naughty dog listen
y'all y'all saw what happened with the
Halo infinite we not going to let let
y'all go out like that it's not ready
give it more time that's how they said
it too that's how they did it
like that
gotta be careful what you wish for
let me see five dollar Super Chat the
longer game as a service lasts the more
of a clown show it becomes a man Chris
from sacred symbols said it best
no live service okay then we have rezu
five dollar Super Chat why don't why
don't they buy me hoyo with the bungee
treatment that is funny because if you
know Spanish mijoyo means something else
completely and leave PS Studio to do
what they do I'm not buying me hoyo
nothing
I am Mike five dollars Super Chat you
telling me the dab that invented sun
setting paid DLC entire planets Pinnacle
weapons and other content is what's
keeping us from factions
just keeping your engagement a little a
little less that's it
all right games is greater than Bunch
yes we already got that we've talked
so proud of my homie and Destiny slash
Bungie Stan Cognito people just if you
were just mad that the developer that
makes the game they truly hate is
calling the shots
[Music]
we can put your knees on that uh
yeah
tax 82 10 super chat when I played
Destiny for the first time I said oh
this is awesome but I don't understand
what the story is particularly what the
story is particularly Destiny one and
the repetitive doing the same Mission
over has potential okay and did you play
Destiny too different
back from the dead one remember for
three months Lord bronze Crucible and
Destiny 2 rarely gets new maps
matchmaking changes seasonally and few
new game modes get added is this really
who you want for Q a the first backup
did your biased you know what I don't
like about people like back for dead
Circle I love to build my brothers but
this is the most abusive thing how you
go or hating on something for months and
years oh they're terrible so what you
doing today oh I'm playing Destiny like
every day every day like I don't respect
that that
bashing something consistently day after
day yet you go back to the vomit you
bash every day I cannot respect it and
to your point
to his point as far as the QA the thing
he's talking about yes he's right about
the PVP portion of Destiny being
neglected it's clear all of them went to
Marathon because marathon's gonna have
dedicated servers and Itachi all that
other good stuff so yeah that's what's
happening there there is definitely a
transition there the key is going to be
if they going to backfill that with
position so I'll give him that but yeah
these dudes be killing me with this man
you know it's crazy too it's like
you know how many times have I come on
this podcast and I've talked mad smack
about a game anthem the division have I
really talked about these games besides
the initial time when we talk about
these games no I don't yeah crazy how
you gonna pay money talks back about a
game you don't care about well his game
that's what the stuff that he like he
don't put up put up with real numbers
we looked at the numbers and what's
going on and we want you to no no we got
together we got a little outfit holding
this I gotta hit oh my God
I got bars for this
Momo isn't this money you'd be throwing
into everyone's uh super chats just just
to hate on them
and plays every expansion
[__] just got better during the course
of this year
yeah you would take an ounce of that
energy you hate on Destiny with and put
that into playing the division you have
another division exactly you're probably
you're busy worrying about Destiny and
not fixing your lopsided terrible game
that ain't got no player base all right
Tom let me finish
I'm late but addict is Right Insomniac
is great making solid eight to eight
point five out of tens in a small amount
of time they're not number one and stop
disrespecting obsidian by comparing them
the obsidian doesn't only make two games
salute the back for that he said he said
you're right [__] I'm running strikes
and Destiny right now I love you brother
you know I'm just covering this all
jokes it's awful but I had this is a
funny strikes in Destiny right now I
know but they complain every day I was
like nah we gotta expose them you the
Travis's the circle slow bowls all y'all
get I'm not letting it slide no more if
I see y'all logging into this game I'm
posting y'all up on Twitter and exposing
that's the new don't put receipts for
y'all get out the game if y'all like it
stop complaining
we got Dustin goings five dollars is
there any way to get into the Xbox show
with Fan Fest is late E3 got canceled
but I would still be in La this would
have been my first E3 oh man oh man I
hate that for you like I'm sorry that's
right these things I I wish they'd be a
little bit more open about getting into
these things but it's not easy like even
for us if we actually have connections
to this like we have a hard time getting
in these things yeah so yeah sorry about
that man that sucks yeah that's why King
and I will not be there
holla at me an addict we're gonna put
pulling up yeah with LA anybody in La
during that time we'll be in L.A yeah
we're gonna be there pretending some
events you know
we got one of the oh geez the original
Lords of the realm Lord zero IL five
dollar Super Chat Capcom stay carrying
everyone
absolute salute zero man oh brother the
original iron Lords that was there from
episode one to 15 like yeah shout out to
zero shout out to my man Laura SWAT too
no doubt let's put the Crush in the chat
for Lord zero IOP welcome Lord bronze
thank you brother appreciate you man no
doubt
oh my God
splendiferous remember for 18 month Lord
bronze well well well I don't recognize
this Colin he's a bit strange today bad
energy rubbing off on you huh you better
stay away from them XBox guys
Sony Bros
oh man
that we have heartbeats the knee once
again five dollar super chat if
PlayStation wants to go games to the
service they have to take shots some
games won't be good it won't happen and
it won't be of good quality a game will
either hit or not like that showcase
that is true no no uh akw in the chat
he's got a Fan Fest ticket in Poland my
polish Lords hit him up he's in the chat
he's for real nice and then both play
again Cali we're gonna be in there we're
gonna I'm gonna let you know just hit me
in the DM I'll give you the dates we're
going to be there it's not the full week
but almost half the week and the weekend
then we got let me see then we got
Raiden blade two pound Super Chat
Spider-Man 2 is on PS4 watch it happen
it'll be very very interesting okay let
me roll back a little bit we got powers
in the chat with a Paris say in the chat
he said the Spiderman Slanders wild who
else besides Insomniac would you trust
was such a major IP like Spidey or
Wolverine he's not feeling that calling
them second classes it's a good solid
wall between Naughty Dog fans you know
it's zodiac fans
then we got Jax 182 2000 attack Cog I
like Destiny and your passion on it
respect look man I I fought to be a
fanboy for that guy
I didn't like the game at first myself
either until I learned it enough
absolutely it's all jokes it's all jokes
slow mo he's been on fire poking the
bear today and he got me out of
character so salute the slow-mo today
you have won the battle today sir
and then we have been in Paris said I
don't have an invite the purpose either
so there you go yeah industry people not
getting butts
um going zero IOP once again five dollar
Super Chat I want to come back on for
the return of Cade y'all I gotta be
there for my bank God so that's right
you a hunter that's right
we all caught up yesterday you go
straight into the final one man it's you
the final topic will make this a quick
one I just thought it was interesting
um yeah so uh we during the uh the
PlayStation showcase we saw more of Alan
Wake too gameplay which look awesome yep
I'm very excited for Alan wig too but a
little bit later on remedy confirmed
that the game would only be releasing on
digital platforms no physical whatsoever
and some people got into a little bit of
a tizzy shout out to Mr Maddie played
today
he wasn't feeling that the preservation
Lords were not happy about this and the
thing is that it's not I mean it's not
all the rumble pie it's not strange
generally to see a game just come out
digital only it is kind of strange for a
game that is this big
um that is on multiple platforms to
decide hey we're just going digital
um and then you know Sam Blake kind of
addressed this and one of the things he
talked about was like hey
um it allows us to keep the price down
right because regardless of uh you know
however little it costs to manufacture
and burn a disc it's still money being
spent so he said it keeps the prices
down it's going to keep it to 59.99 on
console and 49.99 for my the PC Master
race you know I'll be getting it there
you know 49.99
if you buy it on the epic game store
all right listen I have no qualms I'm
not married to steam oh yeah you're a
different guy Gabe has not put a ring on
this I mean a PC masturbates guys I know
only God even steam only listen man I'll
I'll go through I'll go through whatever
launcher you get oh my God
joysticks listening
I'm for the the digital ecosystem talk
about you can be going through anything
and launching ready to be careful
careful all right child protection
I'm for the I'm for the streets
oh salute to Rick you just want that
sticker hold on oh nice nice salute no
doubt all right I got you cut these off
so yeah what do you guys think of this
because this is interesting that a game
this big has decided to do that again
Sam Lake gave some reasons but there are
other reasons as well you could talk
about just the fact that again
we're in a point in time where
everybody's trying to cut Corners
someplace right and the fact that you
don't have to worry about production you
don't have to worry about a box you
don't have to worry about any of that
could be substantial for a game that and
we know this game isn't you know it's a
triple A game kind of in status and and
what we sort of expect from remedy but
this game is
probably cost 50 million dollars to make
or something like that I don't think
it's even reaching 100 million dollars
so uh yeah what do you guys think of
this and what does it kind of it does it
stick one more nail into the coffin of
of physical games because I think we're
getting more closer and closer to a
reality where in the console space we're
gonna have an old digital ecosystem with
everybody and you know for a lot of
people that's scary that's scary so what
do you guys think it's scary and a lot
there's also people who'll be super
vocal but yet when you check their
Library yeah you know what I'm saying
like that's how that's how it be so
is definitely on his way out I don't
know how long we got for physical
um you could say it could be gone by
this generation or at the start of next
but it's I mean Nintendo's all but
embraced this like they don't even give
you a visible game in these clutches
they just give you a cold for the game
and I think Sony uh
did that with one game as well correctly
so I don't know so it's
it's a toss-up and whether or not they
pulled the trigger or not but uh one
thing's for certain though I mean
even if you were someone who just
believed all in digital and you can't
even get your hands on a digital PS5 so
I don't know like it's
yeah I I have I have one of the few that
are in the wild oh you got the job
too that's basically the Unicorn yeah
like I physically never seen one and I
got it at launch wow oh I'm not lucky at
all I don't want to I don't want it
I was lucky I literally got the
notification from uh uh one of the
Twitter guys that was saying hey there's
going to be a drop and I I was coming
home from uh Jiu Jitsu class I'm on the
side of the highway because the time hit
when that was gonna happen and I got my
way into Best Buy and got my digital PS5
it was crazy wow it's like like
solve got no chill with stuff oh yeah
he's a beast oh he's a beast I I will
never forget that that Xbox series X
thing oh yeah like I was like he was
like oh he's like I I'm not getting mine
for a week I'm like okay he's like can
your brother go with you because that I
was doing like the little oh yeah wait
outside and I was like I was like I
don't know he's like pay him and then I
obviously right there is enough for my
brother he's like yeah sure and then
goes in there and I I get the console
and then I'm sitting there and I'm like
okay like um you know they said it's
gonna be like a buck 50 just to
overnight that too don't care send it
when the iron bank give us the goal
I was not he's very hard with us man
listen I I have very little time to play
games when I set aside time for
something if you want to do that thing
the right I feel like so and I'm great
again like I said that you know tell me
if you've heard this before I work a lot
of damn hours yeah
so yeah yeah that was and then the
PlayStation yeah listen man PlayStation
bro
I could not get a pre-order for for
launch I was not able to get to GameStop
I went right to I went right to eBay and
looked for local sellers that have have
a history of of positive sales no shy
students whatever and I found a kid that
had he had uh he had already sold out of
his disc one and all he had was a
digital so you brought legit for
mascouture
you know it's crazy
at that time
it was probably cheaper for you to play
Zachary because what's crazy is you you
paid them in snacks too that's that's
the sad part exactly what exactly he I
was like oh he's like yeah because I was
like because I determined the prize I
even asked I'm like just said about
extra 100. he literally went to Walmart
next door and bought a bunch of snacks
wow yeah so yeah and that PlayStation
cost me a thousand dollars
it was probably cheaper for you to do
that I agree and to pay the 150
overnight it would be to buy that on on
eBay or anything like that yeah so but
that's where you at with it you just
feel like I guess um the for them what
about for them saying they bringing it
down by doing the auditional this avoids
the set you know the dreaded seventy
dollars and and then you know do you
agree with that or are you worried about
this kind of sliding into dangerous
territory with the physical game the
whole seventy dollar thing uh going down
I believe when I see it I don't think
that's going anywhere even with digital
at all at this this point it's been very
like a lot of we've talked about this
whole time there's been a lot of
companies have been notorious for giving
you very little they're asking you for
more yeah I don't see that mentality
dying with just like physical by itself
going away no that's still going to be
apparent you're gonna have those sheisty
um I call it Shy sleep you got those
business modules where you know they're
just gonna give you very little and
expect you to pay the most especially
for these clutch Edition you want an
example of this look at Gotham Knights
got tonight's a prime example of this
the game had little content right you
got some now but had a little content no
performance molds or whatnot and it was
just a broken mess at lunch and they
were selling a digital Deluxe or
whatever Ultimate Edition for God knows
how much
um yeah man that that that's just the
reality now and the funny thing is
remember at the start of the Xbox one
generation we're like oh digital games
then you know we don't have to worry
about paying for the box or anything
like that we're gonna get so many deals
up front when it comes to like you know
if they might do like a pre-order you
get like an extra five dollars off or
something like that but I will say
because digital got so dominant we're
seeing more like frequent like sells on
games in general sure they're not new
but I I do think that because things are
so much more accessible when it comes to
internet I'll give you that that these
developers and Publishers they're okay
with putting their game with that deep
discount like like two months later I
agree I agree don't you just probably
quicker to get the sale first you know
morning thing but but I do remember
though and then remember there was that
talk solve about you know and Dan we're
gonna have a digital storefront use like
remember because people were so worried
about used gays remember that yeah they
were like now we're gonna have it so you
could trade in your use
digital game didn't they didn't they
have like a like a a survey asking
I don't know like I don't I definitely
know it wasn't PlayStation PlayStations
don't even have gifting like yeah I know
you have wish listing but they don't
have gifting yeah they can make sense
I'm with y'all they need gifting did you
notice that was in a lot of the the
videos on the Showcase
the console uh Cog that takes away from
the cells
you know you know they'll be weirdos say
something stupid
so so they think that like if someone
gets me a game that they don't get those
sales
that takes away from the down
that's different different like I've
never heard that wow yeah big cloud we
gotta get you out the hood man I told
you guys stop playing in the whole ride
gotta get away from these people that
you're talking to I'd be away or just
what you heard
it listen man
this Hood life is too much gang banging
his whole body
when it comes to me like with this like
digital stuff like I think the limited
runs is loving this right because it's
like I feel like they're you're gonna
have these companies work more with the
Publishers and stuff because I do feel
like you'll pay a little bit more but I
do think you can get that physical copy
and I think there's going to be more and
more companies going forward that once
they start dialing back to physical
sales they're gonna pick up their
business
um you know I don't think it's gonna be
every game I I but I do think there's
going to be like a lot of prominent like
Xbox games Nintendo switch games
Playstation games you know certain third
party I do think there will be companies
you could reach out to and get that
physical company that physical car
people you have to pay more money
this is like GameStop in the future that
is GameStop can like convert around in
the future
they're just trying to get Funko Pops in
there and gaming memorabilia I mean
that's like the problem is at this rate
GameStop is turning into Hot Topic you
need to see it but it's like some random
so much random stuff it's in their store
it's like you have to look through the
store to find the games now
you gotta they got to reinvent
themselves and then yeah yeah the change
I've seen is now like the pre-order
remember for like you go in there and
there'll be copies of whatever like all
right now it's like if you didn't
pre-order like it is no guarantee for
you that kind of energy so I see the
change I want to get Darren win on this
you know what's your thoughts on the
whole island weight uh two digital
situation digital only situation are you
concerned or you know this way it's
going where you think
so for me unfortunately and I respect
the folks that do care but I'm not one
that's big on the gaming historian stuff
um
sorry Maddie uh I'm I'm Mr lazy I just
want to go tap my thing my game comes up
and I'm playing my game
store in yo volumes and discs uh for
wherever so yeah I mean the the key in
and kind of the point I I think bitclub
was the one that said this is they're
still going to try and charge us 70
bucks for this
um do you remember when Vita came out
and the whole that whole thing with vita
where they're like hey if you buy it
digitally we're gonna knock some off for
that because we don't have the the money
and the production of the of the Chip
And the shipping of it and all that fun
stuff and then that died real quick
um so yeah he I think big clothes 100 on
this they're going to start charging
like we might get out and wait two for
60 bucks
um but yeah it's it's rapidly
because we're all ready
because we're already paying 70 bucks
for digital games as it is so why would
they change and I think I forget the
stat that I heard but it might have been
on sacred symbols but like 70 of games
sold now or digital already yeah so
disparities we're already 70 of the way
there no that's a good point yeah I
don't I don't have any any cons sorry I
don't I don't have any concerns about it
myself it's just where it's going to go
um for the folks that are trying to
preserve uh it's gonna be rough
um so the point about women Run games I
think they got their own problems
already with what they already have
because I'm talking about Maddie I know
he waited a long long long long time for
one of his most recent uh games to get
doing so I think they they they uh while
this bodes well for them I think they
already got more business than they can
handle as it is so yeah good point and I
do I'll jump in I do think the fact that
epic is the publisher here is kind of
you know helping that part out as far as
this particular one just not meeting
having to be 70 but um yeah I'm kind of
with you there like attacking me the
laziness in me you know what I mean like
I I as much as I love the Nostalgia the
only thing I will miss is like that
Collector's Edition version of something
I really love I do like the support in
that way so in a sense I'll buy it I
still have those you also have those I'm
pretty sure you'll have the steel book
we just won't be done in it you know
yeah
it's already talking about yeah like as
long as they keep that you know
preservation alive I'm okay but you know
look that's where we are that's where
the generation is going on I'm a techie
at my heart at my core you know when
things transition into a different
direction and I'm generally the person
that's going to be most likely for it
unless it's some Supreme drawback that I
I can't see but I do want to defend my
co-host Maddie on one thing the only
thing that concerns me when we shift to
this era is the storefront owners
because the store for our owners in any
event or any reason
something can get pulled from a
storefront is scary
for whatever reason and plus people
don't realize how much power they have
to yeah and it's like if if that happens
you know with a beloved game which you
know and you're like damn it's it's all
it's on mostly like right now we've been
seeing it happen with games we don't
really care about you know what I'm
saying oh Crossfire actually shut down
yeah get rid of it like you know that
kind of thing but it's like but
sometimes it's those classic joints and
you're like man I wish I could go back
to that and there's no way to go back to
it or if because your Marvel game that
you yeah you read my mind I was just
about to say it give kaibots was in the
chat what killed me is Marvel heroes now
granted it's special case because it was
an online only game anyway so those tend
to not be preserved but I just think of
situations like that with some legal or
something crazy happens and the studio
the game shut down all the license or
whatever shut down there's no way for
you to play it that part is a little
scary and that that's the only thing
about the future that I do want to be
cognizant of and respectful of but I
think eventually what's going to happen
yeah that you know I think the more and
more that we are in a digital era you're
going to see like
that you're going to see like
governments start to regulate the
industry there'll be regulations yeah
yeah because it's like you can't just
pull something just because you sold it
digitally like yeah it's gonna what was
the game recently where they did yeah
the whole thing the whole game the whole
thing it was a single player game what
was that was it cyberpunk talking about
cyber no no no no no they get
discontinued they pulled it oh I'm the
servers and the game
they've pulled Horizon games off the
store because of uh licensing issues you
remember I remember they just pulled
even though it came back Quantum break
was pulled off remember yeah
kind of did and we now he explained it
but you could still get to that like if
you previously downloaded that like you
know yeah so you're right no you're
right you're absolutely right you're
absolutely right that is there was
something I wish I could remember what
it was but there was a game here
recently where they shut down the
servers and not only names two days
three Ninja Turtles La Lucius Augustus
he I think he's right I think he's right
I think it was like the steam version I
think Maddie was talking about it and
the surge was pulled as well from
people's team libraries yeah really yeah
it's crazy yeah that's the scary part
that's not it yeah you got this big
Library you woke up and you're like I
can't play this anymore for you know I
don't socialize with uh you know the the
PC oh fellas
I don't know what happens over there in
PC land
very big Advocate on not giving the PC
Terrace their ways so the funny thing is
that sound do your point about the
special good no no I'm just gonna say I
was just saying Flack no no you go you
go you go go go there I just say you're
to your point about the special edition
I bought one special edition in my life
but speaking about a Sonic and Sonic
earlier if they if they come oh they
come with that we'll really go with that
they got something with Wolverine yeah
then I'm gonna be in on it
most of the time I you know when we
review few games and stuff uh solve just
simply that digital when that Fable one
I'm like I might need the collectors
collectors come on when it's not my love
love why should be a black and white PS4
just watch they do that with hostage
some cherry blossoms it's over
so yeah real quick like for Sam Lake
caught some Flack because he said
something like oh yeah we'd also don't
want I don't know if Sam like
particularly just a spokesperson for him
but he was like yeah uh we also don't
want you know we we think you know
having to get a disc based game and then
have to download something is not
something that people want to do it's
like well but you're telling us to just
download the whole game thing like it's
a so the download's still happening
right so I think even people they're
having problems like even coming up with
arguments like that that are going to
appease the people that really want the
physical stuff so yeah I think it's it's
definitely in the Death Rows now for
sure we start seeing bigger games that
are on multiple platforms not just on
steam or whatever the case like yeah
it's
it's kind of a wrap I think much like
much like everything Nintendo will be
the last to fall on that probably yeah
they'll probably survive it that's the
sad part yeah
and my and my dumb ass went full digital
with switched that was the dumbest
decision I've ever made I shouldn't have
been on that right now yeah I shouldn't
have went digitally so I was I did with
a couple but my SD card what happened
crap though my SD card reader bit the
dust on me on my switch so I had to buy
tears of the Kingdom physical because I
didn't have any choice and I'm sure as
heck wasn't buying another switch
knowing that it's six years old and
there's about to be another one really
at any minute no I feel that I feel that
so like times are changing that's what
we got yeah let's get these super chats
yes Atticus addict is ready
um
all right with the reset PlayStation
showcase not receiving overwhelming
positive reviews which aspect has you
the most concern choices are a lack of
first party presence B High Life
Services live service game Focus C CGH
CGI trailers and minimal release dates
or D I don't care Xbox showcase better
that step order rate
shut up
yeah was combined in the first one the
choice a so those are the voices gonna
go up on Twitter so I'll get these super
chats then we do outros
Let's see we got an
okay Lord Metroid member for one year
two dollars which I only weighed 260 on
Console digital what a deal
yes all that extra money's going into
their pocket not yours Robert Kelly two
dollar Super Chat can't wait for it to
be delisted in three years
wow wow
five dollar Super Chat Paris oh he's
talking about
Paris naughty dog or even Sucker Punch
can make Spider-Man but insomnia
couldn't make the Last of Us Part Two
Stand Down damn we're going hard for
them
I will say this though I've seen other
people Spider-Man what's that one big
cloud where they had the zuba hips and
the in the basket that was that was
marvelous when they was doing it
remember they was doing this
with the electric company I don't know
if you want somebody else other than
yeah
[Laughter]
you don't want the addicts ready
you guys be playing Diablo 4 why yes
it's funny we just talked about uh
paying for digital Deluxe versions that
give you extra things I just bought uh
the digital Deluxe person it allows me
uh Early Access
oh how privileged of you I kind of like
who you're supposed to play Zelda
exactly exactly I'll be trying to play
on Friday
as best we can again salute everybody
that pulled up again for a start with
our very special patreon guest Lord
daring won amazing amazing gaming
history gamer through and through Lord
of I.T in the building and of course
great takes today where can the fine
people find you what you got going on
sir
if you want to hear more of my nonsense
uh you can find me at daring1 on Twitter
uh if you're interested in EVS electric
cars and Tesla and that type of stuff uh
we're in a Tesla podcast for about five
and a half years at teslatidbits.com
Tesla tidbits on Twitter
um talking about uh
um Maddie's been talking about your
guys's uh ratings on uh on Duke I had at
one point had that in the top five of
Automotive podcasts on iTunes so nice
pretty proud of that but life got in the
way so no more podcasting for me oh good
but I still do have plenty of takes on
EVs and such on that on that account on
Twitter Philadelphia
you killed it brother you did today
you're super comfortable y'all have fun
really enjoyed it very inspiring and
humbling the things that you said you
know in reference to ILP so my uh super
love to you too brother my honor uh to
be on on the show with you guys it's
been great listening to you guys and
even better
definitely said his apologies because he
said brother I've never missed a picture
I guess don't listen to King
you know he would have been here
especially this week he wanted to be
everybody's ready people was ready to do
the coronation for king that's how this
was already a five-hour show I think
imagine oh God it would have been yeah
we'd have broke records
and of course my Brad trade log that's
all in rgt podcast and host and creator
of the big cloud gaming
YouTube channel and everything man so
salute to you brother always hard work
it always intelligent content where can
the people find you what you got going
on Yeah man they shot me it's always fun
hanging out everybody it's good to see
Sav addicts you of course too bad King
couldn't be here he's gonna bend the
knee today
nice to meet you Darren it was cool
talking uh you know obviously bad bit
Colin that was awesome yeah shout out to
you for for that uh Kai it was awesome
um you know you guys find me big cloud
gaming Everywhere YouTube twitch Twitter
uh you guys want to see the rgt we oh we
had hip-hop game wrong we had a fun
breakdown of uh of that showcase and
then you know me and red hood 420 that's
my mother we literally just uh well we
dismantled
I bet you I did you know Buster you
Durant I did on as well so yeah I
dropped a lot uh last week but uh yeah
man a lot of stuff planned uh you guys
should find me also a lagnet
um yeah I've wrote fewer I wrote One
review so far loved it everybody got a
lot of good feedback from it so a lot a
lot of those in store got a lot of other
things we're gonna set up for and um
yeah man I appreciate everybody Real
Talk shot uh real-time shout out to you
uh Cog man you always always been a real
one I appreciate you what you do for the
community you always show love to
everybody and uh you know we had over
you know you had over a thousand people
here wow Non-Stop and I just it goes
back to what I told you before when you
put good into the world good come back
come back good come back Darren one made
me sometimes I forget and then there was
some words that really touched me and I
was like wow you know what I'm saying
like it means a lot it means a lot you
know I'm saying again I don't knock
anybody for doing any hustle how they
want to do it but you know how we do it
and to see the love come back that's
what validates it you know I'm saying
that's what makes us go harder and I
appreciate what you said it's too
brother you're a tremendous talent I
love I get the opportunity to work with
you there the Lord's game you know what
I'm saying and your journey and what
you've been doing with with PlayStation
content and Playstation interview
is is unparalleled keep up the good work
keep your head up and uh yeah man we got
more fun stuff cooking you know saying
it don't stop I want to salute again the
legends that pulled up my man Mr badvin
from the trophy room so little brother
always fun to have you and of course the
legend himself Long Island Viper's own
kalamori already pulled up thanks for
y'all for being mostly respectful
it was I think it was a vocal but now
yeah they were finished pretty good you
know I think I think you know there's
people that clearly have their own
opinion and you know what I noticed that
really big ones was Jada like yeah we
had j-dub on the
reactions people I saw a lot of also at
the end that was okay maybe I was wrong
about Jay's uh maybe I should actually
unblock him listen again we all gonna
have our opinions we all not gonna agree
just
people say they don't like don't like
Smooth they like Jerry
is it
doing all type of stuff today yeah
different languages
Spanish
they want you to whisper the yeah they
want you to whisper ads for somebody
they like where's the Westbank I find
that very uncomfortable
no one do the ASMR with it so some of
these people got headsets you want
another man to whisper
some people really love song My My the
first honey read that I did when I tried
to do the honey thing yeah it was like
it was like who knows you can hear it
yeah when I was in the car I couldn't
hear that at all right so now I was like
no I'm not gonna do that anymore so my
apologies maybe we'll set up a patreon
tip oh yes
but yeah
[Laughter]
oh yeah it was it was a fun show
um I'm excited for this coming week I
don't know how much I'll get to play but
we got Street Fighter six yeah
and we got Diablo four coming together
it's good but you know I'm all about the
technique oh yeah look crazy they dry
yeah that new Brian
oh she killed him
[Laughter]
no I'm gonna rock with him of course but
I'm gonna try to go back to main and
King man I wanna oh that's what I wanna
see I I'm mad at you not that we because
I felt like Brian was the the you know
the sexy new thing on the Block and
everybody wanted but it's like you your
sense of King is super top team this is
the thing though yeah I have the main
King I haven't really made King since
Tekken three yes because that was that
was where he got that he was able to get
more more offense right apart from just
grabs
um but yeah now he's a beast now in
every ass every aspect I'm gonna go back
to Camp okay then you got the kick
reverse okay it's all right
we need more though you're right we
needed we need an IOP Dojo read the I'll
be dojo fgc you don't say get maybe he
can't qualificate begging them anyway
it's a patreon tier probably fast for
that not here you're trying to time
we're trying to time gate us they score
they expose you today yeah the likes the
cake was on time release they calling us
the battle pass podcast anyway all right
he's going to sleep anyway so look
everybody thank y'all for coming through
this was a fun show obviously
um shout out to everybody that pulled up
the chat y'all was phenomenal we got uh
probably like one or two more shows we
got the Xbox show next week yeah Xbox
shows next week's another another big
one and um yeah I think it's Gonna Fill
my rap oh yeah yeah no wrecks y'all no
race no rake energy please cause we
don't need that but um yeah appreciate
y'all appreciate y'all for stepping
through the um the reads and all that
having fun with us on that attic you got
something to say and how the show's
gonna go when me and Cog are gone is uh
kids movies actually gonna show up and
he's going to uh host the reaction so
you guys still get the reaction action
it's just uh me and [__] are going to
try to jump in it just depends on what's
going on at the event I we don't know
currently if we'll be able to just like
leave and and do something like that but
we'll try so yeah again just for clarity
we're going to have a bunch it's still
going to be two Lords here on the day of
the Showcase not next week though I'll
be coming in hot though
so King and Tom potentially you know
will still there you'll get Kings so
y'all should be happy yeah
y'all get King you know whatever next
week we'll do the prediction show on the
weekend and then the week so the week
after the prediction show again me and
attic will be out there in LA for the
showcases and stuff like that I'm gonna
try to give some extra perspective give
y'all some extra content and stuff like
that but man MJ is everything else like
that so salute everybody enjoy your
Sunday appreciate y'all rocking with us
yeah I'm sending you guys over the
Jamaican gamer man streamer really
trying he's a he's actually really good
at Call of Duty I wish he would carry me
through some of that stuff I don't play
it too much go there tell me
hit that like button for your exit the
stream but I appreciate you guys uh for
coming through oh I got it we got
another Super Chat yeah
I didn't yeah okay there was one more
Super Chat
we have King's joystick is missing
five pound super check big boy with a
burst this evening oh miss my chocolate
tip banana whoa whoa whoa sir
time on you sir keep it together anyway
he said we so shady we got a bunch of
King memes in here
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]